BUDGETS. UPCOMING NUMBER THREE,
UM WILL COMMENCE. ALL RIGHT.
HELLO EVERYONE. GOOD MORNING.
FOR THOSE WHO WERE TUNED IN WITH
MY DRIVING SAGA FROM LAST WEEK.
IT WAS THE LONGEST DRIVE I'VE
HAD TO DO EVER EVEN THOUGH WE
GOT OUT HERE IN A LOT ON A GOOD
TIME. UM SO THIS TIME I DON'T
HAVE TO DRIVE SO WE CAN BE HERE
TILL 10 P.M. SO I'M VERY EXCITED
ABOUT THAT. LAST FLIGHT OUT TO
LAX IS 1125. SO WE'RE OK. UH, SO
WITH THAT WE HAVE A, UH, THREE
DIFFERENT DEPARTMENTS THAT ARE
GONNA BE PRESENTING TO, UH, THIS
SUBCOMITTEE WE'RE GONNA BE
HEARING FROM THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES,
DEPARTMENT OF COMMUNITY SERVICES
AND DEVELOPMENT AND CALIFORNIA'S
DEPARTMENT ON AGING. AH, WE WILL
BE DOING THE SAME THING WE DID
LAST WEEK WHERE WE GET PUBLIC
COMMENT AFTER EACH DEPARTMENT. I
THINK IT WENT VERY, VERY
SMOOTHLY LAST WEEK, AND WE'LL
CONTINUE IN, UH, IN THAT ORDER.
SO WE WILL ASK A Dð F IN LAO TO
GET COMFY UP IN THE WELL, PLEASE
. AND THEN I WILL ASK THE
ADMINISTRATION TO START US OFF
WITH DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES.
OUR FIRST ISSUE UP IS GOING TO
BE ON THE CHILDCARE RATE REFORM.
WE'RE GOING TO FIRST HEAR FROM L
A Ó AND WE'LL DIVE ON INTO THE
REST OF OUR PANELISTS. TODAY
WE'RE GONNA BE HEARING FROM THE
DEPARTMENT. UM, WE HAVE SOMEONE
FROM THE EARLY CARE AND
EDUCATION COALITION WORK CAN
HAVE SOMEONE FROM THE èC PU AND
THEN TO FIND FINANCE WILL CLOSE
US OFF. WELCOME BACK AGAIN.
JACKIE BARROSO WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST OFFICE. WE
WERE ASKED TO, UM WALK THROUGH
THE ALTERNATIVE RATE METHODOLOGY
, TIMELINES AND MILESTONES THAT
WERE CODIFIED AS A PART OF THE
2324 BUDGET ACT THROUGH S¼ B 140
. BUT BEFORE I GO OVER THE
TIMELINE, I DO FIRST WANNA
PROVIDE KIND OF A QUICK, HIGH
LEVEL OVERVIEW OF PRIOR WORK
THAT WAS DONE, UM, TO DEVELOP A
SINGLE RATE REIMBURSEMENT. UM,
STRUCTURE THAT THE TIMELINE THEN
BUILDS UPON, UM, SPECIFICALLY IN
2021. UM THE LEGISLATURE
RATIFIED THE AGREEMENT THAT WAS
REACHED BETWEEN THE STATE AND
THE CHILD CARE PROVIDERS. UNITED
UNION, UM, THAT INCLUDED THE
CREATION OF THE JOINT LABOR
MANAGEMENT COMMITTEE, AND THAT
COMMITTEE WAS SPECIFICALLY
TASKED WITH DEVELOPING A SINGLE,
UM, REIMBURSEMENT RATE STRUCTURE
. AND THEN IN NOVEMBER, 2022,
THE JOINT LABOR MANAGEMENT
COMMITTEE, OR JL. M èC, UM,
RELEASED ITS RECOMMENDATIONS ON
HOW TO STRUCTURE AN ALTERNATIVE
SINGLE REIMBURSEMENT RATE.
INCLUDED UM DEVELOPING RATES
BASED OFF OF A MODEL THAT
ESTIMATES THE TRUE COST OF
PROVIDING CHILD CARE SERVICES,
INCLUDING BASE RATES THAT ARE
TAILORED TO EACH PROGRAM SETTING
, UM AND CURRENT RULES AND
REGULATIONS, UM AND THEN ALSO
ALLOWING FOR RATE ENHANCEMENTS
AND INCENTIVES. IN ADDITION, THE
JL M èC RECOMMENDED THAT THE
SINGLE RATE STRUCTURE BE
EVALUATED BASED OFF OF CERTAIN
EQUITY AND PROCESS METRICS. SO
WITH THESE JLM èC
RECOMMENDATIONS THEY REALLY
SERVE THEN AS THE STARTING POINT
FOR THE ALTERNATIVE METHODOLOGY,
TIMELINE AND MILESTONES THAT
WERE ADOPTED LAST YEAR THROUGH
SB 140. IN TERMS OF WHERE WE ARE
TODAY, THE CURRENT MILESTONE
THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES ARE DESS IS WORKING ON
IS COLLABORATING WITH THE JLM
èC TO DEFINE ELEMENTS OF BASE
RATES AND ANY ENHANCEMENTS FOR
THE PURPOSES OF INFORMING A
POTENTIAL SINGLE RATE STRUCTURE,
AND THESE ELEMENTS WOULD BE
SUBJECT TO THE MANDATED PUBLIC
ENGAGEMENT, UM, STATE PLAN
PROCESS AND LEGISLATIVE REVIEW.
AND THEN ONCE THAT WORK IS
COMPLETED, UM THE DEPARTMENT,
UH, WILL, UH, PROVIDE AN UPDATE
TO THE LEGISLATURE ON PROGRESS
MADE THUS FAR. UM THE DEPARTMENT
WAS SUPPOSED TO COMPLETE, UM,
REACHING THOSE DEFINITIONS IN
COLLABORATION WITH THE JLM èC
BY FEBRUARY 15TH. HOWEVER OUR
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT Dð S¼ S¼
IS STILL ACTIVELY WORKING ON
COMPLETING THAT. IN TERMS OF THE
NEXT MILESTONES THAT WOULD
FOLLOW. UM THOSE, UH DEF, UM,
LANDING ON THE DEFINITIONS. UM
OUR UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THE
JLM èC SINCE IT WAS CREATED OUT
OF THE UNION, UM, IT PRIMARILY
IS FOCUSED ON FAMILY BASED
PROVIDERS. SO THEN WE WOULD ALSO
HAVE TO CAPTURE THE CENTER BASED
PROVIDER PERSPECTIVE AND THE
DEPARTMENT WOULD SEEK, UM,
FEEDBACK THAT SPECIFIC TO THE
CENTER BASED PROVIDER. UM,
STRUCTURE COST MODEL AND RATE
ELEMENTS. UM, THIS MARCH, 2024.
AND THE NEXT MILESTONE THAT'S
OUTLINED IN STATUTE IS BY MAY
15TH 2024. THE DEPARTMENT IS
REQUIRED TO REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE ON THE STATUS OF THE
DRAFT CHILDCARE AND DEVELOPMENT
FUNDING STATE PLAN, THEN BY JULY
, 1 2024. THE DEPARTMENT IS
REQUIRED TO SUBMIT A REVISED
STATE PLAN TO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT THAT INCLUDES THE
NECESSARY INFORMATION TO SUPPORT
THE USE OF A NEW SINGLE RATE
STRUCTURE FOR ALL CHILDCARE
PROVIDERS. AND THEN WITHIN 60
DAYS OF THAT SUBMISSION OR
WITHIN 60. IS OF THE FEDERAL
APPROVAL OF THAT STATE PLAN THAT
SUBMITTED THE DEPARTMENT THEN
SHALL PROVIDE BOTH THE UNION AND
THE LEGISLATURE WITH AN OUTLINE
OF IMPLEMENTATION COMPONENTS,
AND THEN THE UNION AND
LEGISLATURE WOULD HAVE 30 DAYS
TO PROVIDE FEEDBACK. WITHIN 90
DAYS OF FEDERAL APPROVAL. UM THE
CURRENT M Ó U AGREEMENT THAT'S
IN PLACE WILL BE REOPENED, UM,
FOR BOTH THE UNION AND THE
ADMINISTRATION TO NEGOTIATE.
THEN HOW DO WE RESTRUCTURE RATES
BASED OFF OF THIS ALTERNATIVE
METHODOLOGY FOR FAMILY BASED
PROVIDERS AGAIN AND THEN, UM, A
PARALLEL PROCESS WOULD OCCUR, UM
, FOR CENTER BASED PROVIDERS
CONCURRENT WITH AND INFORMED BY
THAT M Ó U PROCESS AND THAT
WOULD OCCUR THROUGH THE NORMAL
ANNUAL BUDGET PROCESS. UM, ONE
THING THAT I DEFINITELY I
CLARIFY IS WITH REGARDS TO THAT
JULY 1 2024 SUBMISSION DATE THAT
DOES NOT NECESSARILY MEAN RATES
WILL BE IMPLEMENTED BY JULY. 1
2024. IT REALLY IS JUST THE
DEADLINE TO SUBMIT THE STATE
PLAN TO THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT ACTUALLY
GIVES STATES UP TO JULY 1 2025
TO IMPLEMENT, UM, RATES BASED
OFF OF THIS ALTERNATIVE
METHODOLOGY AND S¼ B 140 DOESN'T
SPECIFY AN IMPLEMENTATION DATE.
SO WE BELIEVE THAT THE STATE
LIKELY WOULD NEED THOSE 12
MONTHS TO LAND ON KEY
IMPLEMENTATION DETAILS LIKE WHAT
IS THE PHASED IN APPROACH
ASSOCIATED FUNDING THINGS LIKE
THAT, UM, THAT WOULD OCCUR
NORMALLY THROUGH THE M Ó U
PROCESS AND THE ANNUAL BUDGET
PROCESS. UM SO WITH THAT I'M
HAPPY TO PASS IT OVER TO THE
OTHER PANELISTS. THANK YOU SO
MUCH, JACKIE. UM HØI. WELCOME
BACK, SIR. SIR THANK YOU SO MUCH
. GOOD MORNING. MADAM CHAIR,
SENATOR ROTH KI¾M. JOHNSON
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES,
AND JUST GRATEFUL TO BE ABLE TO
HAVE THIS OPPORTUNITY TO GIVE
YOU AN UPDATE ON THIS WORK AND
REALLY BUILDING ON THE
INVESTMENTS THAT THE GOVERNOR
AND LEGISLATURE HAVE MADE
HISTORIC INVESTMENTS OVER THE
PAST FEW YEARS. WE'RE GLAD TO BE
MOVING FROM ENVISIONING A SINGLE
RATE STRUCTURE TO ACTUALLY
TAKING THE STEPS NEEDED TO
IMPLEMENT THIS NEW SYSTEM. THE
COMMITTEE HAS ASKED US FOR AN
UPDATE ON THE FOLLOWING ITEMS,
ONE THE FEDERAL GUIDANCE AND
REQUIREMENTS FOR MOVING TO THIS
ALTERNATIVE METHODOLOGY TO SET
RATES, A DESCRIPTION OF THE COST
MODEL AND HOW IT FUNCTIONS,
INCLUDING THE ELEMENTS OF THE
BASE RATE AND ENHANCED RATES AND
THE PROGRESS THAT WE'VE MADE
TODAY, INCLUDING THE SUBMISSION
OF THE UPDATE TO THE LEGISLATURE
, SO I'LL START WITH THE FEDERAL
GUIDANCE. THE ADMINISTRATION FOR
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES REQUIRES
STATES TO COLLECT DATA FROM THE
CHILDCARE AND DEVELOPMENT
PROVIDERS AND PROGRAMS TO INFORM
THE CHILD CARE SUBSIDY RATE
SETTING. TWO YEARS OF SUBMITTING
THAT STATE PLAN THAT WAS JUST
REFERENCED BY THE L A Ó,
CALIFORNIA, LIKE MOST STATES
HAVE HISTORICALLY USED A MARKET
RATE APPROACH TO MEET THIS
REQUIREMENT. AND AS YOU AGENDA
OUTLINES, THE ADMINISTRATION AND
LEGISLATURE HAVE AGREED TO
UTILIZE AN ALTERNATIVE
METHODOLOGY TO INFORM SUBSIDY
RATE SETTING. IS REQUIRED TO PRE
APPROVE ANY STATE PROPOSAL TO
PURSUE THIS ALTERNATIVE
METHODOLOGY. AND IN MARCH OF
LAST YEAR, THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES SUBMITTED THIS
PROPOSAL TO A èC F, AND THAT
PROPOSAL WAS FORMALLY APPROVED
BY THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IN
AUGUST OF LAST YEAR. A ISSUED A
LETTER IN AUGUST ALSO THAT
CLARIFIED EXPECTATIONS FOR THIS
JULY 1 OF THIS YEAR'S SUBMITTAL
OF THE STATE PLAN FOR STATES
THAT ARE MOVING TO THE COST
BASED METHOD. THE GUIDANCE
RECOGNIZED THAT STATES
TRANSITIONING TO THIS
ALTERNATIVE METHODOLOGY MIGHT
NOT HAVE ENOUGH TIME TO COMPLETE
ALL ASSOCIATED ACTIVITIES BY
JULY, 1 OF 2024 AND GRANTED
THOSE STATES FLEXIBILITY ON
TIMELINES SUBJECT TO CERTAIN
CONDITIONS. UH, THAT THOSE
CONDITIONS INCLUDE THAT, UM, THE
PLAN THAT WE DO SUBMIT IN JULY
OF THIS YEAR HAS TO HAVE A
STATUS UPDATE ON THE ALTERNATIVE
METHODOLOGY, A TIMELINE BY WHICH
THE ALTERNATIVE METHODOLOGY
ACTIVITIES WILL BE CONDUCTED ANY
COMPLETED STEPS TO DATE
ANTICIPATED DATE OF COMPLETION
AND EXPECTED DATE, NEW RATES
WILL BE IN EFFECT. IT ALSO
REQUIRES STATES TO CONTINUE TO
PRIORITIZE PAYMENT RATE
INCREASES AS PART OF THE STATE
STRATEGY TO ENSURE EQUAL ACCESS
TO CHILD CARE FOR ALL ELIGIBLE
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES AND
INCREASED PAYMENT RATES ADJUSTED
FOR INFLATION. IT ALSO REQUIRES
COMPLETION OF ALL REQUIRED DATA
COLLECTION ANALYSIS AND
SUBMITTING THE DETAILED REPORT
AND SETTING PAYMENT RATES. BASED
ON THE METHODOLOGY AS THE L A Ó
REFERENCED NÓ LATER THAN JULY. 1
OF 2025. I WOULD ALSO NOTE THAT,
UM LEAD AGENCIES THE STATES, UH,
WITH AN APPROVED ALTERNATIVE
METHODOLOGY BY MARCH ONE. THAT
INCLUDES US, UM, AGREED TO THESE
TERMS AND ARE NOT REQUIRED TO
ALSO CONDUCT A MARKET RATE
SURVEY. IN OTHER WORDS, WE'RE
ABLE TO CONTINUE WITH THIS
ALTERNATIVE COST MODEL THAT
WE'RE WORKING TOWARDS AND NOT
HAVE TO DO THE PRIOR PROCESSES
THAT WE'VE DONE IN THE PAST AND
WE ARE ON TRACK FOR THE JULY 1
SUBMISSION TO INCLUDE ALL OF
THOSE ELEMENTS AS OUTLINED SO
THE COST MODEL. WHAT ARE WHAT
HAVE WE BEEN DOING? AND WHAT
DOES IT LOOK LIKE? JUST AGAIN.
THE COST ESTIMATION MODEL
GENERATES A BENCHMARK REGARDING
COSTS. IT'S A TOOL TO UNDERSTAND
THE COST OF PROVIDING SERVICES,
WHICH ESTIMATES THE COST OF
PROVIDING SERVICES ALIGNED WITH
WHAT THE PROGRAMS ARE CHARGING,
IDENTIFIES THE GAP BETWEEN THEIR
COSTS AND REVENUE SOURCES. AND
IT USES MULTIPLE DATA SOURCES
AND POINTS WHICH ARE DRIVEN BY
THE SELECTIONS THAT WE HAVE IN
THE TOOL. IT'S A TOOL THAT WE
ARE USING. UH, THE COST MODEL
AND ELEMENTS OF THE STRUCTURE
ARE NOT THE SAME AS ACTUAL RATE
SETTING. WE WILL USE THE MODEL
TO INFORM OUR RATE SETTING
PROCESS. SO BETWEEN JULY AND
NOVEMBER OF LAST YEAR, THE
DEPARTMENT COLLABORATED WITH OUR
PRIMARY CONSULTANT PRENATAL TO
FIVE FISCAL STRATEGIES ON PUBLIC
ENGAGEMENT, DATA COLLECTION AND
DEVELOPING THE MODEL. DURING THE
PUBLIC ENGAGEMENT PHASE. UH, WE
CONSULTED AND ENGAGED WITH MANY,
MANY DIFFERENT INTERESTED
PARTIES AND REPRESENTATIVES, UH
THROUGHOUT THE FIELD, UM, AND
DURING THE DATA COLLECTION PHASE
OF THE WORK, UM, WE HAVE
CONDUCTED AN ONLINE SURVEY. UH
THAT SOUGHT TO UNDERSTAND
CURRENT PROGRAM COSTS AND HOW
THEY DIFFER BY COUNTY BY
PROVIDER TYPE CHARACTERISTICS OF
CHILDREN AND FAMILY SERVED CHILD
AGE SERVED AND COMMUNITY NEED.
THE SURVEY WAS ADMINISTERED IN
SEVEN LANGUAGES AND HAD A TOTAL
OF 9250 RESPONDENTS OVER 100.
VIRTUAL INPUT SESSIONS WERE ALSO
CONDUCTED IN MULTIPLE LANGUAGES
TO GATHER ADDITIONAL, RICHER,
QUALITATIVE DATA. THOSE SESSIONS
WERE ATTENDED BY OVER 460
PARTICIPANTS. WE ALSO HAD
MULTIPLE AD HOC GROUPS, FOCUS
GROUPS ORGANIZED TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND THE COST THE COST
DRIVERS IN THE BARRIERS TO
QUALITY AND HOW THEY DIFFER FOR
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS AND PROVIDERS
, AND ESPECIALLY FOR CHILDREN
WHO ARE UNHOUSED IN FAMILIES OF
UNHOUSED OR IN CHILDREN WHO ARE
DUAL LANGUAGE LEARNERS. UH, TO
FILL FACILITATE ACCESS FOR
PROVIDERS WHO WERE UNABLE OR
PREFERRED NOT TO COMPLETE THE
SURVEY. WE ALSO, UH, WORK WITH
OUR CONSULTANT TO DO SOME ONE ON
ONE INTERVIEWS, SO THE RESULT IS
THAT CALIFORNIA NOW HAS A
CUSTOMIZED, ANALYTICAL AND
MODELING TOOL INFORMED BY THE
ACTUAL COST DATA FROM THOSE
SURVEYS AND INTERESTED PARTY
FEEDBACK. THE TOOL ALLOWS USERS
TO UNDERSTAND HOW THE COST OF
CARE CHANGES, DEPENDING ON THE
VARIABLES, SUCH AS LICENSING
REQUIREMENTS, PROGRAM TYPE
CHARACTERISTICS. AGES OF
CHILDREN SERVED NUMBER OF
CHILDREN SERVED GEOGRAPHIC
LOCATION ACROSS THE STATE AND
OTHERS. THE TOOL ALSO FACTORS IN
SUBSIDY LEVELS AND OTHER FORMS
OF REVENUE. AT A VERY HIGH LEVEL
, THE BASE ELEMENTS THAT ARE
WITHIN THIS COST MODEL TOOL
INCLUDE THINGS LIKE RATIOS,
CHILD AND TEACHER RATIOS, GROUP
SIZE STAFFING PATTERNS FOR BOTH
THE TEACHING STAFF AS WELL AS
THE NON TEACHING STAFF,
COMPENSATION, SO SALARY AND
BENEFITS, PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT AND TRAINING
SUPPORTS FAMILY ENGAGEMENT,
CHILD EDUCATION AND DEVELOPMENT.
CHILD HEALTH AND DEVELOPMENT
SUPPORTS. IT ALSO HAS ENHANCED
RATES THAT WE'RE CONSIDERING
THINGS LIKE PROVIDING SERVICES
AT NONTRADITIONAL HOURS FOR
FAMILIES IN ADDITIONAL
CONSIDERATIONS. WE ARE CURRENTLY
MEETING AS WAS REFERENCED WITH
THE, UH, JOINT LABOR MANAGEMENT
COMMITTEE OF CHILDCARE PROVIDERS
SHOULD NOT TO FINALIZE THE
ELEMENTS. UH, WE MET 12 TIMES
BETWEEN DECEMBER AND FEBRUARY
AND FOUR MORE TIMES BETWEEN
FEBRUARY AND YESTERDAY AND SO
GLAD TO SAY THAT YESTERDAY, THE
JOINT LABOR MANAGEMENT COMMITTEE
, UM REACHED GENERAL CONSENSUS
ON DEFINITIONS OF THE BASIN
ENHANCED RATE ELEMENTS TO INFORM
AGAIN THE STATE PROPOSED SINGLE
RATE STRUCTURE. UH, WE'RE
WORKING ON FINALIZING THOSE
DOCUMENTS. UM AND WILL BE
POSTING THOSE, UM AND MAKE
AVAILABLE ALSO TO OUR RATE AND
QUALITY WORK, WHICH IS ALSO
AGAIN FOCUSED ON THE CENTER
BASED PROGRAMS. WE WILL FOLLOW
UP TO DESCRIBE IN SPECIFICITY
WHAT I JUST HIGH LEVEL OUTLINE
OF THOSE BASE ELEMENTS AND
ENHANCED RACE, UH, BASED ON
LICENSE FOR LICENSE EXEMPT
FAMILY FRIEND AND NEIGHBOR
PROVIDERS, AS WELL AS LICENSED
FAMILY, CHILD CARE HOMES AND, OF
COURSE, WORKING WITH THE RATE
AND QUALITY GROUP ON THE CENTER
BASED COMPONENTS, AND THEN THAT
WILL ALL BE OUTLINED IN A REPORT
TO THE LEGISLATURE AS WE'VE
COMPLETED THAT WORK YESTERDAY,
VERY, VERY SOON AND SHORTLY, SO
YOU'LL HAVE THAT REPORT WITH THE
DETAIL INCLUDED AGAIN I JUST
WOULD UNDERSCORE WE ARE ON TRACK
TO SUBMIT AND MEET THE FEDERAL
REQUIREMENTS TO SUBMIT THE STATE
PLAN BY JULY, 1 OF 2024 AND
AGAIN UH UH, JUST OUR REALLY
THRILLED WITH THE OPPORTUNITY TO
BE WHERE WE ARE IN THIS PROCESS
OF IMPLEMENTATION AND
OPERATIONALIZE. YES WE WILL NEED
TO OUTLINE AS THE L A Ó
DESCRIBED WHAT THOSE OPERATIONAL
CONSIDERATIONS LOOK LIKE TO
ACTUALLY CREATE OUR
IMPLEMENTATION DATE. AND THOSE
ARE OUR NEXT STEPS AHEAD. UH,
BUT I JUST REALLY WANNA
APPRECIATE ALL OF THE PARTIES
WHO HAVE HELPED INFORM THIS
PROCESS TO DATE AND ESPECIALLY,
UH, THE MEMBERS OF THE CHILDCARE
PROVIDERS. UNITED WHO SAT IN IN
THOSE MEETINGS THAT I JUST
REFERENCED, UM REALLY SPENDING
THE TIME TO MAKE SURE WE GET IT
RIGHT COMING OUT OF THE GATE.
I'M GLAD TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS, TOO. THANK YOU,
DIRECTOR. I THINK YOU KNOW FROM
THAT. EVERY MOVE IS LIKE 10,000
QUESTIONS THAT I HAD I SO IT'S
REALLY GREAT NEWS. UM, WE'RE
GONNA MOVE ON. WE'RE GONNA HOLD
QUESTIONS UNTIL THE END. UM,
WE'RE MOVING NOW ON TO, UM LÀ
WANDA WESLEY. WHO REPRESENTS
EARLY CARE AND EDUCATION
COALITION. AND THEN KIMBERLY
WILL BE AFTER ALL RIGHT. GOOD
MORNING. THANK YOU, CHAIRMAN
JAFAR AND FELLOW COMMITTEE
MEMBERS FOR YOUR CONTINUED
EFFORT TO SUPPORT CHILDCARE RATE
REFORM FOR DESERVING CALIFORNIA
CHILDCARE PROVIDERS. I AM DOCTOR
LAWANDA WESLEY, THE DIRECTOR OF
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS AT
CHILDCARE RESOURCE CENTER. WE
PROUDLY SERVE 50,000 CHILDREN
AND FAMILIES IN BOTH OF LOS
ANGELES AND SAN BERNARDINO
COUNTY. UM, IT IS MY PRIVILEGE
TO COME BEFORE ALL OF YOU AS A
FORMER PRESCHOOL TEACHER AND
EDUCATOR AND TO REPRESENT
THOUSANDS OF CHILDREN, FAMILIES
AND PROVIDERS WHO DO CARE ABOUT
CALIFORNIA'S CHILDREN. I LIKE TO
TELL YOU THREE REASONS WHY WE
MUST MOVE AND ACT URGENTLY TO
ADDRESS THE IMPENDING CHILD CARE
SHORTAGE CRISIS AND IMMEDIATELY
IMPLEMENT CHILDCARE RATE REFORM,
AS PROMISED BY GOVERNOR NEWSOM
AND THE LEGISLATURE. THE FIRST
REASON IS THAT WE WANNA MAKE
SURE THAT WE INCREASE AND
SUSTAIN A HIGH QUALITY CHILDCARE
WORKFORCE AND WE WANT TO ADDRESS
THE OVERDUE RACIAL AND GENDER,
PAY EQUITIES IN THE FIELD AND
THEN ACKNOWLEDGE, UM, THAT
CALIFORNIA UM IS HEADING TOWARDS
A BROKEN PROMISE. SHOULD I PAUSE
I SEE. ME NÓ GO AHEAD. OK SEE,
I'LL KEEP GOING. ALRIGHT SO THE
FIRST REASON AROUND SUSTAINING
CHILDCARE? UM THERE HAS BEEN AS
WE ALREADY KNOW. MULTITUDES OF
DECADES OF RESEARCH DONE, UM,
HERE IN CALIFORNIA AND ALSO
NATIONALLY AND, UM, WHAT WE WANT
TO DO IS CONTINUE TO UPLIFT
THOSE REPORTS, AND THEY RANGE
FROM LIFTING CHILD CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES OUT OF POVERTY TASK
FORCE THAT WAS CONDUCTED BY THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES IN 2018, THE BLUE
RIBBON COMMISSION IN 2019, THE
MASTER PLAN FOR EARLY CARE AND
EDUCATION IN 20 THEN, OF COURSE,
OUR WRITTEN QUALITY WORK GROUP
THAT WAS JUST MENTIONED, UM,
THAT HAS DONE WORK THROUGH 2022
IS NOW RECONVENING, UM, TO PICK
THAT BACK UP, UM, WITH ALL OF
THE COMBINED RESEARCH AND THE
WORK GROUPS, UM IT'S
OVERWHELMING CONSENSUS, UM, THAT
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
SUSTAIN THE WORKFORCE AND THAT
MEANS WE NEED TO ADOPT THE RATE
REFORM RIGHT AT HOME AND PAY
THIS FIELD OF WOMEN, PRIMARILY
WOMEN OF COLOR. UM, THE LIVABLE
WAGE. UM, UM THEY DESERVE FOR
BEING HIGHLY. SKILL COMPETENT
AND, UM, WE KNOW THAT THIS WAS
DONE DURING THE WORK DURING THE
PANDEMIC, UM, AT A TIME WHERE
THEY WERE DEEMED AS ESSENTIAL
WORKERS. AND SO THAT STILL IS.
THE PLACE STILL IS THE SITUATION
TO THIS DAY. AND SO THE WAY I
SEE IT MORE PLAINLY IS IN ORDER
TO ACCESS AND SUSTAIN A HIGH
QUALITY, COMPETENT AND SKILLED
WORKFORCE. WE MUST PAY FOR THE
TRUE COST OF CARE. AS OF THIS
WRITING, UM REPORTED BY THE, UH
U S¼ BUREAU OF LABOR STATISTICS.
UM, CALIFORNIA HAS LOST ABOUT
1300. JOBS THE REST OF THE
COUNTRY HAS STARTED TO REBOUND.
THE CALIFORNIA STILL LAGS BEHIND
, UM, AND FOR MY AGENCY IN
PARTICULAR CHILD CARE RESOURCE
CENTER WE HAVE RIGHT NOW. 24,000
CHILDREN THAT ARE ON THE WAITING
LIST, SO THE NEED IS THERE, BUT
WE HAVE CHILD CARE PROVIDERS WHO
ARE WALKING WITH THEIR FEET,
SAYING WE NEED TO TAKE OTHER
JOBS TO MAKE ENDS MEET, AND SO
WHAT WE'RE ASKING IS THERE'S PAY
EQUITY RIGHT NOW. WHICH IS MY
SECOND POINT. UM, THAT WE, UM WE
MOVE FORWARD WITH WHAT WAS
PRESENTED TODAY. HAVE A MINIMUM
OF THREE YEAR PLAN BUT NOT WAIT
ANOTHER DECADE. WE CAN'T WAIT
BECAUSE WE WON'T HAVE A
WORKFORCE SECTOR TO GO TO RIGHT
NOW, ACCORDING TO THE STATE DATA
73% OF CALIFORNIA'S CHILDCARE
PROVIDERS, UM ARE WOMEN AND
WOMEN OF COLOR, BUT THEY DO NOT
PAY THEMSELVES A SALARY BECAUSE
THE STATE DOES NOT COMPENSATE
THEM ACCORDINGLY. UM AND SO WHAT
WE BELIEVE RIGHT NOW IS THAT THE
SYSTEM I WOULD LIKE TO SAY THAT
IT'S BROKEN, BUT I, I ALSO FEEL
YOU KNOW, AT TIMES IT'S DESIGNED
THAT WAY. JUST RECENTLY. I SHARE
IT WITH THE L A TIMES AND IT WAS
REPORTED IN THE L A TIMES. UM,
THAT I MYSELF WITH ADVANCED
DEGREES. IT WAS AT A AT A PAY OF
$19 AN HOUR FOR A PERIOD OF
TIME, REGARDLESS OF MY EDUCATION
, AND SO I HAVE FIRST HAND
WITNESS WHAT THIS WAS LIKE, UM,
AS A PRESCHOOL EDUCATOR WORKING
IN THE FIELD, RELYING ON
SUBSIDIES, LIKE HOW IT WORKS, ME
AND PUBLIC HOUSING AND AGAIN, I
HAD AN ADVANCED DEGREE. UM
ACCORDING TO THE 22 U S¼ BUREAU
OF LABOR STATISTICS, UM,
CHILDCARE. PROVIDERS NATIONALLY
EARN ABOUT $13.71 AN HOUR AND
THAT'S ABOUT 28,000 PER YEAR,
WHICH IS NOT ENOUGH TO COVER OUR
COVER BASIC NEEDS OR FOOD. AND
AS A RESULT, AS I SAID, ALREADY,
CHILDCARE PROVIDERS ARE MOVING
WITH THEIR FEET. UM AND I WOULD
LIKE JUST TO START TO CONCLUDE
AND JUST SHARE THAT RECENTLY.
THE CENTER FOR THE STUDY FOR
CHILDCARE EMPLOYMENT REPORTED
THAT MANY OF OUR FOLKS AS OF
DECEMBER 23 2020 THREE ARE
IMPACTED BY CHRONIC HEALTH. UM,
CHALLENGES THAT INCLUDE ANYTHING
FROM, UM IMPACTING BEING
IMPACTED BY OBESITY,
CARDIOVASCULAR ISSUES AND JUST
CHRONIC PAIN. AND SO THAT WAS
NOT HAVING ECONOMIC WELL BEING,
UM, CREATES A PROBLEM. WE ALSO
WANNA MAKE SURE THAT THE 146,000
SLOTS THAT WERE TO BE, UM,
RECOUPED THIS YEAR IS ACTUALLY
KEPT INTO THE THIS YEAR'S BUDGET
AND NOT SWEPT AND SO IN CLOTHES.
WE JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE ASK THAT THE STATE DEVELOP
AND AGAIN, THE NEW, UM SINGLE
RATE ALTERNATIVE METHODOLOGY.
AND THAT IS DONE IN A
TRANSPARENT PROCESS, WHICH IS
GREAT TO HEAR THAT WE DO HAVE
THE QUALITY RATE, UH, WORK GROUP
TO HELP WITH THAT PROCESS. AND
OF COURSE, THE WORK THAT'S BEING
DONE WITH èC èC PU THROUGH THE
JLM èC, AND THEN I JUST WANNA
I'M JUST CLOSE AND SAY WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK THE GOVERNOR
AND THE LEGISLATURE, UM, TO KEEP
ITS PROMISE. AND II. I AM
COMPLETE. THANK YOU, UM ARE WE
HAVING ONE PERSON SPEAK FROM SO
I WAS ALSO ASKED TO SPEAK FROM
ON BEHALF OF THE SO I THINK
THERE IS A MISUNDERSTANDING. SO
I'M ONLY GONNA BE ABLE TO GIVE
YOU TWO MINUTES BECAUSE WE ONLY
ALLOWED IT, UH, SPACE FOR ONE
SPEAKER UNDER E èC. OK SO YOU
YOU MAY PROCEED, UH, MISSING
FERNANDEZ MENDOZA WITH TWO
MINUTES. OK THANK YOU, CHAIRMAN
BART AND THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY.
UM AS YOU KNOW, MY NAME IS
ANDREA FERNANDEZ MENDOZA. I'M
VICE PRESIDENT OF EDUCATION AT
CALIFORNIA CHILDREN'S ACADEMY.
I'M ALSO A BOARD MEMBER FOR
EVERY CHILD, CALIFORNIA, WHICH
IS A PROUD MEMBER OF THE E èC E
COALITION. I'M REPRESENTING HERE
TODAY, UM, MEMBERS FROM LOS
ANGELES COUNTY WE HAVE I HAVE
PERSONALLY WE HAVE 15 SCHOOLS
THAT SERVE OVER 100 AND 34
INFANTS. 100 AND 60, THREE
TODDLERS AND 478 PRESCHOOL
CHILDREN PER DAY. I'VE WORKED IN
THE FIELD FOR OVER 31 YEARS AND
WORKED MY WAY UP THE LADDER FROM
A VOLUNTEER SUMMER YOUTH WORKER
TO WHERE I AM TODAY AS VICE
PRESIDENT. E èC HAS BEEN AN
INTEGRAL PART OF MY LIFE BOTH
PERSONALLY AND PROFESSIONALLY.
AS A SO LARGE, CENTER BASED
PROVIDER OF E èC HIGH QUALITY.
I WAS THRILLED THAT ALL OF YOU
HAD, UM COMMITTED TO
STRENGTHENING CHILD CARE
WORKFORCE BY FINALLY ADDRESSING
THE ANTIQUATED RATE SYSTEM.
CURRENT REIMBURSEMENT RATES
BARELY COVER THE COST OF
SERVICES WITHOUT THE COVID
SUBSIDIES AND ALLOWANCES THAT
WE'VE HAD MANY OF OUR MANY
CENTERS LIKE MINE WOULD HAVE HAD
TO HAVE CLOSED, AND MANY DID.
THE THIS IS DUE TO MULTIPLE
FACTORS, WHICH INCLUDE INCREASE
IN FOOD AND UTILITY COSTS. RENT
INCREASES INCREASED INSURANCE
PREMIUMS, STAFFING COSTS,
MINIMUM WAGE INCREASES THE COST
OF MAINTENANCE AND FACILITIES AT
THE COST OF EVERYTHING HAS RISEN
FOR ALL OF US, AND ESPECIALLY IN
HIGH COST CITIES AND COUNTIES.
THERE ARE MANY PROVISIONS THAT
TITLE FIVE CENTERS MUST FOLLOW,
WHICH ARE NOT COVERED BY
REIMBURSEMENT RATES AND TO
MINIMIZE OUR COSTS. WE HAVE TO
MAKE THE BEST OF DIFFICULT
SITUATIONS. WE FIND OURSELVES
COMPETING WITH FAST FOOD
RESTAURANTS THAT FOR HIGH PAY
WITH LESS RESPONSIBILITY AND
THAT AS A RESULT, WE'RE BLEEDING
OUT OUR STAFF. WE ARE LOSING,
UM, STAFF TO FAST FOOD JOBS, AND
WE DESPERATELY NEED THAT
CONTINUITY OF CARE TO PROVIDE A
HIGH QUALITY EDUCATION FOR THE
MOST VULNERABLE CHILDREN OF
CALIFORNIA. IN A SAFE AND
NURTURING ENVIRONMENT. THE
PROMISE OF A SINGLE RATE
STRUCTURE BASED ON THE COST OF
CARE METHODOLOGY IS WAS A RELIEF
SO FAR TO OUR PROGRAMS, UM, AND
WITH THE CHANGES THAT WERE MADE
FOR FISCAL YEAR WITH THE WHOLE
HARMLESS AND HAS ALREADY SHOWED
POSITIVE IMPACTS, CHANGING FROM
THE ATTENDANCE BASED ENROLLMENT
TO THE, UM, ENROLLMENT BASED
REIMBURSEMENT. UH, I'M SORRY,
UH, PROVIDED A STABLE AND
CONSISTENT STREAM OF INCOME,
WHICH ALLOWED US TO MAKE OUR
BUDGETS AROUND STABLE INCOME
STREAMS AND PROVIDED US FOR
BETTER FINANCIAL PLANNING. IT
ALSO ALLOWED US TO STOP AND I
NEED YOU TO WRAP UP SOME. OK I'M
SORRY. UM AGAIN. THANK YOU. WE
IF YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS ABOUT
THE METHODOLOGY OR HOW ITS
IMPACT CENTERS IN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY AND ALL OVER THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA PLEASE FEEL FREE TO
ASK. WE'RE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
I'M MOVING ON TO REPRESENTATIVE
FROM èC èC PU, UH, KIMBERLY
ROSENBERGER. THANK YOU SO MUCH,
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS. UM I HAD
PREPARED NOTES. BUT AS YOU HEARD
FROM DIRECTOR JOHNSON, WE'VE
MADE PROGRESS. SO BEAR WITH ME.
UM WE ARE INCREDIBLY
APPRECIATIVE OF THE LEGISLATIVE
EFFORTS TO HELP KEEP US ON TRACK
AND ACCOMPLISH THE SHARED GOALS
OF PROVIDING A NEW METHODOLOGY
THAT'S MORE INCLUSIVE OF THE
WHOLE PICTURE OF CHILDCARE IN
CALIFORNIA. WE WANNA ACKNOWLEDGE
THIS COMMITTEE AND THE WOMEN'S
CAUCUS FOR PRIORITIZING THOSE
WORKERS AND HELPING US MOVE THAT
CONVERSATION FORWARD. THE JLM
èC WORKED TO FIND A MORE
MEANINGFUL WAY TO REIMBURSE
PROVIDERS APPROPRIATELY FOR THE
COST OF CARE. IN DOING SO WE
WERE TASKED WITH FAIRLY
COMPENSATING ALL WORKERS, WHICH
INCLUDES FAMILY, FRIENDS AND
NEIGHBORS. THAT HAS BEEN OUR
BIGGEST BARRIER TRYING TO
OVERCOME THAT TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION THEIR NEEDS WHILE
FAIRLY COMPENSATING EVERYONE,
AND SO THAT WAS A PATH WE NEEDED
TO ADDRESS BEFORE WE COULD MOVE
FORWARD. WE HAVE I THINK, COME
TO AN AGREEMENT AND, UM I STILL
NEED TO EMPHASIZE THE IMPORTANCE
OF FAMILY, FRIENDS AND NEIGHBORS
. AND WHY THAT WAS WHAT TOOK SO
LONG FOR US TO FINALIZE. THEY
ARE ONE OF THE LARGEST GROWING
TYPES OF CHILD CARE. THEY HAVE
HELPED INCREASE ACCESS AS THE
STATE EXPANDS SLOTS. THEY
PROVIDE ALTERNATIVE HOURS, CARE
AND COMMUNITIES WITH THE
GREATEST NEED AND HAVE A HIGH
LEVEL OF CULTURAL COMPETENCY.
DESPITE THIS, THEY HAVE LONG
BEEN OVERLOOKED. WHILE THEY MAY
NOT HAVE THE SAME REGULATIONS AS
THEIR PEERS IN HOME AND CENTERS
THAT HAVE REGULATORY
REQUIREMENTS IN THEIR DAY TO DAY
CARE. THEY ARE STILL MEETING
THOSE REQUIREMENTS. THEY PUT
FORWARD EFFORTS TO ON A DAY TO
DAY BASIS FOR TRANSPORTATION,
FOOD PREP LESSON PLANS AND
PROVIDING A SAFE AND CLEAN SPACE
. ALL OF THAT HISTORICALLY HAS
BEEN UNCOMPENSATED TIME. UM THIS
NEW PROPOSED METHODOLOGY
PROVIDES MEANINGFUL COMPENSATION
TO GIVE THEM THE SUPPORT. THEY
NEED. THE SUPPORT OF THE
LEGISLATURE AND EFFORTS INCLUDED
. WE ALSO THINK HAS ALLOWED FOR
THIS BREAKTHROUGH THROUGH TO
ADDRESS THEM, BUT ALSO TO HELP
ENCOURAGE THEM TO MOVE FORWARD
AND UPWARD MOBILITY. WE'RE
SEEING MORE OF THEM BECOME
LICENSED PROVIDERS. WE THINK
THAT THEY ARE HELP GROW THE
WORKFORCE THAT WE SO DESPERATELY
NEED. WE ARE OPTIMISTIC THAT WE
WILL BE FINALIZING A PROPOSAL
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO THE NEXT
STEPS IN EXPANDING THAT
METHODOLOGY TO ALL WORKERS,
INCLUDING CENTERS. WE'RE
APPRECIATIVE OF THE SUPPORT WE
HAVE RECEIVED IN RAISING UP THE
FIELD AS A WHOLE. BUT WE HAVE TO
UNDERSCORE TIME IS OF THE
ESSENCE. WE ARE NOT DONE. WE ARE
JUST OVER ONE OF OUR BIGGER
BARRIERS. AND SO WE LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUING TO WORK WITH YOU
ALL AS WE LOOK TO ACHIEVE THE
GOAL OF THAT NEW METHODOLOGY AND
FUNDING IT MOVING FORWARD. THANK
YOU AND HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
FINDING 78 COMMENTS ADD TO THIS
GOOD MORNING CHAIR KRISH
MALHOTRA DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
WE HAVE NOTHING FURTHER TO ADD
AT THIS TIME. GREAT TURNING IT
BACK OVER TO US FOR ANY
QUESTIONS. UH DIRECTOR JOHNSON,
I YOU KNOW, I'M FIRST. I'M SO
GRATEFUL THAT IN YOU DESCRIBED
SOME OF WHAT WENT INTO BETWEEN
AUGUST AND NOVEMBER THE 100
VIRTUAL INPUT SESSIONS, MULTIPLE
AD HOC FOCUS GROUPS SERVING AND
SO FORTH. AND YOU DESCRIBED EVEN
FURTHER. WHAT WENT INTO THIS?
I'M VERY APPRECIATIVE OF THE
COALITION. THE WORKFORCE THAT
REALLY, UM, HAMMERED IN ON THIS
ISSUE TO GET TO WHERE WE ARE NOW
AND IT IT SOUNDS LIKE WE'RE
GONNA MEET THAT JULY 24TH
DEADLINE SO WE DON'T NEED TO
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THE
FLEXIBILITY TO PUSH THAT BACK.
THAT'S THAT'S CORRECT. WE PLAN
TO SUBMIT AND MEET THAT
DEADLINE. PHENOMENAL. UM MY
QUESTION. UH, WELL, ACTUALLY,
UH, CONNECTING TO THAT YOU YOU
SHARED SOME OF THE OVERARCHING
THEMES RACIAL GROUP SIZE
STAFFING PATTERNS THAT YOU'RE
LOOKING TO INCLUDE IN THE MODEL,
AND, UH, MORE DETAIL IS TO COME
IN UPCOMING DAYS ON THE REPORT
COMING UP, OK, SO THAT'S WHERE
WE'RE AT RIGHT NOW WHERE YOU CAN
SHARE SO FAR. THAT'S CORRECT.
PERFECT OK? I DON'T HAVE ANY
FURTHER QUESTIONS FOR YOU. UM I
WOULD LIKE TO HEAR FROM
PROVIDERS. MAYBE YOU, MISS
MENDOZA. I KNOW HOW TO CUT YOU
OFF A LITTLE BIT. I DON'T KNOW
HOW MUCH SH. HAS BEEN SHARED
OUTSIDE GROUPS OR, UM, WHAT IS
GONNA BE PART OF THIS MODEL TO
MAKE UP THE REIMBURSEMENT RATES?
MAYBE. ARE, ARE THEY HAVE THEY
BEEN PART OF IT? THERE ARE
STAKEHOLDER MEETINGS. THEY HAD
TO BE PAUSED IN LARGE PART
BECAUSE WE DIDN'T HAVE A WORK
PRODUCT TO SHARE BECAUSE WE'RE
STILL TRYING TO, YOU KNOW,
FIGURE OUT THE RUNS. UM AND I
DON'T WANNA CUT OFF DIRECTOR
JOHNSON. I KNOW THERE'S INTENT,
BUT WE HAVE ON OUR END. TRIED TO
KEEP OUR E èC PARTNERS IN THE
LOOP. IN LARGE PART, WE'VE BEEN
ACCOMPLISHING A LOT OF THE
CONVERSATION IN THE LAST COUPLE
OF WEEKS. THAT'S WHERE THE
BREAKTHROUGH HAS BEEN, SO THERE
HASN'T BEEN AS MUCH INFORMATION
CIRCULATED UP UNTIL NOW, BECAUSE
WE HAD ANYTHING TO SHARE. OK WE
HAVE A MEETING NEXT WEEK CHAIR
UM AND AGAIN AS I REFERENCE. WE
ARE PLANNING TO POST WHAT WE
WERE ABLE TO COME TO AGREEMENT
ON WITH A DEFINITION SO THAT
THAT WILL HAVE BE PART OF THE
CONVERSATION. I'M HALTING ALL MY
QUESTIONS UNTIL WE GET TO SEE
THIS, UM, THIS MODEL THAT WE'RE
GONNA BE UTILIZING FOR THE
REIMBURSEMENT RATES, COLLEAGUES
AND QUESTIONS ON THIS. THIS
PANEL I THOUGHT WAS GONNA TAKE
LONGER. AH, BUT I THINK YOU WERE
JUST WAITING. UM, I'D LIKE TO
GIVE THE OPPORTUNITY NOW FOR ANY
FINAL THOUGHTS SINCE WE DO SOME
HAVE SOME EXTRA, UM, TIME HERE,
UM CHAIRMAN WHO ARE IF YOU DON'T
MIND IF I CAN ANSWER QUESTION
TWO THAT WAS POSED TO ME JUST TO
GIVE A LITTLE MORE INSIGHT ON
TO, UM, CONSIDERATIONS THAT THE
CENTERS WOULD MIGHT NEED. SO AS
CALIFORNIA MOVES TO AN
ALTERNATIVE METHODOLOGY. THERE
ARE SEVERAL ISLAND ITEMS TO
HIGHLIGHT THAT SHOULD BE
CONSIDERED MANY CENTER BASED
PROVIDERS, INCLUDING MYSELF, MY
PEERS AND STAFF HAVE ENGAGED IN
THE RATE REFORM AND QUALITY WORK
GROUP TO PROVIDE INPUT AND
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR THE NEW
RATES SPECIFICALLY FOR CENTER
BASED PROVIDERS. THE SUBSIDIZED
FIELD IS VERY TECHNICAL AND
IMPORTANT REQUIREMENTS THAT ARE
ONLY APPLICABLE TO DIRECT
CONTRACT. CHILDCARE CENTERS. WE
HAVE TEACHER QUALIFICATION
REQUIREMENTS. ASSESSMENT
REQUIREMENTS, ENVIRONMENT
NECESSARY PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT, FAMILY SUPPORT
NEEDED FAMILY INVOLVEMENT,
CURRICULUM SUPPORT SOCIAL
EMOTIONAL CLASSROOM SUPPORT
NEEDED TO ADDRESS CHALLENGING
BEHAVIORS, MULTILINGUAL
LEARNERS. UH, UNIVERSAL DESIGN
FOR LEARNING AND EXCEPTIONAL
NEED SUPPORTS AS MANY AS WELL AS
MANY OTHER ASPECTS TO PROVIDING
QUALITY EARLY EDUCATION FOR OUR
LITTLEST LEARNERS. IMPORTANT
COST. THAT SHOULD ALSO BE IN THE
, UM TAKEN INTO CONSIDERATION
ARE THE REGIONAL COSTS AND THE
MINIMUM WAGES IN EACH LOCALE. AS
YOU KNOW, THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES HAS A VERY HIGH, YOU
KNOW, AS LONG AS ALSO AS WELL AS
LOS ANGELES COUNTY, THEY'RE ALSO
VERY HIGH. UM COST AREAS. THE
AGES OF THE CHILDREN SERVE TO
ACCOUNT FOR NOT ONLY THE CHILD
ADULT RATIOS, BUT THE NUMBER OF
CHILDREN SERVED IN EACH
CLASSROOM. UM, TITLE FIVE. ED.
UM, CENTERS HAVE HIGHER
STRICTER. UM RATIOS THAT
INCREASE OUR STAFFING COSTS
WHERE IT'S DIFFERENT FOR FAMILY,
CHILD CARES OR UNLICENSED CARE.
REIMBURSING ON ENROLLMENT
INSTEAD OF ATTENDANCE CENTERS
NEED TO BE FULLY STAFFED TO MEET
THEIR ENROLLMENT RATIOS.
REGARDLESS SO IF THREE CHILDREN
SHOW UP, WE STILL HAVE TO PAY
FOR THE WHOLE CLASSROOM TO RUN
AND, UM UTILITIES. EVERYTHING
ARE STILL IN INCLUDED, AND SOME
CENTERS ARE OPEN FROM SIX IN THE
MORNING TO 6 P.M. AT NIGHT, SO
THOSE STAFFING REQUIREMENTS ARE
A LOT HIGHER THAN IF IT WERE A
SHORTER PERIOD OR FOR DIFFERENT
MODELS. UM IT IT AGAIN. THERE
ARE A LOT OF OTHER, UM, ASPECTS
TO THIS, BUT I DO APPRECIATE THE
TIME TO HIGHLIGHT THOSE FEW. UM
THE LAST ONE I'D LIKE TO
HIGHLIGHT IS SUBSIDIZED. DIRECT
CONTRACTING PROGRAMS ARE
MANDATED TO PERFORM CHILD
ASSESSMENTS, OBSERVATIONS AND
DIFFERENT ASPECTS OF QUALITY
THAT ARE TIED TO THEIR CONTRACTS
. UM THEY ARE NOT REIMBURSED.
THEY ARE NOT. THEY ARE UNFUNDED
MANDATES. AND SO PART OF THIS
SUPPORT, WHICH SHOULD ALSO BE
AND I KNOW IT WASN'T INCLUDED IN
THE SURVEY. THEY WENT OUT WITH
TECHNOLOGY COSTS AND, UM, THE
COST. TO UM, BUY THE SOFTWARE TO
RUN THE ASSESSMENT ON THE
CLASSROOM MONITORING, UM, TECH
SUPPORT AND THE TRAINING THAT IS
REQUIRED. THERE IS CONSTANT
TURNOVER IN E èC E PROGRAMS SO
HAVING TO CONSTANTLY RETRAIN THE
FIELD IS VITAL TO PROVIDE
QUALITY TO THE FIELD AND TO THE
CHILDREN THAT WE SERVE, AND IT
AFFECTS OUR MOST VULNERABLE
LEARNERS IN CALIFORNIA, SO IT IS
ESSENTIAL WE PROVIDE THEM WITH
QUALITY. SO UM, THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY.
I APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
WRAP MY SPIEL UP. WHAT ARE TITLE
FIVE TITLE FIVE CONTRACTORS ARE
THE èC S¼ PP AND èC Tð R, THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PRESCHOOL
PROGRAM AND THE CALIFORNIA CHILD
, UM, CHILDCARE PROGRAM AND SO
WE ARE REQUIRED TO FOLLOW TITLE
FIVE REQUIREMENTS, WHICH ARE THE
HIGHER THEY'RE HIGHER THAN TITLE
22 REQUIREMENTS. UM AND THERE
ARE THERE ARE A BIT STRICTER ON
WHAT WE HAVE TO PROVE. AND
THERE'S NÓ REIMBURSEMENT FOR THE
INCREASED THERE ISN'T A
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN BETWEEN OK,
CAN YOU TALK TO ME AT YOUR
REMINDED ME OF, UM THIS ISSUE
WAS BROUGHT UP EARLIER THIS YEAR
PROVIDERS WHO NEED TO CLOSE FOR
LUNCH OR PAY TIME OFF OR NON PAY
TIME OFF AND HOW THAT IMPACTS UM
, THEIR RATES OR JUST LIKE THEIR
FUNCTION. SO FOR STAFFING WE
HAVE WE HAVE TO MAINTAIN OUR
RATIOS AT ALL TIMES, AND THIS
INCLUDES TAKING CHILDREN TO THE
BATHROOM. SO IF WE PULL A
TEACHER OR ADULT TO MOVE FROM A
CLASSROOM TO A BATHROOM, WE HAVE
TO HAVE FOR ADULTS TO SEND WITH
THEM. SO OUR STAFFING
REQUIREMENTS FOR LUNCHES FOR
BREAKS ALL OF THOSE THINGS WE
STILL HAVE TO MAINTAIN.
APPROPRIATE RATIOS IF ONE CHILD
IS AWAKE DURING NAPTIME, SO
THERE ARE SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGES
TO BEING ABLE TO STAY, UM WITHIN
RATIO, BUT WE DO IT. WE MYSELF.
I'VE BEEN ON THE FLOOR IN
CLASSROOMS IN THIS MONTH BECAUSE
YOU KNOW, WE MAKE SURE WE RUN
OUR RATIOS AT ALL TIMES. I'M UH,
D¯ÚI DIRECTOR WOULD YOU SAY OR
EVEN KIMBERLY? ANYTHING THAT YOU
HEARD RIGHT NOW? WERE WAS NOT IN
CONVERSATION DURING THE PAST SIX
MONTHS IN NEGOTIATIONS. ALL OF
THOSE ITEMS SHE LISTED WERE OF
CONSIDERATION ARE THINGS THAT WE
HAVEN'T TAKEN INTO ACCOUNT. I
THINK, UM, THE TITLE 22 IS OFTEN
LIKE HOW, UH, TITLE FIVE IS HOW
THEY LOOK AT RATES. IT'S THOSE
REGULATIONS, THOSE ADDITIONAL
REQUIREMENTS AND THAT WAS KIND
OF THE DISCONNECT WE HAD WITH A
FAMILY FRIEND AND NEIGHBOR
BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT HELD TO
THOSE, UM, BUT THOSE WERE STILL
INCLUDED IN THE CONVERSATION AND
HOW THEY WERE COMPENSATED. SO I
THINK THE STRUCTURE DOES ALLOW
FOR THOSE NUANCES. UM YEAH, I'LL
JUST ADD AGAIN THAT AS WE'RE
LOOKING AT THE COST MODEL AND
THEN ACTUALLY LOOKING TO SET
RATES. THE PROGRAM TYPES TO THE
POINTS THAT ARE BEING MADE WILL
BE CONSIDERATIONS. THE
REQUIREMENTS AND STANDARDS ARE
CONSIDERATION. SO HOW IT WORKS.
TODAY WE HAVE TWO DIFFERENT RATE
STRUCTURES, RIGHT. WE'RE MOVING
TO A SINGLE SOME MORE SIMPLIFIED
STRUCTURE, BUT WE HAVE A
STANDARD REIMBURSEMENT RATE IN A
REGIONAL MARKET RATE. UM AND THE
STANDARD REIMBURSEMENT RATE IS
WHAT SUPPORTS, UH TITLE FIVE
PROGRAMS THAT ARE REFERENCED.
THESE ARE BASICALLY PROGRAMS WHO
HAVE A DIRECT CONTRACT WITH THE
STATE TO SERVE A CERTAIN AMOUNT
OF YOUTH RIGHT, AS OPPOSED TO A
FAMILY RECEIVING A VOUCHER AND
THEN CHOOSING WHERE THEY USE
THAT VOUCHER. SO ALL OF THESE
CONSIDERATIONS ARE PART OF THE
CONSIDERATIONS THAT I APPRECIATE
THE LIFTING UP OF TECHNOLOGY AS
WELL IN TERMS OF ADDITIONS TO
THE SURVEY THAT WAS REFERENCED
HERE, BUT CERTAINLY PART OF THE
CONSIDERATIONS OF THE COST OF
CARE OF THE VARYING TYPES OF
PROGRAMS WE HAVE ACROSS THE
STATE. THANK YOU. MY FINAL
QUESTION. UH, JACKIE, YOU
MENTIONED THAT, UM IT'S STILL
GONNA TAKE SOME TIME AFTER THE A
èC F APPROVAL. DO WE ANTICIPATE
? DID YOU SAY NEXT YEAR WE COULD
POTENTIALLY SEE THE RATES
KICKING IN THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT REQUIRES THE STATE TO
BEGIN TO BASE THEIR RATES ON THE
ALTERNATIVE METHODOLOGY BY JULY.
1 2025 OK, UM HOW THAT LOOKS
LIKE HOW THAT STRUCTURED. OF
COURSE, THOSE DETAILS WOULD NEED
TO BE, UM, NEGOTIATED IN PART
WITH THE UNION BUT THEN ALSO
AGAIN FOR CENTER BASED THERE
NEEDS TO ALSO BE THAT, UM,
CONCURRENT ANNUAL BUDGET PROCESS
. PERFECT COLLEAGUES. ANYTHING
FURTHER. THANK YOU. EVERYONE. I
APPRECIATE IT. WE'RE GONNA MOVE
ON TO PUBLIC COMMENT ON THIS
ISSUE IF ANYONE WOULD LIKE TO,
UM, PROVIDE A PUBLIC COMMENT ON
ISSUE ONE. CHILD CARE. GREAT
REFORM, PLEASE STEP FORWARD.
GOOD MORNING, SARAH BOTCHES WITH
CHILDREN NOW, THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR THE DISCUSSION AS AN
ORGANIZATION THAT REPRESENTS THE
BEST INTERESTS OF STUDENTS. WE
JUST WANNA MAKE SURE THAT THE
STATE PLAN HAS INCLUSIVE
LANGUAGE CENTERED WITH AN EQUITY
FRAMEWORK USING A COST ANALYSIS
MODEL RATHER THAN THE REGIONAL
MARKET. UH, PRICE, WHICH WAS
GOOD TO HEAR THAT THAT'S NOT
UNDER CONSIDERATION WOULD
REGULAR COST ESTIMATE? UH UH,
COST STUDIES AND ADJUSTMENTS FOR
COST OF GOODS AND SERVICES AS
THEY INCREASE. WE THE COST OF
LIVING MINIMUM WAGE LOSS CHANGE
AND VARY THROUGH EACH OF OUR
COUNTIES. AND SO FOR US, IT'S
REALLY ENSURING THAT WE HAVE AN
APPROPRIATE AND RESPECTFUL
COMPENSATION PACKAGE FOR OUR
PROVIDERS, ENSURING THAT THERE
IS A TRANSITION PLAN EITHER AS
PART OF THE ALTERNATIVE
METHODOLOGY OR AS A SEPARATE
STATE DOCUMENT THAT OUTLINES HOW
AND ON WHAT TIMELINE THE STATE
TRANSITIONS TO THE CURRENT
FUNDING RATES, ENSURING THAT OUR
PROVIDERS ARE NOT DISCOURAGED.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. AND PLEASE KEEP HER
COMMENTS TO ONE MINUTE. GOOD
MORNING. UM, THANK YOU FOR
HAVING US HERE TODAY. MY NAME IS
JUSTINA ERPELDING AND ON BEHALF
OF OUR MEMBERS OF OVER 6000 THAT
ARE PART OF EVERY CHILD
CALIFORNIA AND OUR E èC E
VOICES PROGRAM. I WANNA SAY
THANK YOU FOR ALL OF YOUR
SUPPORT OF THE E èC COMMUNITY
DURING THIS LEGISLATIVE SESSION,
AND WE RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT YOU
PLEASE SUPPORT THE NEW RATE
REFORM METHODOLOGY BASED ON THE
TRUE COST OF CARE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. HØI. MY NAME IS
FRISIA MOORE. I OWN TWO TITLE 22
PRESCHOOLS AND GROVE, CALIFORNIA
AND THIS HIGHLY IMPACTS MY
ABILITY TO BE ABLE TO PAY MY
TEACHERS. SO I SUPPORT THIS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR COMING.
HELLO GOOD MORNING. MY NAME IS
NINA BOOY. I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF EVERY CHILD,
CALIFORNIA WE ARE IN FULL
SUPPORT OF THE COST OF CARE.
ALTERNATE METHODOLOGY, INCLUDING
ALL OF THE ELEMENTS THAT WE
DISCUSSED TODAY. UM EARLY CARE
AND EDUCATION PROGRAMS ARE
CRITICAL, UM, FOR OUR STATE IN
ORDER TO MOVE FORWARD, AND WE
THINK THAT ALL OF OUR PROVIDERS
SHOULD BE COMPENSATED
APPROPRIATELY. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. OH, GOOD MORNING
CHAIR AND MEMBERS ROFFE WITH
THRIVING FAMILIES, CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU FOR MAKING TIME ON
TODAY'S AGENDA FOR AN UPDATE ON
THE CHILD CARE RATE REFORM. UH
Tð F èC HAS SOME CONCERNS
FOCUSING ON THE LACK OF
TRANSPARENCY, TRANSPARENCY IN
THE PROCESS AND ISSUES BEING
DISCUSSED SO FAR. ADDITIONALLY
Tð F èC IS CONCERNED
SURROUNDING THE LACK OF
CONVERSATION TO DATE,
RECOGNIZING THAT IF A NEW RATE
STRUCTURE IS NOT ACTUALLY
IMPLEMENTED BY JUNE, 30TH 2025,
THEN WE WILL REVERT BACK TO
REIMBURSING FAMILY CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS BASED ON A 2018 MARKET
RATE. BAY. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
ATTENTION TO THE CONCERNS RAISED
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH YOU ON THESE ISSUES. THANK
YOU. MORNING COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
P Kò IS A DIRECTOR OF GOVERNMENT
AFFAIRS FOR CHILD ACTION IN
SUPPORT OF A TRUE COST BASED
REIMBURSEMENT RATE. IT BREAKS
OUR HEARTS TO SEE CHILDCARE
FACILITIES CLOSED DOWN DUE TO AN
ANTIQUATED REIMBURSEMENT SYSTEM
FOR EARLY EDUCATORS, PARENTS AND
CHILD CARE PROVIDERS NEED THIS
CHANGE NOW. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU. HØI JENNIFER GREY
WITH PARENT VOICES CALIFORNIA
AND WE ARE IN SOLIDARITY WITH
ALL OF THE CHILD CARE PROVIDER
UNITED MEMBERS ON A TRUE COST OF
CARE MODEL, AND WE JUST WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE REALLY STAY
LIKE FOCUSED ON MAKING SURE THAT
WE MEET ALL OF OUR TIMELINES.
YOU KNOW, WHEN PARENTS OR, UM
YOU KNOW, PROVIDERS DON'T TURN
IN THEIR PAPERWORK ON TIME OR
DON'T DO WHAT'S ASKED OF THEM.
YOU KNOW, THEY GET CUT OFF OF
SERVICES OR THEY LOSE THEIR
THEIR SUBSID. AND SO WE'RE JUST
ASKING THAT THE STATE MEET THEIR
REQUIRED DEADLINES AND THAT WE
KEEP ON TRACK. THANK YOU.
ABSOLUTELY. THANK YOU. MORNING,
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS ANDREW SHANE
AND CHILD POVERTY. CALIFORNIA UH
I'LL I MYSELF, UH, WITH THE
COMMENTS MADE BY JENNIFER GREY
FROM PARENT VOICES AND IN
SOLIDARITY WITH èC, èC PU, UH,
LIFTING UP THE NEED TO SUPPORT
UH, FAMILY, FRIENDS AND
NEIGHBORS. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
GOOD MORNING. CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS ARE DEDICATED
PROFESSIONALS WHO SHOULD BE PAID
FAIRLY AND SUPPORTED FOR THEIR
KNOWLEDGE, EXPERIENCE AND TALENT
AND LAURIE FURS AND FELLOW
DIRECTOR OF LEGAL ADVOCACY AT
THE CHILDCARE LAW CENTER. WE ARE
IN FULL SUPPORT AT PAYING
PROVIDERS IN FULL BASED ON THE
ALTERNATIVE METHODOLOGY BY NOT
GIVING CHILDCARE PROVIDERS
RESPECT AND FAIR PAY. CALIFORNIA
POLICYMAKERS UPHOLD
DISCRIMINATORY LAWS THAT EXPLOIT
BLACK LATINA AND IMMIGRANT WOMEN
. WE URGE THE LEGISLATURE TO
MOVE CHILDCARE PROGRAMS FROM
MERELY SURVIVING. TO THRIVING
AND COMMUNITIES WILL BECOME
HEALTHIER AND MORE VIBRANT NOW
AND INTO THE NEXT GENERATION.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, MADAM CHAIR AND
SENATORS ROSANNA CARVAO ELLIOTT
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE EARLY CARE
AND EDUCATION CONSORTIUM, WHICH
IS A NATIONAL, A NATIONWIDE
NONPROFIT AND THE MEMBERS HERE
IN CALIFORNIA OPERATE 475
CENTERS WITH CAPACITY TO SERVE
OVER 67,000 CHILDREN. I WANT TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR HOLDING
THIS HEARING AS YOU HEARD FROM
SOME OF THE OTHER PUBLIC
COMMENTS. UM, IT IS GREAT TO
HAVE AN UPDATE FOR THE PUBLIC,
UH, THAT AREN'T AT THE TABLE TO
PARTICIPATE IN HERE. WHAT IS
GOING ON? YOU ALSO HEARD A LOT
ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF GETTING
THIS DONE IN A TIMELY MANNER. I
REALLY WANT TO THAT, UM AS I
THINK IT WAS MISS GRUP YOU
MENTIONED ABOUT GOING BACK TO
THE 2018 RATES THAT CAN'T
HAPPEN. CERTAIN PROVIDERS WILL
NOT BE HERE IN EXISTENCE. IF
THAT DOES HAPPEN, AND THEN I
JUST ALSO WANT GENERALLY ALIGN
MY COMMENTS WITH THOSE OF DR DE
DOCTOR LEANDA WESLEY, WHO IS
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE E èC E
COALITION. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
REMEMBERS KATHY MOSSBERG,
REPRESENTING THE FIRST FIVE
ASSOCIATION. I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR THE HEARING AND WANT TO
ALIGN OUR OUR SUPPORT AND
COMMENTS WITH THOSE OF DR WESLEY
AS WELL. AND THE LARGER E èC
COALITION. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING CHAIR MENDAR AND MEMBERS
. MY NAME IS JULIET. TERRY I'M A
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS SPECIALIST
WITH THE CHILDCARE RESOURCE
CENTER. I'M HERE TO ALIGN MY
COMMENTS TODAY WITH THOSE OF
JENNIFER GREY APPARENT VOICES.
THOSE OF THE E èC E COALITION
AND THOSE OF PU. WE ARE IN FULL
SUPPORT OF THE ALTERNATIVE
METHODOLOGY AND JUST REALLY URGE
THE LEGISLATURE TO DO EVERYTHING
POSSIBLE TO KEEP THE ESTABLISHED
TIMELINE FOR PROVIDERS. UM
PROVIDERS HAVE WAITED DECADES ON
DECADES FOR FAIR PAY AND EQUITY,
AND THEY SIMPLY CAN'T WAIT
ANOTHER YEAR LONGER FOR PAY
JUSTICE. THANK YOU SO MUCH. SEE
NÓ ONE ELSE. WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON
TO ISSUE NUMBER TWO. ON THE
PROPOSED DELAYS TO HOME SAFE AND
HOUSING DISABILITY ADVOCACY
PROGRAMS.
TALK ABOUT SOME HOUSING AND
SENIORS. HAVE A FULL HOUSE HERE,
THEN. WELL, AND WE HAVE SOMEONE
JOINING US FROM ZOOM AS WELL. DR
KUCHEL WELCOME. HØI THANKS FOR
HAVING ME. UM ARE YOU READY FOR
ME TO START? GIVE ME ONE SECOND
HERE. I'M SORRY. I CAN'T BE
THERE IN PERSON. THEY GONNA PUT
HER UP THERE? YEAH. A RE. THEY
GONNA PUT HER UP THERE? SORRY.
ARE THEY PUTTING HER UP THERE?
WE'RE BEING STRAINED, SO I DON'T
KNOW. OK? THEY SHOULD. OK? WELL,
DOCTOR MICHELLE. UM, IS JOINING.
OR SHE IS PERFECT IS THE
DIRECTOR OF U èC S¼ Dð. BENNY
OFF HOMELESS HOUSING INITIATIVE.
WELCOME, DOCTOR. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. I'M SORRY. I CAN'T BE
THERE. GOOD MORNING, CHAIRMAN
JAVAR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MARGO KUSCHEL,
PROFESSOR OF MEDICINE AT U èC.
S¼ F, UM, WHERE I DIRECT THE BEN
F HOME ASSISTANT HOUSING
INITIATIVE. I'M ALSO A
PRACTICING, UM, PHYSICIAN AND AN
N. I HÌ FUNDED RESEARCHER TODAY
. I'M GONNA TALK ABOUT THE OLDER
ADULT HOMELESS POPULATION IN THE
STATE. SO AS YOU KNOW, ON A
GIVEN NIGHT IN 2020, THREE MORE
THAN 100 AND 81,000 PEOPLE
EXPERIENCED HOMELESSNESS IN
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE 12% OF THE
NATION. POPULATION BUT 28% OF
THOSE EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS
AND HALF OF THOSE EXPERIENCING
UNSHELTERED HOMELESSNESS, BUT
ONE OF THE FASTEST GROWING
GROUPS OF PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS ARE THOSE AGED 50
OLDER. WE CONDUCTED RESEARCH IN
THE EARLY TWO THOUSANDS THAT
SHOWED THAT ABOUT 11% OF SINGLE
HOMELESS ADULTS IN SAN FRANCISCO
WERE 50 OLDER, BUT BY 20 BY 2003
37% WERE MY TEAM RECENTLY
CONDUCTED A LARGE REPRESENTATIVE
STUDY OF HOMELESSNESS, THE
CALIFORNIA STATEWIDE STUDY OF
PEOPLE EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS
, AND WE FOUND THAT AMONG SINGLE
ADULTS EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS
NEARLY HALF ARE NOW 50 OLDER.
THE RISK OF EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS FOR OLDER ADULTS
DOES NOT FALL EQUALLY ACROSS THE
POPULATION IN CASPER 31% OF
OLDER CALIFORNIANS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS IDENTIFIED AS BLACK
DESPITE ONLY 6% OF OLDER
CALIFORNIANS IN THE GENERAL
POPULATION. AMONG ADULTS. 50
OLDER WHO EXPERIENCE
HOMELESSNESS, 41% HAD NEVER BEEN
HOMELESS BEFORE THE AGE OF 50.
NOT EVEN FOR A NIGHT. THOSE
OLDER ADULTS WHO HAD BEEN
HOMELESS BEFORE 50 CONTINUED
AFTER 50 HAD HAD DEVASTATING
CHILDHOODS AND THEN LIVED BY
MARX LIVES MARKED BY TRAUMA AND
STRUGGLE. BUT THOSE WHO BECAME
FIRST HOMELESS AFTER 50 HAD VERY
DIFFERENT STORIES. THEY HAD
LIVED TYPICAL LIVES AND HAD
WORKED PHYSICALLY DEMANDING LOW
WAGE JOBS THROUGHOUT THEIR LIVES
UNTIL SOMETHING DISRUPTED THEM
IN LATE LIFE THAT WAS TYPICALLY
EITHER THEY OR THAT LOST THEIR
JOB. THEY ARE THEIR SPOUSE
BECAME ILL, THEIR MARRIAGE BROKE
UP OR THEIR SPOUSE OR THEIR
PARENT DIED, AND SUDDENLY THEY
FOUND THEMSELVES HOMELESS.
UNDERLYING THIS CRISIS, WHETHER
IT IS FOR PEOPLE HOMELESS FOR
THE FIRST TIME, OR THOSE LATER
IN LIFE IS THE HOUSING
AFFORDABILITY CRISIS. WE FOUND
THAT THE MEDIAN MONTHLY
HOUSEHOLD INCOME OF OLDER ADULTS
IN THE SIX MONTHS PRIOR TO THIS
EPISODE WAS $920. WITH THE
MEDIAN RENT OF A ONE BEDROOM
APARTMENT IN OUR STATE,
EXCEEDING $1500 AFFORDABLE
HOUSING IS OUT OF REACH FOR MANY
OLDER ADULTS IN CALIFORNIA, WE
HAVE ONLY 24 UNITS OF HOUSING
AFFORDABLE AND AVAILABLE FOR
EVERY 100. EXTREMELY LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS. WE ARE 1 MILLION
UNITS SHORT. BUT WHETHER NEW TO
HOMELESSNESS OR HOMELESS FOR A
LONG TIME, THOSE 15 AND OLDER
HAVE HEALTH STATUS MORE SIMILAR
TO PEOPLE IN THEIR SEVENTIES AND
EIGHTIES, AS MEASURED BY KEY
INDICATORS LIKE MOBILITY,
FUNCTION, COGNITION AND PROBLEMS
LIKE FALLS AND INCONTINENCE,
ALMOST A THIRD REPORTED TWO OR
MORE DIFFICULTIES WITH
ACTIVITIES OF DAILY LIVING. A
THIRD REPORTED MOBILITY PROBLEMS
, AND OVER HALF REPORTED THEIR
HEALTH WAS FAIR OR POOR. THESE
ARE DEVASTATING INDICATORS. THIS
LEADS ME TO SAY WHEN TALKING
ABOUT HOMELESSNESS. 50 IS A NEW
75. ONCE HOMELESS. WE HAVE FOUND
THAT ADULTS, OLDER ADULTS HAVE
DIFFICULTY EXITING HOMELESSNESS
AND MOST EVEN THOSE WHO FIRST
ENTER AFTER THE AGE OF 50.
BECOME CHRONICALLY HOMELESS. OUR
RESEARCH HAS FOUND THAT 80% OF
OTHER HOMELESS ADULTS REGAIN
THEIR HOUSING WITHIN A FEW
YEARS, BUT HALF RETURNED TO
HOMELESSNESS WITHIN A YEAR AFTER
REGAINING IT. WHAT PROTECTS
AGAINST HIS RETURN HAVING A
SUBSIDY? HOMELESSNESS IS
DEVASTATING TO HELP AN OLDER
ADULT EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS
HAVE HIGH RISK OF MORTALITY
THREE AND A HALF TIMES THAT OF
THE GENERAL COMMUNITY. AMONG
THOSE 15 OLDER, THE MEDIAN AGE
OF DEATH IS 64 AND CANCER AND
HEART DISEASE ARE THE MOST
COMMON CAUSES OF DEATH. THOSE
FIRST HOMELESS AFTER 50 HAVEN'T
EVEN HIGHER RISK OF DYING
COMPARED TO THOSE FIRST HOMELESS
BEFORE 50. AND THOSE WHO REGAIN
THEIR HOUSING IMMEDIATELY AND
DRASTICALLY CUT THEIR RISK OF
DYING. THE STATUS QUO IS NOT
ACCEPTABLE TO SOLVE OLDER ADULT
HOMELESSNESS. WE HAVE TO
DRAMATICALLY INCREASE THE SUPPLY
OF DEEPLY AFFORDABLE HOUSING,
AND WE NEED TO CENTER RACIAL
EQUITY. WE HAVE TO FOCUS ON
PREVENTION, KEEPING THOSE WHO
ARE AT RISK OF HOMELESSNESS FROM
BECOMING HOMELESS AND PREVENTING
THOSE WHO HAVE RECENTLY EXITED
FROM RETURNING TO IT. WE NEED TO
ALIGN OUR SYSTEMS TO MEET THE
NEEDS OF THIS OLDER POPULATION.
WE HAVE TO EMBRACE HOUSING FIRST
, WHICH IS A FLEXIBLE SOLUTION
THAT ACKNOWLEDGES THAT HOUSING
IS CENTRAL. BY PROVIDING
PERMANENT HOUSING OPTIONS WITH
TAILORED, SUPPORTIVE SERVICES
THAT ARE VOLUNTARY AND MEET THE
NEEDS OF THIS POPULATION. WE
HAVE TO BE MORE FLEXIBLE AND
NIMBLE IN HOW WE USE MEDICAID,
HOME AND COMMUNITY BASED
SERVICES TO PROVIDE THE CRITICAL
PERSONAL CARE SUPPORT NEEDED
RECOGNIZING THAT THOSE WHO
EXPERIENCE HOMELESSNESS MAY NOT
BE ABLE TO NAVIGATE OUR CURRENT
SYSTEMS, AND WE NEED TO PROVIDE
VOLUNTARY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SUPPORTS THAT MEETS THE DISTINCT
NEEDS OF THE OLDER ADULT
POPULATION. THE AGING OF THIS
POPULATION PRESENTS US WITH
STARK CHOICES. WE CAN'T BE
COMPLACENT AND ALLOW OUR ELDERS
TO LIVE AND DIE ON OUR STREETS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, DOCTOR AND
APOLOGIZE. CORRECTION YOU'RE
FROM SF. UM WE'RE GONNA MOVE
TOWARDS OUR DEPARTMENT. OUR
CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR FROM èC
Dð S¼ S¼ HAS JOINED US. IT'S
CLAIRE RAMSEY. YES UM, THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR AND SENATORS.
UM, FOR HAVING ME HERE TODAY. MY
NAME IS CLAIRE RAMSEY. AND I'M
THE CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES.
AND I'M HERE TO TALK ABOUT THREE
OF OUR èC Dð S¼ S¼ HOUSING
PROGRAMS IN THIS FIRST UNDER
THIS FIRST ISSUE, I WILL BE
TALKING ABOUT BOTH OUR HOME SAFE
PROGRAM AND OUR HOUSING AND
DISABILITY ADVOCACY PROGRAM ALSO
KNOWN AS HÌ Dð. UM I WAS ASKED
TO PROVIDE, UH, A BRIEF OVERVIEW
OF BOTH PROGRAMS. UM WHICH I'LL
START WITH, UM AND I'LL ALSO BE
OVER GIVING AN OVERVIEW OF
RECENT DATA TRENDS. UM WHICH
SHOW OUR IMPACT AND OUTCOMES,
SOME KEY ACHIEVEMENTS AND THEN
ALSO WAS ASKED TO DISCUSS THE
PROPOSED DELAYS, UH, IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. SO I JUST
WANNA FLAG THAT THERE. UM, IS A
GOOD OVERVIEW OF THE TWO
PROGRAMS IN THE AGENDA TODAY, SO
I'LL JUST HIGHLIGHT THAT HD APP
WAS ESTABLISHED IN 2016, AND IT
HAS THE GOAL OF ASSISTING PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING OR AT RISK OF
HOMELESSNESS, WHO ARE LIKELY
ELIGIBLE FOR DISABILITY BENEFITS
. BUT BY PROVIDING BOTH HOUSING
SUPPORTS AND DISABILITY
BENEFITS, ADVOCACY THERE ARE
FOUR KEY COMPONENTS TO AGED APP
OUTREACH, CASE MANAGEMENT
BENEFITS, ADVOCACY AND HOUSING
SUPPORT TO ELIGIBLE INDIVIDUALS.
WE CURRENTLY HAVE 57 COUNTIES
PARTICIPATING AND AN ADDITIONAL
17 TRIBAL GRANTEES AS OF FY 2220
THREE. I'LL JUST NOTE THAT OUR
TRIBAL GRANTEES INCLUDE BOTH
FEDERAL EXCUSE ME, FEDERALLY
RECOGNIZED AND NON FEDERALLY
RECOGNIZED TRIBES, TRIBALLY LED
NONPROFITS AND OTHER TRIBAL
ORGANIZATIONS. HOME SAFE WAS
ESTABLISHED IN 2018, AND IT
SERVES OLDER ADULTS 60 OVER AND
DEPENDENT ADULTS 19 TO 59 WHO
ARE ELIGIBLE OR APPARENTLY
ELIGIBLE FOR A P S¼ ADULT
PROTECTIVE SERVICES OR WHO ARE
SERVED BY A TRIBAL SOCIAL
SERVICES AGENCY WHO APPEAR
ELIGIBLE FOR A P S¼ WHO ARE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS OR AT
RISK OF HOMELESSNESS. UH
GRANTEES WITHIN HOME SAFE. THERE
IS A NUMBER OF STRATEGIES WE USE
TO PROVE, PREVENT AND STABILIZE
HOUSING FOR ÁP S¼ CLIENTS,
INCLUDING CASE MANAGEMENT,
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE, LEGAL
ASSISTANCE AND DEEP CLEANING
RIGHT NOW, ALL 58 COUNTIES ARE
OPERATING A HOME SAFE PROGRAM,
AND WE HAVE AWARDED 20 THREE
ADDITIONAL TRIBAL GRANTEES IN,
UH, FISCAL YEAR. 2220 THREE. WE
WERE ASKED TO DESCRIBE WHAT
MAKES THESE PROGRAMS UNIQUE. SO
I THINK WHAT WE'RE THE POWER
BEHIND BOTH THESE PROGRAMS IS
REALLY THE BRIDGE BETWEEN
HOUSING AND SOCIAL SERVICES AND
MEETING PEOPLE WHERE THEY'RE AT.
WE THINK THAT BY INTEGRATING OUR
PROGRAMS WITH BROADER SOCIAL
SERVICES, WE'RE ENSURING ACTIVE
INVOLVEMENT OF THE SOCIAL SAFETY
NET. UM WHICH IS HELPING TO
PROVIDE HOUSING STABILITY FOR
OLDER ADULTS AND PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES. UM, AS I MENTIONED
HOME SAFE IS INTEGRATED WITH
ADULT PROTECTIVE SERVICE. AND SO
IN THIS CASE, AS DOCTOR CEL
MENTIONED OFTEN, A LIFE CRISIS
CAN BE A PRECIPITANT TO
HOMELESSNESS, OFTEN HOMELESSNESS
FOR THE FIRST TIME AFTER 50.
OFTEN THOSE INDIVIDUALS CROSS
PATHS WITH THE A P S¼ SYSTEM,
AND SO THERE IS A MOMENT OF
INTERVENTION THERE THAT CAN
HAPPEN WHEN IT IS PAIRED WITH
HOME SAFE. IN THE PROGRAM. WE'RE
REALLY SUPPORTING OLDER ADULTS
TO HELP THEM INCREASE THEIR
INCOME AND TO HAVE STABLE INCOME
, WHICH CAN HELP THEM ACHIEVE
HOUSING STABILITY BY MAKING SURE
THAT THEY CAN CONSISTENTLY PAY
RENT. UM AND THAT THEY'RE ALSO
GETTING THEIR HOUSING SUPPORTS
RECOGNIZED AS THEY'RE WORKING
THROUGH THAT DISABILITY PROCESS,
WHICH CAN BE QUITE LENGTHY. UM I
ALSO WANT TO FLAG THAT THESE
PROGRAMS ARE UNIQUELY FLEXIBLE
AND THAT REALLY ALLOWS, UH EACH
OF OUR GRANTEES TO MEET THEIR,
UM ELIGIBLE PARTICIPANTS WHERE
THEY'RE AT, SO IT CAN MEAN SOME
PEOPLE MIGHT NEED HELP WITH
ARREARS TO PREVENT THEM FROM
LOSING A HOUSING PLACEMENT. SOME
PEOPLE MIGHT NEED HELP WITH A
DOWN PAYMENT FOR, OR, UM, UH,
FIRST MONTH'S RENT FOR AN
APARTMENT OR HELP TO BUY
FURNITURE, AND THOSE THINGS ARE
ALL POSSIBLE WITH THE FLEXIBLE
DOLLARS WITHIN OUR TWO PROGRAMS.
UM I NOW WANNA ADDRESS THE
QUESTION ABOUT IMPACTS OF THE
INVESTMENTS. SO AS I KNOW YOU'RE
ALL AWARE WE HAD VERY
SIGNIFICANT, UM ONE TIME
INVESTMENTS IN BOTH FISCAL YEAR
21 AND FISCAL YEAR 22 FOR BOTH
HÌ Dð A AND FOR HOME SAFE AND
THESE DOLLARS WERE MADE
AVAILABLE ACROSS MULTIPLE YEARS.
SO UM, ONCE, UH, STARTED SERVING
PEOPLE AND THROUGH JUNE OF 2020
THREE, UM WE HAVE HAD THREE 1003
145 PEOPLE OF PERMANENTLY HOUSED
THROUGH OUR PROGRAM. 9318
DISABILITY APPLICATIONS HAVE
BEEN SUBMITTED ON BEHALF OF
PARTICIPANTS AND 1881 DISABILITY
APPLICATIONS HAVE BEEN APPROVED.
UH, AFTER SIX MONTHS AFTER
EXITING THE PROGRAM, WE ARE
SEEING 84% OF PARTICIPANTS
RETAIN THEIR HOUSING, WHICH, AS
DR CASHEL MENTIONED IS A
SIGNIFICANT MARKER OF, UM
ATTAINING HOUSING, STABILITY AND
A THING WE'RE LOOKING AT VERY
CLOSELY, BECAUSE WE WANNA MAKE
SURE THAT THIS IS NOT A
TEMPORARY SOLUTION BUT A
PERMANENT SOLUTION. EACH STEP
HAS A 68% APPROVAL RATE ACROSS
ALL DISPOSED DISABILITY BENEFIT
APPLICATIONS. AND JUST FOR
COMPARISON, THE AVERAGE RATE OF
APPROVAL FOR THOSE BENEFITS IS
35. SO AND JUST WANNA FLAG THAT
WE OFTEN HAVE HÌ Dð PARTICIPANTS
STAY IN OUR PROGRAM OVER
MULTIPLE YEARS BECAUSE THE
DISABILITY BENEFIT APPLICATION
PROCESS CAN BE LENGTHY AND CAN,
UM, INVOLVE MULTIPLE APPEALS.
UH, PARTICIPANTS CAN STAY IN THE
PROGRAM WHILE THEY ARE
DISABILITY APPLICATION IS
PENDING, AND, UM, BEING WORKED
ON THROUGH APPEALS, AND THEN
THEY CAN CONTINUE TO RECEIVE THE
HOUSING SUPPORTS WHILE THEY STAY
ON THE PROGRAM OVER MULTIPLE
YEARS, UM ANOTHER, UH, INDICATOR
. I JUST WANNA FLAG IS THAT WE
REALLY HAVE SEEN HÌ Dð A, UM
INCREASE COLLABORATION ACROSS
KEY SYSTEMS. UM WE HAD, UM,
SURVEYS OUT AND 98% OF OUR
GRANTEES REPORT THAT THEY ARE
WORKING WITH HEALTH SYSTEMS AS
PART OF THEIR AGED APP WORK 88%
THAT THEY ARE COLLABORATING WITH
THE IN HOME SUPPORT OF SERVICES
SYSTEM AND 88% COLLABORATING
WITH PUBLIC HOUSING AUTHORITIES.
SO WE'RE REALLY PLEASED TO SEE
THAT, UM, AGAIN BECAUSE WE'RE
INTEGRATED WITH SOCIAL SERVICES.
THAT APP IS REALLY REACHING
ACROSS SYSTEMS AND NOT STAYING
SILOED. UM AND THEN FINALLY, I
WOULD JUST LIKE TO FLAG UM, A
COUPLE OF OUTCOMES AT PROGRAM
EXIT. UM WE ARE SEEING, UM, AND
WE HAVE, UH, RELEASED A REPORT.
UM WE'RE CALLING THE A B 120
REPORT BECAUSE IT WAS REQUIRED
OF US IN LAST YEAR'S BUDGET. UM
THAT 41% OF OUR PARTICIPANTS IN
HD APP ARE EXITING TO PERMANENT
HOUSING IN FISCAL YEAR 2220
THREE, UM AND WE WANNA CONTINUE
WITH THOSE, UM, GOOD NUMBERS AND
KEEPING, UH, PEOPLE UH, WORKING
THROUGH THE PROGRAM INTO
PERMANENT HOUSING. UM, I'D LIKE
TO SHARE ONE AGE GAP SUCCESS
STORY. UM A 57 YEAR OLD MAN CAME
INTO THE AGE DE PROGRAM FACING A
SITUATION THAT MANY OLDER ADULTS
WHO EXPERIENCE HOMELESSNESS FOR
THE FIRST TIME STRUGGLE WITH HE
HAD BECOME TOO DISABLED TO WORK
AND COULD NÓ LONGER AFFORD
HOUSING. HE INITIALLY DECLINED
TO PURSUE DISABILITY BENEFITS,
HOPING INSTEAD THAT HE WOULD
EVENTUALLY FIND AND MAINTAIN A
JOB. DURING THE PANDEMIC, HE
BECAME UNEMPLOYED AND THEN
HOMELESS AGAIN. AFTER MOVING
INTO INTERIM HOUSING THROUGH THE
REGIONAL CONTINUUM OF CARE, HE
WAS LINKED TO THE PROGRAM AND
DECIDED TO APPLY FOR SSI. HE WAS
DENIED SIX MONTHS LATER FOR THE
FIFTH TIME, BUT ALTHOUGH HE WAS
PREPARED TO GIVE UP STAFF
ENCOURAGED HIM AND TOGETHER THEY
FILED HIS FIRST APPEAL. ALSO IN
THAT SAME MONTH, HE WAS ABLE TO
SIGN A LEASE ON HIS OWN
APARTMENT FOR THE FIRST TIME IN
HIS LIFE AND MOVED INTO HIS
FIRST STABLE HOME IN YEARS. THE
PROGRAM LEVERAGED FEDERAL
SUBSIDIES TO PAY HIS RENT AND
SUPPORTED HIM IN MEETING BASIC
NEEDS. WHILE THE S¼ S¼ I APPEAL
WAS PURSUED. AND THEN IN JANUARY
OF 2023 18 MONTHS AFTER HE
APPLIED AND APPEALED, UM THIS
AGE DE PARTICIPANT, UH, RECEIVED
HIS DISABILITY BENEFITS AND HIS
BENEFITS WERE ACTIVATED. UM WE
WERE ABLE THROUGH THAT PROGRAM
TO ENSURE HE RECEIVED AN
EMERGENCY ADVANCE PAYMENT OF
$3000 TO COVER HIS COSTS WHILE
HE WAS WAITING FOR HIS
DISABILITY BENEFITS TO START AND
HE'S NOW RECEIVING $1113 A MONTH
IN S¼ S¼. I BENEFITS AND HE'S
OWED OVER $27,000 IN RETROACTIVE
BENEFITS, WHICH HE'LL RECEIVE
SOON. AND HE QUOTED BY SAYING,
I'VE LIVED WITH MENTAL ILLNESS
FOR 27 YEARS. THIS IS THE FIRST
TIME I'VE HAD ANY KIND OF
ASSISTANCE. I'M SO GRATEFUL. I
AM A SUCCESS STORY, SO WE'RE
PROUD TO BE ABLE TO SHARE THAT
STORY WITH YOU. UM NOW I'LL MOVE
ON TO PROGRAM IMPACTS AND
OUTCOMES AND KEY ACHIEVEMENTS
FOR HOME SAFE. SO AS OF JUNE
2020 THREE 8756 PEOPLE HAVE
RECEIVED ASSISTANCE THROUGH THE
HOME SAFE PROGRAM, AND WE HAVE
HAD 3555 INSTANCES OF HOUSING
RELATED FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE
PROVIDED ADDITIONALLY, WE HAVE
CONNECTED 2037 PEOPLE, UM TO THE
LOCAL CO ORDINATED ENTRY SYSTEM
THROUGH HOME SAFE. UM, DOCTOR,
CREEL'S, UM UM AND HER, UH, TEAM
AT THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA,
SAN FRANCISCO BE OFF
HOMELESSNESS AND HOUSING
INITIATIVE LED AN INTERIM
EVALUATION OF THE HOME SAFE
PILOT. SO IF YOU REMEMBER HOME
SAFE STARTED AS A PILOT, AND
THEN WHEN THE UM ADDITIONAL ONE
TIME FUNDS WERE ADDED IN 2021,
THE PROGRAM EXPANDED STATEWIDE.
UM FROM THAT INITIAL, UH,
FINDINGS. UM THERE WAS A FINDING
THAT HOUSING WAS RETAINED FOR
85% OF PARTICIPANTS IN HOME
SAFE, UM, AT SIX MONTHS. EXIT
FROM THE PROGRAM. UM IT WAS
FOUND THAT HOME SAFE HAS
FOSTERED STRONG RELATIONSHIPS
BETWEEN A P S¼ AND THE LARGER
NETWORK OF SOCIAL SERVICE
PROVIDERS THAT MAKE UP THE
CONTINUUM OF CARE. AND AGAIN, UM
, IT WAS FOUND THAT THE FLEXIBLE
DOLLARS AVAILABLE IN HOMES SAFE
WERE CRUCIAL TO THE PROGRAM'S
SUCCESS. UM IT APPEARED THAT AT
THAT POINT HOME SAFE WAS
STABILIZING CLIENTS WHO WOULD
HAVE OTHERWISE BECOME HOMELESS.
UM IN FY 2223 èC Dð S¼ S¼ HAS
CONTINUED ITS PARTNERSHIP WITH
UCSF TO FURTHER EVALUATE, UM,
HOME SAFE AND WE ANTICIPATE, UM,
EVALUATION FINDINGS TO BE
PUBLISHED IN EARLY 2026. SO WE
WILL HAVE, UM, ANOTHER
EVALUATION. UM NOW THAT THE
PROGRAM'S BEEN RUNNING LONGER
AND IS BROADER THROUGHOUT THE
STATE UM, HOME SAFE GRANTEES,
UM, ALSO REPORT TO CDS, S¼ THAT
THEY HAVE STRONG COLLABORATIONS
WITH OTHER PROGRAMS 96% ARE
COLLABORATING WITH IN HOME.
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES AND 74% ARE
COLLABORATING WITH THEIR MEDI
MANAGED CARE PLANS. UM AGAIN
HIGHLIGHTING SOME OUTCOMES. UM
WE'VE ALSO HIGHLIGHTED THAT IN
OUR A B 120 REPORT. UM WE ARE
SEEING THAT APPROXIMATELY 47% OF
PARTICIPANTS ARE EXITING FROM
HOME SAFE TO PERMANENT HOUSING
IN 2220 THREE. UM AND WE ALSO
WANT TO SHARE A STORY FROM HOME
SAFE, UM, FROM BUTTE COUNTY. OH,
AND I APOLOGIZE. OUR APP STORY
WAS FROM, UM L A COUNT FROM LOS
ANGELES COUNTY. WE ACTUALLY MOVE
ON TO QUESTION NUMBER THREE.
SURE. UM SO WE WERE ASKED TO
DISCUSS THE PROPOSED DELAYS OF
$50 MILLION IN HD APP AND $65
MILLION IN HOME SAFE THAT IS
PROPOSED TO BE IMPLEMENTED IN
2024 25. WE WERE ASKED HOW IT
WOULD IMPACT LOCAL PROGRAMS AND
WHETHER èC Dð S¼ S¼ IMPACTS.
EXCUSE ME ANTICIPATES THAT ANY
LOCAL HOME SAFE AND PROGRAMS
WOULD CLOSE OR SCALE BACK. UH,
IF FUNDING IS WITHHELD BY ONE
FISCAL YEAR. SO THANK YOU FOR
THOSE QUESTIONS FIRST. I WOULD
LIKE TO, UH, CLARIFY, UM, OUR
INTENT BEHIND THESE DELAYS AND
MAKE SURE THERE IS NÓ CONFUSION
ABOUT WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
ACCOMPLISH HERE. UM FIRST TO
CLARIFY THE IMP. UH, EXCUSE ME
IMPLEMENT THE PROPOSED DELAYS.
WE ARE SEEING THIS AS A RE
APPROPRIATION OF THE 2223 FUNDS
INTO THE 2526 FISCAL YEARS, SO
SIMPLY, WE ARE EXTENDING THE
TIMELINES FOR SPENDING THOSE ONE
TIME DOLLARS IN 2220 THREE. UM
WE ARE NOT INTENDING THROUGH
THIS PROPOSAL TO NEGATIVELY
IMPACT THESE PROGRAMS OR DISRUPT
SERVICE DELIVERY. UM, THE DATA
WE USE TO, UH IDENTIFY THE $50
MILLION IN AGE GAP IN THE $65
MILLION IN HOME SAFE WERE BASED
ON POINT IN TIME INFORMATION
THAT WE HAVE AND THAT WE
RECOGNIZE WE MAY NEED TO MAKE
ADJUSTMENTS IN MAY REVISION, SO
WE ARE CURRENTLY EVALUATING OUR
DATA. UM AS I THINK WE'VE, UM
MENTIONED IN PREVIOUS HEARINGS
ARE CLAIMING DATA COMES IN A
FAIRLY IN ARREARS FROM THE
ACTUAL SPENDING BY THE GRANTEES,
SO WE'RE ALWAYS PLAYING A LITTLE
BIT OF CATCH UP TO UNDERSTAND
ACTUAL EXPENDITURES IN THE
PROGRAM. BUT WE ARE LOOKING AT
THAT DATA SO THAT WE CAN
EVALUATE AND HAVE BETTER NUMBERS
IN MAY REVISION. TO PRESENT TO
THE, UM TO THE LEGISLATURE. UM
WE ARE ALSO AWARE THAT THIS, UM
IMPACT UH OR EXCUSE ME THAT WE
DON'T WISH TO IMPACT ANY OF THE
PROGRAMS BY DELAYING, UH,
FUNDING INTO 2526 AND THAT WE
LIKELY WILL HAVE UNEXPENDED
FUNDS THAT CAN BE DELAYED
STATEWIDE. HOWEVER WE WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THAT MAY NOT BE
TRUE IN EVERY SINGLE COUNTY IN
EVERY SINGLE LOCALITY. UM SO
THAT WE ARE WORKING CLOSELY WITH
THE COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION AND WITH COUNTIES TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT THEIR LOCAL
IMPACTS MAY BE, AND TO DETERMINE
WHETHER WE NEED TO TAKE ANY
ACTIONS TO MITIGATE. UM A
NEGATIVE IMPACTS FROM THESE
DELAYS. UM UH, FOR THOSE
PARTICULAR COUNTIES, UM I WILL
STOP THERE. UM, BUT JUST WANNA
MAKE SURE IT'S CLEAR THAT WE
REALLY ARE, UH, WANTING THESE
PROGRAMS TO CONTINUE. WE WANT
THE GOOD WORK OF GRANTEES TO
CONTINUE AND WE BELIEVE THE
DELAYS CAN APPROPRIATELY, UM,
SAVE THE STATE MONEY IN 2425,
WHILE ALLOWING THE PROGRAMS TO
FULLY EXPEND THE ONE TIME
DOLLARS UM INTO 2526. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH, UH, CHIEF
DEPUTY DIRECTOR MOVING ON TO
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. CAN YOU
TELL ME HOW TO PRONOUNCE YOUR
FIRST NAME? GOOD MORNING CHAIR.
I'M ITALIS PEREZ DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. THANK YOU. EACH
RECEIVED A TOTAL OF $300 MILLION
GENERAL FUND OVER TWO YEARS,
BEGINNING IN THE 2021 BUDGET.
ADDITIONALLY HÌ Dð RECEIVED $25
MILLION GENERAL FUND ONGOING
SINCE THE 2019 BUDGET ACT. AS
FOR HOME SAFE, THE PROGRAM
RECEIVED A TOTAL OF 100 AND $85
MILLION GENERAL FUND OVER TWO
YEARS, BEGINNING IN THE 2021
BUDGET ACT. BOTH PROGRAMS. ONE
TIME APPROPRIATIONS ARE MATCH
EXEMPT, WHICH MEANS COUNTIES ARE
NOT CURRENTLY REQUIRED TO
CONTRIBUTE A DOLLAR FOR DOLLAR
MATCH GUARANTEE FOR THESE FUNDS.
AS REFLECTED IN YOUR AGENDA. THE
A B 120 HÌ HÌ Dð ANNUAL REPORT
SHOWS THAT BASED ON JUNE 30TH
2020 THREE POINT IN TIME
ESTIMATES THE TOTAL REMAINING
AMOUNT OF ONE TIME FUNDS FOR HÌ
Tð IS 100 AND $77 MILLION
GENERAL FUND AND HOME SAFE IS
100 AND $27 MILLION GENERAL
FUND. THE INTENT OF THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. PROPOSALS FOR
HÌ Dð AND HOPE SAFE IS TO ALIGN
THE AUTHORITY WITH HOW COUNTIES
ARE USING THEIR FUNDS. THE
AMOUNTS TO DETERMINE THESE
SHIFTS IN FUNDS ARE BASED ON
POINT IN TIME DATA AND COUNTY
AND TRIBE SPENDING TRENDS. THIS
WILL OVERALL HELP COUNTIES HAVE
AN ADDITIONAL YEAR TO SPEND
THESE REMAINING FUNDS FOR THE
PROGRAMS. WE WILL ASSESS AS
NECESSARY IF THERE ARE ANY
UPDATES TO THIS POINT IN TIME
EXPENDITURES. THANK YOU SO MUCH,
UM, NOW MOVING ON TO KELLY
CARPENTER, WHO'S A PROGRAM
MANAGER OF ADULT SERVICES IN
NEVADA COUNTY. GOOD MORNING,
MADAM. UH, MADAM, CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. UM, I'M HERE TO JUST,
UH, GIVE A BRIEF SUMMARY OF THE
HOME SAFE PROGRAM AT THE COUNTY
LEVEL. UH, NEVADA COUNTY WAS
PART OF THE ORIGINAL PILOT IN
1910 2019 IN NEVADA COUNTY IS
RURAL WITH A POPULATION OF ABOUT
100. THREE 1000 WITH 37% OF THE
POPULATION BEING OVER 65. WE
DEVELOPED OUR SPECIFIC HOME SAFE
CRITERIA. CHECKLISTS PROGRAM
INTAKE FLOW CHARTS AND INTENDED
ALL OF OUR LOCAL COMMUNITY
PARTNER MEETINGS TO COLLABORATE
WITH OUR HOMELESS OUTREACH TEAM.
OUR AGING AND DISABILITY
RESOURCE CENTERS. HOSPITALS UH,
AND OUR BEHAVIORAL, HEALTH AND
SOCIAL SERVICES DEPARTMENT AND
WE ACTIVELY HAVE WORKED WITH
THEM FOR THE LAST FIVE YEARS AND
BRIGHT AT OUR FUNDING TOGETHER
TO SUPPORT OUR COMMUNITY. WE
ALSO MET WITH OUR FISCAL
DEPARTMENT TO SHARE THE PROGRAM
DETAILS AND VÀ AND VERIFY THE
REALISTIC TIMING TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE WERE ABLE TO PROVIDE THE
SUPPORT. AT THE COUNTY LEVEL. UM
AND THEY COMMITTED TO A TWO WEEK
TURNAROUND TIME ON BEING ABLE TO
ISSUE CHECKS TO HELP OUR
CLIENTS. WE MANAGE THE HOME SAFE
PROGRAM IN HOUSE WITH OUR
CURRENT ÁP S¼ TEAM OF TWO AND
ALL OF THE A P S¼ CASES AND HOME
SAFE CASES ARE REVIEWED BY
MYSELF AS A PROGRAM MANAGER AND
THE SUPERVISOR OF MY TEAM FOR
PAYMENT AUTHORIZATION. HOME SAFE
HAS BEEN A GAME CHANGER FOR US.
IT REALLY HAS BEEN ABLE TO MAKE
NEEDED COMMUNITY REFERRALS TO
RETAIN HOUSING AND HAVE THE
FUNDS TO ASSIST OUR CLIENTS IS
TRULY MEANINGFUL SUPPORT. PRIOR
TO HOME SAFE, OUR ÁP S¼ SOCIAL
WORKERS WERE ABLE TO OFFER
COMMUNITY REFERRALS TO IMPROVE
THEIR SITUATION. BUT MOST OFTEN,
THE CLIENTS DIDN'T HAVE THE
RESOURCES TO PURSUE THE
REFERRALS. DURING OUR HOME SAFE
FUNDING STREAMS, OUR COUNTIES
EXPERIENCED SIGNIFICANT WINTER
STORMS TWO YEARS IN A ROW AND
ALSO COVID WAS THROWN IN THE
MIX. WE SERVED 250 THREE CLIENTS
. WITH HOPE SAFE. WE ASSISTED
100 AND 28 CLIENTS WITH NEW
HOUSING OR SUSTAINED HOUSING. WE
ASSISTED 125 CLIENTS WITH
HOUSING RELATED SUPPORT,
WRAPAROUND SERVICES, UM, THAT
WOULD BE HANDICAP RAMPS, HAZARD
REMOVAL, MOBILE HOME ROOFS,
HOARDING CLEANUP. WE RECEIVED
APPROXIMATELY $158,000 IN OUR
AVERAGE COST PER CLIENT WAS
ABOUT 2200. THE AVERAGE CLIENT
SERVED WAS 65 YEARS OF AGE AND
50% 58% OF THOSE, UH FOLKS WERE
FEMALE AND 42% WERE MALE. I
WANTED TO CIRCLE BACK ON
MEANINGFUL SUPPORT AND SHARE A
STORY OF AN A P S¼ STORY. WE HAD
AN ELDERLY WOMAN WHO WAS LIVING
WITH HER MENTALLY ILL SON. UM
AND HE WAS USING HER MONEY AND
KIND OF HAD TAKEN OVER HER HOME,
UM, DURING ONE OF HIS MENTAL
HEALTH BREAKS. UH HE, UM, DOUSED
HER WITH VODKA AND ATTEMPTED TO
LIGHT HER ON FIRE. THANK
GOODNESS. UH SHE WAS ABLE TO GET
TO HER CELL PHONE AND CALLED FOR
911 SERVICES, AND HE WAS
ARRESTED ON THE SCENE. SO PRIOR
TO HOMES SAFE, WE WOULD HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO OFFER HER VICTIM
WITNESS SUPPORT AND COUNSELING.
BUT WITH HOME SAFE SUPPORT FUNDS
, WE WERE ABLE TO OFFER THOSE
THINGS AS WELL. BUT ALSO WE WERE
ABLE TO PAY HER BACK RENT CHANGE
THE LOCKS ON OUR MOBILE HOME.
AND CLEANED UP HER HOME. I MEAN
THAT THAT WAS TRULY A SUCCESS
STORY FOR US, UM, SO HOME SAFE
FUNDING AT THE COMMUNITY LEVEL
IS SO VERY IMPORTANT AND HOME
SAFE IS MEANINGFUL SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR SHARING
THAT STORY. I'M JOINING US FROM,
UH, THE SAN FRANCISCO HUMAN
SERVICE AGENCY. SUSIE SMITH,
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF POLICY
PLANNING AND PUBLIC AFFAIRS. HØI
THANK YOU FOR HAVING THIS PANEL.
UM I JUST WANNA START. SO WE'RE
GONNA TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT HD
APP. UM, WHAT WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
DO HERE IN SAN FRANCISCO WITH
THE EXPANDED FUNDING AND WHAT
THE IMPACT ON A ONE YEAR DELAY
IN FUNDING WOULD BE, UM, I JUST
WANT TO START BY REMINDING US
YOU KNOW THAT THE HÌ Dð PROGRAM
IT'S SERVING PEOPLE WHO ARE
DISABLED AND HOMELESS. SO A
PRETTY VULNERABLE POPULATION. WE
HAVE FOUND THAT, UM EACH STEP
HAS PROVEN TO BE AN EFFECTIVE
MULTIYEAR STRATEGY TO MOVING
PEOPLE WHO ARE DISABLED AND
HOMELESS INTO HOUSING, AS WELL
AS ACCESSING MEDICAL CARE AND A
STEADY STREAM OF INCOME. IT
TAKES TIME TO TAKE ROOT AND SEE
THE OUTCOMES. UM AS OTHER PEOPLE
HAVE MENTIONED IT GETTING S¼ S¼
I CAN TAKE. I MEAN HERE IN SAN
FRANCISCO, ON AVERAGE ABOUT 18
MONTHS. I KNOW ELSEWHERE. IT'S
MUCH LONGER THAN THAT. THAT
EXPANDED FUNDING HAS BEEN
TRANSFORMATIVE FOR US IN TWO
WAYS. ONE WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
DOUBLE THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE THAT
WE SERVE IN SAN FRANCISCO. AND
SECONDLY, IT'S ENABLED US TO
DEVELOP AN ENTIRELY NEW MODEL
WHERE WE NOW HAVE A
MULTIDISCIPLINARY TEAM THAT GOES
FROM SHELTER TO SHELTER, HELPING
PEOPLE EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS
AND ROLE IN A VARIETY OF
SERVICES. WE HAVE A TEAM OF
NONPROFIT AND CITY WORKERS WHO
SCREEN PEOPLE FOR ELIGIBILITY
FOR PERMANENT HOUSING IN THE
SHELTERS. WE HELP WITH BENEFITS
APPLICATIONS, SO MEDI CAL FRESH
GENERAL ASSIST. AND WE SCREEN
FOR HÌ UP AND HOME SAFE AGAIN,
BRINGING ALL OF THESE SERVICES
DIRECTLY TO THE PEOPLE IN NEED.
UM SINCE THE EXPANDED FUNDING,
UM TOOK EFFECT WE'VE BEEN ABLE
TO VISIT 21, DIFFERENT SHELTERS
AND NAVIGATION CENTERS ACROSS
OUR CITY AND ROLLING THEM IN
THESE VARIETY OF BENEFITS. AND
WE HAVE OUTCOMES SO WE CAN BE
PROUD OF WE'VE SUPPORTED 235
DISABLED HOMELESS FOLKS THROUGH
THIS PROGRAM. WE HAVE AN S¼ SI
AWARD RATE OF 77. AND, AS WAS
MENTIONED EARLIER. THE NATIONAL
AVERAGE IS 31. SO WE ARE GIVING
AGAIN HOMELESS FOLKS OR DISABLED
THE STEADY STREAM OF INCOME IN
TERMS OF HOUSING. UM OUR SOCIAL
WORKERS HELP AGE THAT
PARTICIPANTS THROUGH THE
COMPLICATED PROCESS OF SECURING
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING.
EVEN IF YOU ARE PRIORITIZED FOR
THAT HOUSING, IT TAKES TIME AND
INTENSIVE SOCIAL WORK AND
NAVIGATION TO ACTUALLY GET INTO
THAT UNIT 75% OF OUR EACH STEP
PARTICIPANTS ARE NOW PERMANENTLY
HOUSED. AND AGAIN. THIS IS
THROUGH THE EXPANDED FUNDING,
WHICH WAS FIVE TIMES THE AMOUNT
THAT WE HAD GOTTEN FROM 1
MILLION TO 5 MILLION. SO THIS IS
PROVIDING REAL, UM, DIRECT REAL
TIME ACCESS TO THESE SUPPORTS.
IT'S ENABLING US TO MAINTAIN
RELATIONSHIPS THAT THEN HELP US
BUILD THE S¼ S¼ I ADVOCACY CASE
AND ENABLE US TO BE SUCCESSFUL.
UM, I HAVE A SUCCESS STORY I CAN
SHARE. UM SO WHEN TO SHARE THE
STORY OF JOHNNY, A 40 THREE YEAR
OLD MAN WHO HAD BEEN ASSAULTED
MULTIPLE TIMES, LIVING ON THE
STREETS AND IN SHELTERS DUE TO
TRAUMATIC BRAIN INJURIES. HE WAS
ONE OF THE HIGHEST UTILIZES OF
SF GENERAL HOSPITAL EMERGENCY
CARE. HIS BRAIN INJURIES MADE IT
DIFFICULT FOR HIM TO
COMMUNICATE. BUT THROUGH THE
SUPPORT OF THE AGED APP, SOCIAL
WORKER AND LEGAL TEAM, HE HAS
BEEN ABLE TO DEVELOP A POSITIVE
RELATIONSHIP WITH HIS DOCTOR.
WHO HE SEES MONTHLY. HE'S SEEN A
NEUROLOGIST AND IS AND IS
GETTING REGULAR SPEECH THERAPY
AND OCCUPATIONAL THERAPY AND
BECAUSE OF THAT POSITIVE
RELATIONSHIP WITH HIS DOCTOR
THAT WAS THROUGH THE CONNECTION
OF EACH APP. HE NÓ LONGER USES
THE ER AS HIS PRIMARY SOURCE OF
MEDICAL CARE. SO THERE ARE THESE
OTHER SYSTEMS LEVEL IMPACTS,
WHICH I THINK IS REALLY
IMPORTANT TO MENTION. UM AND
THAT CONNECTION TO MEDICAL CARE
ENABLED US TO BUILD THE S¼ S¼ I
CASE ABOUT A YEAR AGO, HIS S¼ S¼
I CASE WAS AWARDED AND SHORTLY
AFTER HE MOVED INTO A QUIET,
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING BUILDING
WHERE THE ON SITE SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES HAS ENABLED HIM TO
MAINTAIN HOUSING STABILITY. SO
WHAT IS THE BIG DEAL ABOUT
DELAYING OUR FUNDING FOR ONE
YEAR? RIGHT THAT'S THE QUESTION
ABOUT THIS HEARING, AND SO I
JUST WANT TO SHARE KIND OF WHAT
THAT MEANS LOCALLY. SO FOR US,
UM, OUR NEXT YEAR'S BUDGET, FY
2425 BUDGET WOULD BE REDUCED BY
$2.8 MILLION, WHICH IS ALMOST
80% OF OUR BUDGET NEXT YEAR. UM
OUR CONTRACTOR BAY AREA LEGAL
AID. UM THEIR FY 2425 CONTRACT
WOULD HAVE TO BE REDUCED BY TWO
THIRDS. WE'D HAVE TO STOP NEW
ENROLLMENTS. SO WE WERE LOOKING
AT ABOUT 70 DISABLED HOMELESS
ADULTS THAT WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO
BE SERVED. SO IT THERE IS A REAL
IMPACT IN TERMS OF STOPPING
ENROLLMENT. SO I WANNA BE REALLY
CLEAR ON THAT. UM 30 TO 40% OF
OUR EXISTING CLIENTS WOULD BE IN
JEOPARDY OF LOSING LEGAL
REPRESENTATION AND SOCIAL WORK
SUPPORT, WHICH IS AGAINST THE
LEGAL AND MORAL OBLIGATIONS WHEN
AN ATTORNEY TAKES ON A CASE. SO
THE SO THE LIMITED SORT OF IN AS
I MENTIONED IT'S A MULTIYEAR
PROGRAM, SO HAVING FUNDING THAT
IS SORT OF STOPS AND THEN STARTS
AND THEN STOPS AGAIN MAKES IT
REALLY DIFFICULT. WITH THE
INCREASED FUNDING, WE WERE ABLE
TO RAMP UP QUICKLY TO MEET THE
NEED. OUR NONPROFIT PARTNERS
HIRED STAFF WHO NEEDED TO BE ON
BOARDED AND TRAINED, AND IT'S A
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT IN THE
FIRST YEAR OF A PROGRAM. UM IF
THEY HAD TO REDUCE THE STAFF
NEXT YEAR DUE TO THIS BIG
DECLINE. I MEAN, WHAT THEY'VE
TOLD US IS THEY'RE UNLIKELY.
RAMP BACK UP AGAIN. A NONPROFIT
CAN'T JUST, YOU KNOW, INCREASE
FUNDING BY TWO THIRDS DECREASE
BY TWO THIRDS AND THEN INCREASE
IT IT. YOU CAN'T RUN A PROGRAM
OR AN ORGANIZATION THAT WAY. UM
SO IT PROVIDES A DIFFICULTY IN A
LONG IN A IN A, YOU KNOW, A
PROGRAM A STRATEGY THAT IS MULTI
YEAR AND IT PROVIDES UNCERTAINTY
FOR BOTH PARTICIPANTS AND STAFF.
AND SO WE WOULD SEE A DISRUPTION
IN SERVICES. AT THE SAME TIME. I
DON'T ENVY ANY OF THE MEMBERS OF
THE LEGISLATURE HAVING TO MAKE
THE DIFFICULT DECISIONS THAT
NEED TO BE MADE THIS YEAR. UM TO
CLOSE THE DEFICIT. I KNOW THAT
èC WJ IS WORKING WITH èC, Dð,
S¼, S¼ AND COUNTIES TO TRY TO
FIGURE OUT WHETHER AND HOW A
DELAY WOULD BE OPERATIONALIZED
AND WHAT AMOUNT OF FUNDING WOULD
ACTUALLY BE DELAYED IN THE END,
BUT I GUESS ONE OF THE QUESTIONS
OR REQUESTS I HAVE IS LOOKING AT
REALLOCATING UNDERSPENDING AND
SEEING WHERE THERE ARE DIRECT
IMPACTS IN TRYING TO MITIGATE
THAT BY, YOU KNOW, LOOKING AT
COUNTIES THAT WEREN'T TO USE THE
MONEY AS EFFECTIVELY AND ALSO
LOOKING AT WHETHER A LESSER
AMOUNT CAN BE DELAYED BECAUSE A
TWO THIRDS IMPACT FOR OUR
PROVIDERS AND 80 ALMOST 80% I
DIDN'T TALK ABOUT THE IMPACT ON
OUR STAFF. I WAS JUST TALKING
ABOUT THE PROVIDERS, BUT AN
HONEST 80% CUT IN ONE YEAR HAS
REAL IMPACT. AND SO MAYBE THERE
COULD BE A LESS SEVERE. VERSION
OF THIS HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. I'M SORRY. I THINK I
WENT OVER FIVE MINUTES. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. UM, NEXT UP IS
REPRESENTING JUSTICE IN AGING.
UM PATTY PRUNE HOOVER. THANK YOU
. GOOD MORNING, CHAIRMAN OF OUR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. MY NAME IS
PATTY PRUER. I'M THE DIRECTOR OF
HOUSING ADVOCACY AT JUSTICE AND
AGING. UH, I WANNA THANK YOU FOR
HOLDING THIS HEARING AS WELL AND
INVITING ME BACK THIS YEAR TO
SPEAK ABOUT THE IMPACT OF THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSED DELAYS
IN FUNDING FOR THE HOME SAFE AND
HOUSING, DISABILITY AND
ADVOCACY. AS WE CALL IT HÌ Dð
PROGRAMS. UM YOU KNOW, JUSTICE
IN AGING IS A LEGAL ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION. WE USE THE POWER
OF LAW TO FIGHT SENIOR POVERTY,
ENSURE ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE,
ECONOMIC, SECURITY AND HOUSING
TO ADVANCE EQUITY. AS WE AGE.
WE'RE ALSO DEEPLY INVOLVED IN
IMPLEMENTING THE CALIFORNIA
MASTER PLAN FOR AGING SO THAT
EVERY CALIFORNIAN HAS ACCESS TO
THE HOUSING, HEALTH CARE
SERVICES AND SUPPORTS AND
ECONOMIC SECURITY TO THRIVE AS
THEY AGE. THESE TWO PROGRAMS ARE
A KEY ACCOMPLISHMENT AND GOAL OF
PREVENTING AND ENDING
HOMELESSNESS AMONG OLDER ADULTS
AND PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES AND
HAVE BEEN TOUTED AS PART OF OUR
SUCCESS. WE ARE CONCERNED THAT
HOME SAFE AND AGED APP ARE THE
ONLY TWO STATEWIDE PROGRAMS THAT
EXIST TO SPECIFICALLY MEET THE
HOUSING, STABILITY AND SERVICE
NEEDS OF OLDER AND DISABLED
ADULTS WHO ARE AT EITHER
IMMINENT RISK OR CURRENTLY
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS. I
WANNA HEARKEN TO, UM, DOCTOR
KEL'S EXCELLENT, UH, OVERVIEW OF
WHAT IS HAPPENING WITH OLDER
ADULTS AND HOMELESSNESS. AND I
HAVE ALSO GIVEN YOU, UH, OUR
PAPER HOT OFF THE PRESS. UM AND
HOW CALIFORNIA'S OLDER, LOW
INCOME RENTERS ARE BEING
SQUEEZED BY HOUSING.
UNAFFORDABILITY UM AND THAT IS
WHAT IS DRIVING THIS AGE GROUP
BEING THE FASTEST GROWING GROUP
AGING INTO HOMELESSNESS, AND WE
SHOULDN'T BE SAYING THOSE WORDS
TOGETHER AGING INTO
HOMELESSNESS. SO, UM PROPOSED
FUNDING DELAYS ARE ARE NOT GOING
TO BE WITHOUT A LOT OF PAIN. UM
THE DELAYS OF 65 MILLION FOR THE
HOME SAFE PROGRAM AND 50 MILLION
FOR THE, UM HÌ Dð A WOULD FORCE
COUNTIES AND TRIBAL ENTITIES TO
SEVERELY CURTAIL THEIR HOUSING,
STABILITY AND HOMELESS
PREVENTION SERVICES CURRENTLY
PROVIDED TO THIS POPULATION AND
TO DO SO, AT A TIME WHEN ADULT
HOUSING INSTABILITY AND
HOMELESSNESS IS SPIKING. UM SO,
UM, THERE'S BEEN AN EXCELLENT
BACKGROUND ON THE HOME SAFE AND
DE PROGRAMS PROVIDED TO YOU IN
THE AGENDA AND BY CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR RAMSEY AND YOU'VE HEARD
GREAT TESTIMONY ABOUT HOW THESE
PROGRAMS OPERATE IN INDIVIDUAL
COUNTIES. I JUST WANT TO GIVE A
LITTLE MORE PICTURE OF HOW, UM
TH THIS RAMP UP THAT HAPPENED IN
2021, AND I THINK, UM COUNTIES
HAVE DESCRIBED HOW IT TAKES TIME
TO, UM, ABSORB THE GOOD FUNDING
INCREASES AND TO BUILD SYSTEMS
AND SO, UM LOCAL PROGRAMS WORK
TO RAMP UP EACH OF THESE
PROGRAMS, BUT IT TOOK A WHILE TO
HIRE STAFF ASSEMBLE
MULTIDISCIPLINARY TEAMS SIGNED
CONTRACTS WITH HOMELESS SERVICE
PROVIDERS. AND THE MORE RECENT
NUMBERS THAT, UM, DIRECTOR
RAMSEY GAVE, UH, REALLY GIVE YOU
A PICTURE OF HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE
BEING SERVED. UM IT'S A DROP IN
THE BUCKET. I WOULD LIKE TO BE
HERE ASKING YOU TO EXPAND THESE
PROGRAMS. UM I KNOW THAT'S NOT
IN THE BUDGET CARDS FOR THIS
YEAR, BUT THAT'S WHAT WE SHOULD
BE DOING TO ADDRESS THIS CRISIS.
UM SO WHAT IS THE IMPACT OF
DELAYING THAT FUNDING? UH, FIRST
, I WANT TO POINT OUT THAT THAT,
UM POINT IN TIME DATA THAT WAS
USED BY THE DEPARTMENT IS REALLY
IMPORTANT, BUT IT IT HAS TWO LAG
TIMES. IT IS, UH, THAT THE
COUNTIES DELAY IN BEING ABLE TO
SUBMIT, UH, CLAIMS FOR
REIMBURSEMENT, BUT IT ALSO WAS
DONE AS OF JUNE OF 2020. THREE
SO WE'RE A YEAR BEHIND. PLUS
WHATEVER LAG TIME, UM IS, UM
HAPPENING AS A RESULT OF
BUREAUCRACY AND, UM I THINK THAT
WE WILL SEE THAT THERE'S NÓ. UM
WELL, THEY'RE ABOUT NINE
COUNTIES THAT INCLUDING SAN
FRANCISCO THAT ARE SCHEDULED TO
RUN OUT OF THEIR MONEY AT THE
END OF THIS YEAR, AND SO WITHOUT
, UH ADDITIONAL FUNDING OR A
REALLOCATION. WE ARE GONNA SEE
CUTBACKS. THERE'S NÓ WAY AROUND
IT. AND THIS HAS BEEN TOUCHED ON
. I'LL JUST MENTION IT. THE
UNCERTAINTY OF CONTINUED FUNDING
REALLY THREATENS TO CURTAIL THE
PROGRESS WE'VE MADE AT A TIME
WHEN HOMELESSNESS IS GROWING AT
AN ALARMING RATES. WE SHOULDN'T
BE CUTTING BACK THESE SERVICES
AND THEN RAMPING UP AGAIN. WHEN
THE BUDGET PICTURE IS BETTER. IT
HAS ITS OWN PROBLEMS. SO FOR
HOME SAFE, WHICH IS THE PROGRAM
I WORK WITH MOST CLOSELY, UM
THERE WAS NÓ HOME SAFE FUNDING
IN THE LAST BUDGET YEAR, SO
COUNTIES HAVE ALREADY BEEN ASKED
TO USE THE TWO YEARS OF FUNDING
THEY GOT IN FISCAL YEAR. 21 AND
22 TO COVER FISCAL YEAR 23
EXPENDITURES. AND SO NOW THEY'RE
BEING SAYING OH, NÓ USE IT
ANOTHER YEAR, BUT THERE IS NÓ
NEW MONEY. I JUST WANNA MAKE
CLEAR THAT IT'S NOT AS IF
THERE'S ANOTHER EXPENDITURE
THAT'S GOING TO BE APPLIED. UM
AND THE TOTAL TWO YEAR
ALLOCATION, UM, SENT TO LOCAL
GRANTEES, WHICH WAS AS PEOPLE
SAID TRANSFORMATIVE, UM WAS
ABOUT 100 AND 66 MILLION. UM UH,
AS SOMEBODY MENTIONED OF, UH, 85
MILLION IN EACH YEAR, BUT A
CERTAIN PORTION STAYS WITH THE
DEPARTMENT FOR, UH, THEIR
FUNCTIONS. UM SO A $65 MILLION
DELAY. UM STRETCHES THE TOTAL
DOLLARS FOR AN ADDITIONAL YEAR
AND REPRESENTS A 39% REDUCTION
IN FUNDING THAT GOES TO THE
COUNTIES JUST WHEN THESE
PROGRAMS ARE REACHING FULL
OPERATIONAL CAPACITY. UM I
MENTIONED THAT THERE ARE
COUNTIES THAT ARE RUNNING OUT OF
THEIR MONEY. AND FOR THAT REASON
, JUSTICE AND AGING WOULD
SUPPORT BOTH TRYING TO, UM USE
CURRENT DATA TO REFLECT WHAT'S
REALLY LEFT AVAILABLE SO THAT IT
ISN'T A CUT BUT ALSO TO SUPPORT
THE DEPARTMENT HAVING THE
AUTHORITY TO REALLOCATE UNSPENT
FUNDS AMONG THE COUNTIES FOR
THOSE COUNTIES THAT ARE MORE
LIKELY TO RUN OUT OF MONEY IN
THIS NEXT FISCAL YEAR. ANY FINAL
THOUGHTS. YEAH, THANK YOU. UM I
JUST WANT TO POINT YOU TO, UM,
THIS REPORT. WHICH REALLY POINTS
OUT THAT, UM THE NUMBER OF OLDER
ADULTS SEEKING HOMELESS SERVICES
HAS MORE THAN DOUBLED IN THE
LAST SIX YEARS. WE HAVE A CRISIS
THAT WE NEED TO ADDRESS AND THE
FINAL POINT IS THAT, UM WE HAVE
A RETURN ON INVESTMENT HERE WHEN
WE INVEST IN HOMELESS PREVENTION
WHEN WE CAN GET PEOPLE HOUSED
WHEN WE CAN GET THEM ON
DISABILITY BENEFITS. WE NOT ONLY
INCREASE THE SUCCESS ON THOSE
CLAIMS WHEN HIGH TIERS OF
SERVICES GO FROM UNHOUSED TO
HOUSE THAT RESULTS IN COST
SAVINGS THROUGH REDUCED ER
VISITS, HOSPITALIZATIONS,
PSYCHIATRIC HOSPITALIZATIONS,
LOWER RATES OF REINCARCERATION
INCARCERATION AND WE WILL
INADVERTENTLY UM, CAUSE
EXPENDITURES IN OTHER AREAS IN
ADDITION TO THE HUMAN TRAGEDY OF
IT, IF WE DO NOT KEEP THESE
PROGRAMS GOING, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. APPRECIATE IT. L A Ó G
ONE, G ONE YOU WANT YOU WANT ANY
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS? ADD TO
THIS. YES. THANK YOU, MA'AM
CHAIRS. UM JUAN TROTTER WITH THE
LI LIP ANALYST OFFICE. SO IN
GOING THROUGH THESE DELAYS, UM
THESE PROPOSED DELAYS. ONE OF
OUR MAIN QUESTIONS HAS BEEN, UM
HOW MUCH FUNDING UM, WILL BE
LEFT BEHIND FOR EXPENDITURE. UM,
IN THE BUDGET YEAR. SO, FOR
EXAMPLE, DOES, UM WILL THIS
LEAVE ENOUGH MONEY? TO MAINTAIN
CURRENT, UM, SERVICE LEVELS. OR
WILL CURRENT SERVICE LEVELS NEED
TO BE REDUCED TO, UM, REFLECT
THE REDUCTION IN FUNDING, AND SO
AS HAS BEEN MENTIONED. UM IF THE
ATTEND IS TO LEAVE ENOUGH
FUNDING TO MAINTAIN CURRENT
SERVICE LEVELS. WILL THIS ALSO
BE REFLECTED ON A COUNTY BY
COUNTY BASIS? UM AS THE AGENDA
HAS, UM, MEANT INDICATED. NOT
ALL THE FUNDING FOR THIS PROGRAM
HAS BEEN SPENT TO DATE. UM AND
IS OUR UNDERSTANDING THAT, UM
THAT, UM, FUNDING FROM PREVIOUS
BUDGET ALLOCATIONS. UM THOSE
REMAIN TO BE SPENT IN, UM IN
BUDGET YEAR. AND ALSO TO AS ALSO
HAS BEEN MENTIONED. UM,
PREVIOUSLY WE ALSO ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT, UM THESE REVISED OR THESE,
UM, DELAYS ARE REFLECTION OF
POINT IN TIME DATA. UM AND THAT
THESE WILL BE REVISITED AS WE
GET CLOSER TO MY REVISION. UM
AND SO WE THINK THAT THAT WOULD
BE A GOOD TIME FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO GET A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF, UM, THE BUDGET
FUNDING LEVELS ON A COUNTY BY
COUNTY BASIS. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. UM LET'S LET'S
START WITH THAT LAST POINT. I. I
KNOW YOU MENTIONED THAT THERE
ARE SOME COUNTIES THAT HAVE
UTILIZED MORE OF THEIR FUNDING
AND OTHERS THAT HAVE NOT. WE'VE
HEARD FROM ONE OF THEM. THAT
WOULD RUN NOW. ARE WE LOOKING?
YOU SPOKE A LITTLE BIT TO THIS
LOOKING AT A MODEL WHERE WE'RE
REALLOCATING IT WHERE WE'RE, YOU
KNOW, FOR THE ONES THAT ARE
GONNA RUN OUT THIS YEAR TO
POTENTIALLY MAKE THEM SURVIVE
ANOTHER YEAR. UM THANK YOU FOR
THAT QUESTION. YES WE ARE HAVING
CONVERSATIONS WITH èC W Dð, A
AND THE COUNTIES. WHAT IS
POSSIBLE? WE REFER TO IT AS
REDISTRIBUTION. BUT UM, UH
BETWEEN COUNTIES WHO MAY BE SOME
, UH, GETTING CLOSE TO HITTING
THEIR LIMIT OR SPENDING DOWN
THEIR ENTIRE ALLOCATION AND
OTHER COUNTIES WHO DID TAKE
LONGER TO RAMP UP WHO MAY HAVE
MORE MONEY. UM THAT COULD BE
SHIFTED OVER. SO WE ARE LOOKING
AT THAT. AND WE ARE LOOKING, UM,
TO HAVE OUR DATA THROUGH THE END
OF, UH, LAST YEAR. SO THROUGH
THE, UH, FIRST TWO QUARTERS OF
THE 2324 YEAR, AND WE'VE SHARED
SOME DATA WITH, UH, THE COUNTIES
SO WE CAN START TO LOOK AT, UM
WHAT IS AVAILABLE BETWEEN
COUNTIES AND WHERE SOME COUNTIES
MAY HAVE UNDERSPENT WHERE
COUNTIES ARE AT RISK OF RUNNING
OUT OF MONEY? I MEAN, PATTY, I'M
SO GLAD YOU BROUGHT UP THE
MASTER PLAN ON AGING BECAUSE I
MEAN, THAT'S KEY. HERE, RIGHT?
GO ONE. IS HOUSING AND I EVEN
WROTE, YOU KNOW, GO ONE
INITIATIVE THREE ADDRESS.
HOUSING NEEDS ACCESS TO
INTEGRATED MODELS ABLE TO REMAIN
IN HOMES AND COMMUNITY AND AGED
APP AND HOME SAFE PROGRAM DOES
JUST THAT. I'M AND I'M GLAD THAT
WE'RE GETTING SOME REPORTS ON
ANALYZING THESE PROGRAMS BECAUSE
THAT'S ALSO PART OF THE MASTER
PLAN ON AGING ON GO FIVE
INITIATIVE, 88 SPECIFICALLY
TALKS ON ABOUT HOME SAFE AND
AGED UP AND HAVING ANALYZED THE
SUCCESS OF THE STORIES AND
HEARING STORIES FROM YOU HEARING
STORIES FROM THE COUNTIES. THIS
IS A VERY EXTREMELY UM,
BENEFICIAL PROGRAM THAT IS
REALLY GONNA HELP WITH THIS
SILVER TSUNAMI THAT WE'RE GONNA
BE SEEING IN 2030 IT AND FINDING
A WAY I KNOW YOU MENTIONED. THIS
IS A TOUGH YEAR. I MEAN, I THINK
SOMEONE SAID YOU DON'T ENVY US
BEING IN A POSITION TO COME. UH
I MEAN CUTS, BUT THIS IS A
PROGRAM THAT THERE IS SOME
FUNDING LEFT IN THERE WHERE WE
CAN BE MAGICIANS HERE AND FIND A
WAY TO SPREAD IT ACROSS THE
STATE AT DIFFERENT COUNTIES AND
NOT ESSENTIALLY IMPACTING
PROJECTS BECAUSE AND OTHER
THINGS. WE'VE TALKED ABOUT THE
UNCERTAINTY OF STOP, GO, STOP!
GO REALLY IMPACTS OUR èC VÆ S¼
FROM ADEQUATELY PROVIDING THESE
SERVICES, THE UNCERTAINTY OF IT,
ALL RIGHT, BUT IT SOUNDS LIKE
WE'RE GONNA POTENTIALLY FIND A
WAY TO BE ABLE TO COME TO A WAY
TO MAKE THESE PROGRAMS LAST Y A
COUPLE MORE YEARS WITH THE
FUNDING THAT WE HAVE AVAILABLE
AND STILL BE ABLE TO DELAY AND
SAVE SOME FUNDING ON THE
UNUTILIZED FUNDS. THAT SIX.
RIGHT? EXACTLY RIGHT CHAIRMAN
TAR. THAT'S OUR INTENT AND OUR
GOAL HERE AND AGAIN. WE DO THINK
WE'LL JUST HAVE A BETTER SENSE
OF ALL OF THIS. THAT MAY
REVISION AND SO AGREE WITH L A
Ó S¼ ANALYSIS THAT, UM, WILL
HAVE BE ABLE TO HAVE MORE IN
DEPTH CONVERSATION, THEN. UM TO
THE TWO COUNTIES HERE. IF EITHER
OF YOU WOULD LIKE TO ANSWER THIS
YOU YOU GAVE ME SOME PERCENTAGE
OF GREAT. UM THE ABILITY 6 84%
OF PEOPLE ARE RETAINING THEIR
HOMES. WE HAVE A 68% APPLICATION
APPROVAL RATE. AND THEN I
BELIEVE, UH, SUSIE, YOU
MENTIONED, UH, 75% MAIN TO STAY
WITHIN THEIR HOMES. WHAT IS WHAT
BARRIERS TO EXIST? I'M LOOKING
AT THIS. IF I WAS IN A
CLASSROOM, GREAT NUMBERS, IT'S
STILL A èC RIGHT. WHAT BERRIES
EXIST TO GET TO A B A MINUS, UM,
OF RETENTION IN OUR HOME IN
HOMES. THE 75% THAT I MENTIONED.
NOT EVERYONE HAS BEEN PLACED IN
HOUSING YET, SO THERE ARE STILL
IN PROCESS, BUT I WILL SAY SOME
OF THE CHALLENGES. I MEAN, WE'VE
HAD HÌ DE CLIENTS PASS AWAY
BEFORE THEY GOT THEIR HOUSING.
WE'VE HAD, UM HÌ UP CLIENTS THAT
DO LOSE CONTACT. I MEAN, WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT EVEN WITH THE
MOST, UM, ON THE GROUND, YOU
KNOW, MULTI TEAM IN COMMUNITY.
THIS IS A DIFFICULT POPULATION,
AND SOMETIMES WE DO LOSE CONTACT
WITH FOLKS. BUT IF YOU LOOK AT
THE AVERAGE OF THIS INTERVENTION
VERSUS OTHERS IN TERMS OF MAKING
CONSISTENT CONNECTION YOU KNOW,
IT'S VERY SUCCESSFUL. THE OTHER
THING. I JUST WANNA ADD. WE
PLANNED, UM, BECAUSE WE KNEW WE
COULD CARRY FORWARD UP UNTIL
THIS POINT. THE EXTENDED FUNDING
LIKE WE PLANNED OVER A FOUR YEAR
PERIOD, SO IT'S NOT THAT WE
DON'T HAVE UNSPENT DOLLARS AND
WE I MEAN, WE DO HAVE UNSPENT
DOLLARS, BUT WE WERE ABLE TO UP
UNTIL NOW. WE COULD CARRY
FORWARD THAT 2.8 MILLION, SO
PART OF IT IS LIKE COUNTIES ARE
PLANNED FOR AND NONPROFITS ARE
PLANFUL. SO WE LOOK AT WE WANT
TO STRETCH THAT. YOU KNOW, WE
HAD A TWO YEAR SPIKE IN FUNDING
THAT WE STRETCHED OVER A COUPLE
OF YEARS, SO I JUST WANNA BE
CLEAR. THERE MAY BE UNSPENT
FUNDING, BUT WE COUNTED ON THAT
FOR NEXT YEAR. SO THAT'S THE
THAT'S THE DIFFERENCE. AND I
THINK, SOMETIMES IN THE L A NOT
AN UNDERSTANDING THAT NUANCE
LIKE WE LOOKED AT, OK, IF WE
HAVE TWO YEARS TO SPEND THE
FUNDING, WE DON'T WANT TO SPEND
IT ALL IN ONE YEAR. WE WANT TO
SPREAD IT OUT TO THE TWO YEARS
SO COUNTIES MAY HAVE ON PAPER.
YOU KNOW, WE HAVE. WE WILL. IF
WE DO IT THE WAY WE'RE PLANNING,
WE WOULD HAVE THAT 2 MILLION
UNSPENT THAT WERE PLANNING ON
CARRYING OVER TO NEXT YEAR. WE
CAN'T CARRY IT OVER. WE NOW HAVE
TO WAIT UNTIL ANOTHER YEAR.
THAT'S THAT STOP AND GO PIECE
THAT I WAS TALKING ABOUT. DOES
THAT MAKE THAT MAKE SENSE? UM,
LET'S HAVE A LITTLE INTO THAT,
IF YOU ON PAPER HAVE SOME
FUNDING TO BE ABLE TO SURVIVE
THE FOLLOWING YEAR. UM, ARE YOU
ANTICIPATING BECAUSE THIS WOULD
BE AN IMPACT IN IN SIX MONTHS
FROM NOW OR SO FOR YOU TO STOP
ENROLLING PEOPLE LIKE YOU
MENTIONED. YEAH, YEAH, WE WOULD
HAVE JULY 1ST 2025 WE WOULD HAVE
TO BECAUSE WE HAD PLANNED TO
SPEND BECAUSE WE WERE ALLOWED TO
CARRY OVER THAT EXTRA FUNDING
INTO NEXT YEAR. WE HAD PLANNED
TO DO SO AND THAT WOULD HAVE WE
WOULD BE ENROLLING ANOTHER 70
PEOPLE. AND I AND I CAN IMAGINE
WE HAVE SOME VERY SMART
MATHEMATICS AND ALL THAT. WHO
CAN LOOK AT WHAT COUNTIES HAVE
ON PAPER LEFT OVER AND BE ABLE
TO. ADEQUATELY SAY WHICH ONES
REALLY WILL HAVE LEFTOVER OK,
ITS IF I COULD JUST ANSWER TO
THAT POINT WE ARE LOOKING AT, UM
IDENTIFYING COUNTIES NOT
NECESSARILY THAT ARE AT 100% BUT
THAT ARE AT A PERCENTAGE HIGH
PERCENTAGE THAT WE PROJECT WOULD
SPEND OUT THE FULL AMOUNT EVEN
IF IT'S ON PAPER. THEY'RE NOT
SHOWING. SO WE ARE ACCOUNTING.
UM FOR THAT, UM, PLAN FULLNESS
THAT YOU WERE TALKING ABOUT? UM
AND SO, UM, THE OTHER THING I
JUST WANNA FLAG BECAUSE THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT I THINK WERE NOT
ABLE TO BE AS CLEAR ABOUT. UM
BEFORE THIS HEARING IS WE ARE,
UM, PROPOSING REDIS. UH, EXCUSE
ME, UM RE APPROPRIATION AS THE
AS A MECHANISM TO EXTEND THESE
FUNDS, WHICH MEANS, UM, THAT SAN
FRANCISCO WOULD NOT HAVE TO HOLD
BACK ITS FUNDS IN 2425 AND WAIT
TO SPEND THEM IN 2526. IT'S JUST
THAT OTHER COUNTIES WOULD HAVE
THE ABILITY, IF SAN FRANCISCO
ENDED UP SPENDING OUT ALL THE
WAY. UH, BY THE END OF 25, THAT
WOULD BE OK. BUT IF OTHER
COUNTIES NEEDED THAT EXTRA YEAR
THEY COULD SPEND IT OUT. AND
THEN WE'RE TRYING TO COUNT THE
SAVINGS FOR THE COUNTIES. THAT
WILL, UH, NEED THE YEARS. SO UM,
WE'RE NOT SUGGESTING THAT
COUNTIES HAVE TO TAKE A PAUSE OR
PUT A MORATORIUM ON SPENDING OR
CLAIMING, UH, AS PART OF THIS
DELAY PROPOSAL. COLLEAGUES. ANY
QUESTIONS? SENATOR THANK YOU.
JUST JUST TO ALSO MAKE THE
POINT. I MEAN, THE AGING AND
HOMELESSNESS IS ONE OF OUR KEY
ISSUES THAT WE NEED TO STAY
INVESTED ON. AND I THINK ANY,
YOU KNOW, ESPECIALLY WHEN
SOMEONE IS THERE IN THE END OF
THEIR LIFE ANY ANY PUSHES DOWN
THAT THAT SLIPPERY SLOPE CAN BE
INCREDIBLY DETRIMENTAL TO L? GB
Tð CAUCUS IS DOING SOME, UH,
RURAL TOURS AROUND THE STATE AND
WE WERE DOWN IN THE COACHELLA
VALLEY THIS THIS LAST WEEK AND
CERTAINLY HEARD A LOT ABOUT THE
COST OF HOUSING AND THE AMOUNT
OF SENIORS DOWN THERE AND THE
PROBLEMS THAT PEOPLE ARE HAVING.
SO THIS IS JUST ONE OF THOSE
THINGS THAT YOU KNOW, I KNOW
THAT I KNOW WE NEED TO MAKE
ADJUSTMENTS. BUT I'M AND I'M
HAPPY TO HEAR THAT YOU'RE
LOOKING AT HOW TO PERHAPS
BALANCE THAT OUT. SO THERE'S NOT
THAT STOP AND GO BECAUSE THAT
STOP AND GO IS GONNA LOSE
PEOPLE, RIGHT? WE'RE GONNA LOSE
PEOPLE AND THEY'RE GONNA FALL
OFF THE EDGE. AND UH, WE'RE NOT
GONNA BE ABLE TO GET HIM BACK,
RIGHT? THERE'S NOT TIME FOR
THINGS LIKE THIS, AND THEN THE
MEDICAL PROBLEMS COMPOUND. SO
JUST TO SAY, I'M GLAD YOU'RE
LOOKING AT IT REALLY HARD. THIS
IS SOMETHING THAT'S GONNA BE, I
THINK A VERY HARD ONE TO REALLY
THINK ABOUT CUTTING BECAUSE I
THINK IT'S AN IMPERATIVE AND WE
GOT TO TREAT PEOPLE WITH
RESPECT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. LOOKING FORWARD TO THAT
MAY REVISE ON MORE UP TO DATE
NUMBERS AND WHEN WE HAVE BUT
APPRECIATE US FINDING A WAY TO
MAKE IT ALL WORK AND THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR THE HARD WORK THAT
Y'ALL DO ON THE GREAT THINGS
THAT YOU'RE DOING IN A DIFFERENT
COUNTIES MOVING ON NOW TO AND
WE'RE GONNA HOLD THIS ITEM OPEN.
WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO ISSUE
NUMBER THREE. YES THANK YOU.
CHAIR AND SENATORS, UM CLAIRE
RAMSEY FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES. I'M HERE TO
TALK ABOUT OUR COMMUNITY CARE
EXPANSION PROGRAM. UM WHICH IS
REALLY A GREAT SEGUE FROM THE
LAST WHERE WE TALKED ABOUT, UH,
LACK OF HOUSING AND LACK OF CARE
OPTIONS FOR OLDER ADULTS. PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES ARE èC èC E
PROGRAM. AS WE CALL IT IS REALLY
WORKING TO EXPAND. UH THE
INFRASTRUCTURE AVAILABLE FOR
PEOPLE THE HOUSING OPTIONS FOR
PEOPLE, UM, THE COMMUNITY CARE
EXPANSION. PROGRAM UH, HAS TWO
COMPONENTS, AN EXPANSION
COMPONENT AND A PRESERVATION
COMPONENT AND THE VISION BEHIND
èC èC WAS TO EXPAND THE
STATE'S HOUSING AND CARE
CONTINUUM FOR OLDER ADULTS AND
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES WHO
WERE EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS,
UM, AND WHO ARE AT RISK OF
UNNECESSARY
INSTITUTIONALIZATION. èC èC E
IS PART OF OUR STATE'S KEY
STRATEGIC MULTI AGENCY EFFORT TO
REDUCE THE INFLOW OF INDIVIDUALS
INTO OUR HOMELESSNESS RESPONSE
SYSTEM, AND IT'S ANOTHER PATHWAY
BY WHICH OUR DEPARTMENT IS
TRYING TO ADVANCE THE MASTER
PLAN FOR AGING GOALS THAT WE
SPOKE ABOUT IN THE LAST PANEL.
UH, BOTH GOAL ONE HOUSING FOR
ALL AGES AND STAGES AND GOAL.
FIVE AFFORDING AGING. UM AND WE
REALLY WANT THAT HOUSING TO BE
AFFORDABLE, AGE FRIENDLY AND
DISABILITY FRIENDLY. THE èC èC
PROGRAM WAS FUNDED THROUGH ONE
TIME FUNDS TOTALING $860 MILLION
, WHICH HAS BEEN AVAILABLE OVER
MULTIPLE YEARS AND WAS
ESTABLISHED IN 2021. UH, FOR THE
EXPANSION PROGRAM COMPONENT WE
ARE USING OF THAT 860,000,570
MILLION OF THAT IS FOR
ACQUISITION, CONSTRUCTION AND
REHABILITATION OF ADULT AND
SENIOR CARE FACILITIES THAT
SERVE. UM APPLICANTS AND
RECIPIENTS OF OUR S¼ S¼. I S¼ S¼
P PROGRAM OR OUR CASH ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM FOR IMMIGRANTS ARE CAPPI
PROGRAM WHO ARE AT RISK OR
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS AND A
PORTION OF THOSE FUNDS. OH, I'M
SORRY, DID YOU OK, SORRY. A
PORTION OF THOSE FUNDS CAN BE
USED FOR OPERATING SUBSIDIES TO
HELP MAINTAIN, UM FISCAL
SOLVENCY FOR THE FACILITIES. OUR
PRESERVATION PROGRAM HAS
PROVIDED $247 MILLION TO 34
COUNTIES TO IMMEDIATELY PRESERVE
AND PREVENT THE CLOSURE OF OUR
LICENSED RESIDENTIAL, ADULT AND
SENIOR CARE FACILITIES,
INCLUDING OUR, UM AFS ADULT
RESIDENTIAL FACILITIES AND OUR
RESIDENTIAL CARE FACILITIES FOR
THE ELDERLY ARE R èC FE S¼, UM,
ARE INTENT IS TO EXPAND AND
PRESERVE A TOTAL OF 7000 BEDS OR
UNITS THROUGHOUT THE STATE. UM
WE WERE ASKED A FEW QUESTIONS
FOR, UM ON QUESTION TWO WHAT HAS
BEEN ACHIEVED SO FAR, INCLUDING
NEW BEDS FOR INDIVIDUALS ON S¼
S¼ I AND OVERVIEW OF THE TYPES
OF RESIDENTIAL FACILITIES
SUPPORTED WITH THE èC èC FUNDS
AND THE NEEDS OF THOSE
INDIVIDUALS. HOW MANY FACILITIES
ARE SERVING INDIVIDUALS ON S¼ S¼
I THAT HAVE BEEN AWARDED
EXPANSION GRANTS OR OPERATING
SUBSIDIES. AND WHAT HAS THE
DEPARTMENT LEARNED ABOUT THE
IMPACT OF THOSE OPERATING
SUBSIDIES? SO APPLICATIONS FOR
èC èC WERE ACCEPTED THROUGH A
JOINT R FA, UM UNTIL JUNE, 1ST
2020 THREE. WE RECEIVED
OVERWHELMING INTEREST WITH THREE
174 APPLICANTS REQUESTING
APPROXIMATELY $3.8 BILLION IN
FUNDING. UH, I HAVE. THIS IS A
VERY HOT OFF THE PRESS. UH,
HEARING, SO WE HAVE A HOT OFF
THE PRESS ITEM HERE TOO. WE
JUST, UH, PUT OUT A PRESS
RELEASE THIS MORNING THAT WE
HAVE AWARDED, UH, SEVEN MORE
PROJECTS IN èC èC E, WHICH
BRINGS OUR TOTAL AWARDS TO DATE
TO $464 MILLION ACROSS 55
PROJECTS THAT WILL EXPAND
CAPACITY FOR AN ADDITIONAL 2465
BEDS OR UNITS. UM AND THAT'S IN
A MIX OF SETTINGS THROUGH
LICENSED RESIDENTIAL CARE
FACILITIES. RECUPERATIVE CARE
SITES AND PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING, AND I'LL GIVE YOU SOME
BREAKDOWNS OF THOSE NUMBERS IN
JUST A MOMENT. UM WE HAVE
LEARNED THAT, UH, THE RENTAL
EXCUSE ME. THE OPERATING
SUBSIDIES REALLY REPRESENT A
CRUCIAL ELEMENT OF THIS PROGRAM,
AND IT'S REALLY IMPERATIVE FOR
THESE FACILITIES TO BE ABLE TO
RECEIVE THAT NEED IT TO BE ABLE
TO RECEIVE THE OPERATING
SUBSIDIES IN ORDER TO CREATE A
SUSTAINABLE LONG TERM PROJECT.
UM WE DO KNOW THAT, UM, WE HAVE
HAD, UM, CHALLENGES OVER THE
PAST YEARS WITH OUR FACILITIES
THAT SERVE S¼ S¼ I S¼ S¼ P AND
CAPPI RECIPIENTS STAYING OPEN.
UM, BECAUSE MARGINS ARE JUST SO
SMALL, AND THEY'VE ALSO
EXPRESSED TO US THE CHALLENGES.
THEY HAVE TO KEEP THE PROPERTIES
UP AND AT, UM, A SUFFICIENTLY,
UM YOU KNOW, GOOD LEVEL TO HAVE
BE HABITABLE. UM THE BREAKDOWN
OF FACILITY TYPES AND THOSE
RECEIVING OPERATING SUBSIDIES
AND I CAN FOLLOW UP IN WRITING
AS WELL FOR ALL THESE NUMBERS,
BUT WE HAVE 15 PROJECTS THAT ARE
FUNDED TO CREATE 745 BEDS IN
ADULT RESIDENTIAL FACILITIES.
UM, AND FOUR OF THOSE PROJECTS
REQUESTED AND ARE RECEIVING, UM,
OPERATING SUBSIDIES, WHAT WE
CALL CAPITAL OPERATING SUBSIDY
RESERVES OR COASTERS. 16 OF OUR
PROJECTS ARE CREATING 657 BEDS
IN RC F, SO THAT'S FOR A
RESIDENTIAL CARE FACILITIES FOR
THE ELDERLY AND SIX OF THOSE
PROJECTS REQUESTED AND ARE
RECEIVING THE Kò Ó S¼ A FUNDS
19 PROJECTS ARE FUNDED TO CREATE
480 PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING
UNITS AND FIVE OF THOSE
REQUESTED AND RECEIVED èC OSER.
UM WE ALSO HAVE, UH, TWO OF THE
REMAINING PROJECTS EXCUSE ME
THAT ARE INCLUDED OF THE
RECUPERATIVE CARE, RESPITE OR
RECOVERY RESIDENCES THAT WERE
ELIGIBLE PROJECTS, UM, TO
REQUESTED ON OUR RECEIVING
COASTER, AND I JUST WANNA
MENTION THAT THOSE NUMBERS MAY
NOT, UM, PERFECTLY ADD UP
BECAUSE SOME PROJECTS HAVE
MULTIPLE TYPES OF FAC. THAT
THEY'RE BUILDING ON THE SAME
SITE. UM AND THEN TO QUESTION
THREE. HOW IS THE èC PROGRAM,
PREVENTING THE CLOSURE OF
LICENSED RESIDENTIAL CARE
FACILITIES AND EXPANDING THE
LICENSE CAPACITY? UM AS I
MENTIONED, OUR GOAL IS TO CREATE
OR PRESERVE 7000 NEW BEDS ACROSS
THE STATE. UM AND WE HAVE, UM,
AWARDED, UH, ON OUR PRESERVATION
PROGRAM. 247 MILLION IN ONE TIME
, NONCOMPETITIVE ALLOCATIONS TO
34 COUNTIES THROUGH THE PROGRAM.
SO WE PUT OUT, UM, A NOTICE TO
ALL COUNTIES, ALL COUNTIES HAD
THE OPPORTUNITY TO ACCEPT FUNDS
AND 34 COUNTIES, UH, ARE
PARTICIPATING. UM THE
PARTICIPATING COUNTIES ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION AND DISBURSEMENT
OF THE FUNDS TO EXISTING
LICENSED FACILITIES THAT ARE
SERVING THE PRIORITIZED
POPULATION AND THAT ARE AT RISK
OF CLOSURE. THE LICENSE CARE
FACILITIES MAY RECEIVE EITHER AN
OPERATING SUBSIDY OR AND OR THEY
CAN ASK FOR BOTH CAPITAL FUNDS
TO MAKE IMPROVEMENTS AND REPAIRS
OR PHYSICAL UPGRADES TO THEIR
PROPERTIES. UM AND THIS IS AGAIN
TO MAINTAIN BOTH THE FACILITIES
AS, UM A HIGH QUALITY FOR ALL
THE RESIDENTS WHO ARE LIVING
THERE. I. I WANT TO GIVE YOU
SOME UPDATES ABOUT WHAT IS GOING
ON WITH THE PRESERVATION PROGRAM
. UM WE NOW HAVE 22 OF THOSE 34
COUNTIES THAT HAVE EXECUTED A
CONTRACTS AND OUR OUR, UH,
MOVING FORWARD IN THEIR NEXT
PHASE. WE HAVE 12 THAT ARE STILL
IN THE PROCESS OF EXECUTING
THEIR CONTRACTS. 14 OF THOSE, UH
22 THAT ARE ALREADY IN EXECUTED
CONTRACTS ARE IN THE PROCESS OF
RELEASING THEIR LOCAL REQUESTS
FOR APPLICATIONS TO THEIR LOCAL
FACILITIES WHO ARE ELIGIBLE. AND
WE HAVE, UH, TWO. EXCUSE ME, 12
COUNTIES THAT ARE IN CONTRACT
WITH AT LEAST ONE FACILITY, SO
THE MONEY IS STARTING TO GET OUT
INTO THE COMMUNITY NOW. UM THE
NEXT STEP WILL BE DISPERSING
FUNDS TO FACILITY OPERATORS. AND
I JUST WANNA FLAG THAT WE HAVE
TWO COUNTIES THAT ARE ALREADY IN
THAT PHASE OF IMPLEMENTATION. UM
INCLUDING, UH, TRINITY COUNTY,
ONE OF OUR RURAL COUNTIES WAS
ABLE TO BE ONE OF THE FIRST ONES
OUT OF THE GATE TO GET MONEY TO
FACILITIES. UM WE ANTICIPATE AS
THE MONEY STARTS TO GO OUT, WE
WILL HAVE, UH, ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION TO PROVIDE BUT AGAIN
, WE HAVE ANECDOTALLY HEARD FROM
FACILITY OPERATORS. WE'VE ALSO
DONE SOME SITE VISITS WITH
FACILITIES AND HEARD FROM THEM
DIRECTLY ABOUT THE, UM
SIGNIFICANT IMPORTANCE OF THESE
FUNDS, UH, BOTH TO BASICALLY
MAKE SURE THAT THEY ARE MEETING
THEIR BOTTOM LINE AND ARE ABLE
TO BE FISCALLY SOLVABLE. SO
SOLUBLE. EXCUSE ME, UM AND, UM,
ALSO FOR THE UPGRADES, AND FOR
THE, UM UH, IMPROVEMENT. SO YOU
KNOW, THERE ARE THERE ARE
RESIDENTIAL CARE FACILITIES THAT
ARE BEEN IN BUSINESS FOR DOZENS
OF YEARS AND OUR FAMILY
BUSINESSES BUT REALLY STRUGGLE
TO PAY FOR LIKE A WHOLE WHEN A
HOLE IN THE ROOF HAPPENED WHEN
THEY NEEDED TO, UH, REMODEL THE
KITCHENS OR BATHROOMS OR TO MAKE
THEM ACCESSIBLE SO THAT THEY
COULD SERVE MORE PEOPLE. UM
USING MOBILITY DEVICES. UM AND
SO WE'VE REALLY HEARD FROM
OPERATORS THE IMPORTANCE OF
THESE FUNDS SO THAT THEY CAN
CONTINUE TO OPERATE FOR 30 40 50
YEARS AND CONTINUE THEIR FAMILY
BUSINESSES. UM, JUST TO SAY THAT
WE ARE STARTING TO SEE GOOD
TRENDS. UM, WE HAVE NUMBERS
THROUGH THE THIRD END OF THE
THIRD QUARTER OF 2020 THREE. SO
WHEN WE COMPARE, UM OUR NUMBER
OF LICENSED FACILITIES THAT
SERVE S¼ S¼ I S¼ S¼ P AND CAPPI
RECIPIENTS, UM, FROM THE END OF
2021 THROUGH THE END OF THE
THIRD QUARTER OF 2023, WE HAVE
SEEN AN INCREASE OF 7.8% OF THE
NUMBER OF FACILITIES. UH OH.
EXCUSE ME, UM, ADULT CARE
FACILITIES WITH 3.8% INCREASE IN
THEIR OVERALL CAPACITY, AND IN
THAT SAME TIME FRAME FOR SENIOR
CARE FACILITIES. WE HAVE SEEN AN
INCREASE OF 9.4% IN THE NUMBER
OF FACILITIES WITH A 2% INCREASE
IN THE OVERALL CAPACITY. SO
THESE ARE THE TREND LINES THAT
WE, UM ARE WE REALLY LOOKING FOR
AND ARE EXCITED TO SEE CONTINUE
AS WE CONTINUE TO ROLL OUT THE
PRESERVATION AND EXPANSION
DOLLARS, I WILL STOP THERE. UM,
BUT HAPPY TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU. UM, QUESTION. OH,
FIRST L A Ó ANY COMMENTS ON
THIS? ITEM. JUAN Dð LEGISLATIVE
AND OFFICE. UM, WE HAVE NOTHING
TO ADD AT THIS TIME. DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. ITALY'S PEREZ
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NOTHING
FURTHER TO ADD AT THIS MOMENT. I
HAVE A QUESTION TO EITHER OF
YOU, MISS RAMSEY. YOU YOU
MENTIONED GREAT OFF OFF THE
PRESS HOT OFF THE PRESS 464
MILLION ACROSS 55 PROJECTS, UM,
PRESERVATION PROGRAM
APPROXIMATELY 247.7 MILLION.
UNLESS THERE'S AN UPDATE IN
NUMBER. UH UH. UM PRETTY GOOD.
CLOSE TO THE 860. I KNOW. PART
OF THAT WAS FOR HÌ Dð B S¼
FUNDING. DO WE HAVE A NUMBER OF
HOW MUCH IS LEFT IN OUR PLANNED
FOR THE LEFTOVER OR AM I UM,
JUST TO CLARIFY YOUR QUESTION.
ARE YOU SPECIFICALLY ASKING
ABOUT WHERE WE ARE IN SPENDING
ON THE HÌ Tð B S¼ FUNDING
SPECIFICALLY NÓ ON THE 86. I
KNOW WE HAD 860 FOR THIS RIGHT
FOR ALL OF FOR PROTECTION, BUT
53.4 IS FOR HÌ Dð B S¼ FUNDING.
UM THAT'S FROM TAKING OUT OF
THAT OUT OF THAT. THE NUMBERS
THAT I HAVE IN FRONT OF ME ARE
464 THAT YOU MENTIONED AND IN
THE AGENDA WE HAVE 247.7 Dð THAT
DIDN'T DO THE QUICK MATH. IS
THERE ANYTHING REMAINING? YES.
SO PLANS FOR THAT. I DIDN'T MEAN
TO INTERRUPT YOU. THANK YOU. YES
WE DO HAVE ANOTHER, AND I'M ALSO
TRYING TO DO THE BACK OF THE
MATH. UH UH, BACK OF THE NAPKIN
MOUTH. UH, 116 MILLION TO FINISH
, UM, AWARDING THROUGH THE
EXPANSION, UH, GRANTS, AND WE
EXPECT TO BE DOING THAT IN THE
COMING MONTHS SO LIKELY BEFORE
THE END OF THE FISCAL YEAR, THE
ALL THE EXPANSION DOLLARS WILL
BE OUT AND AWARDED, UM, THE
PRESERVATION DOLLARS, UM, HAVE
GONE OUT, UM, THAT INCLUDED BOTH
THE ORIGINAL, UM ALLOCATION FOR
OPERATING SUBSIDIES AS WELL AS
THE SECOND ROUND OF 55 MILLION.
THOSE HAVE ALL BEEN PUT OUT. UM
AND THEN, UM, WE ALSO, UM WILL
CONTINUE TO MAKE SURE THAT, UM
THEIR OTHER COMPONENTS OF THE
PROGRAM. WE HAVE A THIRD PARTY
ADMINISTER ADMINISTRATOR OF THE
PROGRAM, WHICH SOME OF THE
FUNDING GOES TO THEM, WHICH ARE
HELPING TO BASICALLY ADMINISTER
AND DISPERSE ALL THE FUNDS AND
WORK WITH THE INDIVIDUAL
GRANTEES. DO WE HAVE AN AVERAGE
FOR EACH APPLICATION? HOW MUCH
WE'RE FUNDING. UH WE CAN GIVE
YOU NUMBERS ON THE TOTAL AWARD
FOR EVERY PROJECT AS WELL. ARE
YOU ALSO ASKING ON THE HOW MUCH
PER BAG FOR THE EXPANSION
PROGRAM? SURE WE CAN PROVIDE A
FULL LIST OF ALL 55 PROJECTS. IS
THAT WHAT YOU'D LIKE? DO WE
ANTICIPATE UTILIZING THE ENTIRE
$160 MILLION THAT WE HAVE LEFT
OVER? YES, OK, WE DO. WOULD YOU
RECOMMEND THIS BEING A TOPIC
THAT WE CAN PUT A LITTLE BIT?
THAT HASN'T BEEN GONE OUT TO
PULL BACK TO FIND OTHER
PROGRAMS. GINNY BELLA, WITH THE
ANALYSTS OFFICE. I THINK AS YOU
AS YOU'VE INDICATED, THERE'S
GOING TO BE DIFFICULT BUDGET
CHOICES IN OUR OFFICE HAS SAID
THAT SOME OF THE THINGS YOU
MIGHT WANT TO START TO LOOK AT
IS MONEY THAT HAS NOT ALREADY
BEEN COMMITTED. THIS SOUNDS LIKE
IT FITS THAT THAT CATEGORY. THE
MONEY IS NOT OUT. I DON'T KNOW
WHAT COMMITMENTS THE DEPARTMENT
MAYBE HAS ALREADY MADE TO
SUBCONTRACTORS. BUT CERTAINLY IF
THAT'S SOMETHING AS YOU'RE
LOOKING AT THE WHOLE PACKAGE OF
DECISIONS YOU'RE MAKING. IF
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT IS STILL
ON THE TABLE. I THINK IT'S WORTH
CONSIDERING WHAT COURSE ARE OUR
DRAWBACKS. WHERE ARE ON THAT
PROCESS FOR THE REMAINING UM
APPLICATIONS. SO WE'RE CURRENTLY
REVIEWING APPLICATIONS AND
MAKING DECISIONS ON AWARDS AND
DECLINES, UH, ON THOSE, UM,
REMAINING APPLICATIONS.
OBVIOUSLY WE HAD FAR MORE
INTEREST THAN WE CAN FIND. SO WE
DO EXPECT TO BE ABLE TO, UM,
FULLY EXPEND THOSE FUNDS THROUGH
THE APPLICATIONS WE RECEIVED. UM
I WILL JUST NOTE THE WAY THE
FUNDS WERE, UM UM, BASICALLY,
UH, STRUCTURED WITHIN THE R FA
WAS THAT THERE WAS REGIONAL
AMOUNTS FOR EACH OF THE SEVEN
REGIONS. WE'VE BROKEN INTO SEVEN
REGIONS THROUGHOUT THE STATE. SO
THERE ARE A COUPLE REGIONS THAT
HAVE NOT HIT THEIR TARGET, WHICH
THOSE ARE A HIGH PRIORITIES FOR
US TO, UM, FINISH THOSE AWARDS.
WE STILL HAVE MONEY WITHIN THE
TRIBAL SET ASIDE THAT ARE WE ARE
LOOKING AT APPLICATIONS WITHIN
TRIBAL AWARDS. AND THEN, UM,
THERE WAS A MONEY THAT WAS
ALLOWED TO BE HELD FOR ANY KIND
OF HIGH PRIORITY PROJECTS. UM
THAT WE'RE STILL LOOKING TOWARD
THROUGH THE STATE SET ASIDE SO
UM, I WOULD SAY RESPECTFULLY
THAT ALTHOUGH THEY HAVE NOT BEEN
ACTIVELY AWARDED, UH OR OR NOT
AWARDED AT THIS MOMENT, WE ARE
ACTIVELY REVIEWING APPLICATIONS
TO FULFILL THE COMMITMENT THAT
WAS PUT OUT IN THE, UM, REQUEST
FOR PROPOSAL. SENATORS ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THAT UPDATE. WE'RE GONNA BE
MOVING ON TO ISSUE NUMBER FOUR.
IN HOME SUPPORTIVE SERVICES
OVERVIEW.
I WELCOME THE ADMINISTRATION TO
KICK US OFF. THANK YOU. UM I'M
STAYING UP FOR THIS PANEL, BUT,
UM, CLAIRE RAMSEY èC Dð SS S¼.
I'M GOING TO LET MY COLLEAGUE
LEO, UH, INTRODUCE HERSELF AND
START GOOD MORNING. UM MADAM
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS. MY
NAME IS LEORA FELICA. I AM THE
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF THE ADULT
PROGRAMS DIVISION. I OVERSEE THE
IN HOME SUPPORTIVE SERVICES
PROGRAM, THE CASH ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM FOR IMMIGRANTS, UM, AND
THE ADULT PROTECTIVE SERVICES
PROGRAM. UM SO I GUESS WE'LL
JUST GO AHEAD AND GET STARTED.
UM THE AGENDA DID A GREAT JOB OF
REALLY GIVING A REALLY, UM IN
DEPTH OVERVIEW OF THE I HÌ S¼ S¼
PROGRAM. I KNOW THE QUESTION IS
KIND OF, UM CAN WE GIVE A BRIEF
OVERVIEW? I'LL JUST KIND OF
EMPHASIZE A COUPLE OF POINTS. UM
I JUST S¼ PROGRAM PROVIDES
DOMESTIC AND PERSONAL CARE
SERVICES TO CHILDREN AND ADULTS
WITH DISABILITIES AND OLDER
ADULTS TO KEEP THEM SAFELY IN
THEIR OWN HOMES AND COMMUNITIES
AND AVOID INSTITUTIONALIZATION.
I HÌ S¼ S¼ IS A VERY LARGE
PROGRAM. IT'S THE LARGEST
PROGRAM IN THE COUNTRY, UM, WHEN
IT COMES TO HOME AND COMMUNITY
BASED SERVICES IS ALSO THE
BACKBONE OF CALIFORNIA'S HOME
AND COMMUNITY BASED SERVICES
PROGRAMS. WE ARE NOW SERVING
OVER 750,000 AUTHORIZED CASES,
AND THOSE INDIVIDUALS ARE BEING
SERVED BY OVER 650,000 PROVIDERS
. AT THIS POINT, WE ISSUE OVER
1.5 MILLION CHECKS EACH MONTH TO
PROVIDERS FOR THOSE SERVICES. UM
I HÌ S¼ S¼ IS LARGELY
ADMINISTERED BY THE COUNTIES
WITH OVERSIGHT FROM CDS. S¼
COUNTY SOCIAL WORKERS PERFORM AN
ANNUAL IN-HOME ASSESSMENT TO
DETERMINE WHAT I HÌ S¼ S¼
SERVICES A RECIPIENT NEEDS BASED
ON THEIR ABILITY TO PERFORM
CERTAIN TASKS. I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT THE
AUTHORIZATION OF THE SERVICES
OFTEN MEANS THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN SOMEONE STAYING IN THEIR
OWN HOME AND BEING
INSTITUTIONALIZED. UM I HÌ S¼
S¼, ONE OF THE MO MORE UNIQUE
COMPONENTS OF IS THAT IT IS A
SELF DIRECTED PROGRAM, MEANING
THAT I HÌ S¼ S¼ RECIPIENTS ARE
REALLY RESPONSIBLE FOR MANAGING
THEIR OWN CARE. HÌ S¼ S¼
RECIPIENTS ARE SERVED BY
PROVIDERS WHO CAN BE A FAMILY
MEMBER. A FRIEND, UM OR SOMEONE
THEY DO NOT KNOW THAT MAYBE
COULD BE ON THE REGISTRY. UM AND
THE I HÌ S¼ S¼ RECIPIENT IS
CONSIDERED THE EMPLOYER OF THAT
PROVIDER, AND THAT PROVIDER IS
CONSIDERED THEIR EMPLOYEE.
THAT'S ALSO A VERY UNIQUE TO, UM
CALIFORNIA'S PROGRAM. AND BY
SAYING THAT I HÌ S¼ S¼ RECIPIENT
IS THE EMPLOYER. THEY'RE REALLY
RESPONSIBLE FOR MANAGING AND
HIRING THEIR OWN PROVIDER. OTHER
THAN PROGRAM OVERSIGHT. èC Dð
S¼ S¼ IS THE PAYROLL AGENT ON
BEHALF OF THE I HÌ S¼ SS
RECIPIENTS. SO WE DO ALL OF THE
PAYROLL ACTIVITIES AND WE ALSO
ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
OPERATION OF THE CASE,
MANAGEMENT INFORMATION AND PAY
ROLLING SYSTEM, WHICH IS THE
SYSTEM OF RECORD FOR I HÌ S¼ S¼.
THE 2425 GOVERNORS BUDGET
PROPOSES A TOTAL OF $22.4
BILLION TOTAL FUNDS AND FISCAL
YEAR 20 THREE 24 AND 24 POINT
THREE BILLION DOLLARS TOTAL FUND
IN 2425. THIS IS AN INCREASE OF
APPROXIMATELY $1.9 BILLION. THE
INCREASE IS LARGELY DUE TO THE
EXPANSION OF THE FULL SCOPE ME,
UM TO UNDOCUMENTED ADULTS. THE
SUNSET OF ENHANCED FEDERAL
MEDICAID FUNDING AND THE GROWTH
IN PROJECTED CASELOAD COST PER
HOUR AND HOURS PER CASE. I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT
THERE ARE NÓ BUDGET. UM
SOLUTIONS RELATED TO I HÌ S¼ S¼
PROGRAM AND IN THIS CYCLE THANK
YOU. AND I'M GOING TO TAKE
QUESTION TWO. CLAIRE RAMSEY FROM
èC Dð S¼ S¼. UM QUESTION TWO
RELATED TO L. A Ó NOTES THAT I
HÌ S¼ S¼ SERVICE UTILIZATION
CONTINUED TO BE LOWER THAN
HISTORICAL LEVELS. AND IF THE
DEPARTMENT HAD, UM, ANY, UM
UNDERSTAND OF THE DRIVING OF
THAT DECREASE. UM I JUST FIRST
WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THE L A
Ó, UM, IN THEIR REPORT DID A
GOOD JOB HIGHLIGHTING, UM,
SEVERAL OF THE POSSIBLE REASONS
BEHIND THIS, UM, LOWER, UM UH,
PAID CASE RATE THAT WE'RE SEEING
COMING OUT OF THE PANDEMIC. UM
IT IS SOMETHING THAT WE DON'T
HAVE AN ABILITY TO HAVE, UM UH,
LIKE A PERFECT READ ON WHAT IS
CAUSING THE DECREASE. WE DO
THINK THAT IT MAY IN PART BE DUE
TO DELAYS IN, UH, PROVIDERS
BEING ASSOCIATED WITH CASES, SO
IT'S NOT ACTUALLY THAT SOMEONE
ISN'T GETTING, UM, A PROVIDER
AND BEING CONNECTED TO A
PROVIDER. BUT INSTEAD THAT THERE
MAY BE A LAG BETWEEN THOSE TWO
THINGS HAPPENING, WHICH ON PAPER
LOOKS LIKE A CASE DOES NOT HAVE
A PROVIDER. UM WE ARE LOOKING
MORE CLOSELY AT THAT DATA, AND
WE DO THINK NOW THAT WE ARE
SEEING INCREASES AS MS FELICA,
UH REFERENCED, UM IN THE NUMBER
OF CASES BECAUSE WE ARE EXPANDED
TO A LARGER POPULATION WITH THE
UNDOCUMENTED EXPANSION THAT WE
MAY JUST BE SEEING A NEW CASE
LOAD COMING ON GETTING FAMILIAR
WITH THE I HÌ S¼ S¼ PROGRAM
GETTING FAMILIAR WITH THEIR
PROVIDERS BEING ASSOCIATED WITH
CASES AND WE'RE ALSO WORKING TO
REMOVE THOSE BARRIERS TO DELAYS.
UM WORKING BOTH WITH THE
COUNTIES. THIS IS LARGELY A
PAPER PROCESS TO CONNECT CASES
SO TRYING TO MAKE SEE IF WE CAN
STREAMLINE OR, UM I MAKE THAT
SIMPLER FOR EVERYONE, AND WE'RE
ALSO TRYING TO WORK WITH, UH,
PROVIDERS. SO THEY HAVE THE
FUNCTIONALITY TO, UM, PUT THEIR
OWN PROVIDER ON THEIR CASE. UM
AND THEN THIS IS SOMETHING WE
WILL CONTINUE TO MONITOR BECAUSE
WE DO WANT PEOPLE TO USE THE
SERVICES THEY'RE AUTHORIZED FOR.
THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT. UM AND WE
DON'T WANT THERE TO BE ANY, UM,
UNNEEDED BARRIERS TO THAT. UM I
WILL. NOW GO ON TO QUESTION
THREE, WHICH WAS, UM, REFERENCE
TO THE ELIMINATION OF THE MEDI
ASSET LIMITS THAT'S GOING TO
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF SENIORS
AND PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES
ELIGIBLE FOR I HÌ S¼ S¼. THE
QUESTION RELATES TO THE BUDGET
ESTIMATE OF APPROXIMATELY $48
MILLION IN GENERAL FUND. THE
QUESTION ABOUT HOW THAT ESTIMATE
WAS DERIVED AND HOW WE PROJECT
CASE LOADS AND EXPENDITURES OF
ASSOCIATED WITH THE REMOVAL OF
THE MEDI CAL ASSET LIMIT. UM THE
48 MILLION IN GENERAL FUND COST
IN FY 2425 WAS CALCULATED BY
MULTIPLYING THE PROJECTED NEW I
SS MONTHLY CASELOAD BY THE
AVERAGE MONTHLY COST PER CASE
AND BY THEN BY THE NUMBER OF
IMPACTED MONTHS, THIS IS THE
METHODOLOGY WE USE TO, UM,
PROJECT I HÌ S¼ S¼ SERVICES AND
I HÌ S¼ S¼ ADMINISTRATION
RESPECTIVE TO THE INDIVIDUAL
COST PER CASE. UH, THE TOTAL
AMOUNT IS CALCULATED BY THE SUM
OF THESE RESULTS. THE NEW HSS
CASE. LOAD UM, REFERENCED ABOVE
WAS ACTUALLY DERIVED USING
PROJECTED CASE LOADS FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES. UM BASED ON WHAT THEY
PROJECT, UH, THE NEW NUMBER OF,
UH, RECIPIENTS WILL BE BECAUSE
OF THE ASSET ELIMINATION. AND
THEN WE USE AN INTAKE RATIO, UH,
TO DETERMINE, UH, HOW MANY OF
THOSE MEDI BENEFICIARIES WILL BE
ELIGIBLE FOR? I HÌ S¼ S¼. UM, I
DO WANT TO FLAG THAT èC Dð S¼
S¼ DOES NOT ACTUALLY HAVE ACCESS
TO DATA ELEMENTS THAT SHOW
WHETHER SOMEONE, UM, RECEIVED
MEDICAL BECAUSE THEY WERE NÓ
LONGER BLOCKED OUT BECAUSE OF
THE ASSET LIMIT THAT FINANCIAL
DATA IS SOMETHING THAT DHCS HAS,
UM, THAT THEY HAVE THAT DATA.
BUT WE CAN ONLY SEE UM VERY
LIMITED MEDICAL DATA. SO WE'RE
RELYING ON THEM FOR THE INITIAL
NUMBER THAT WE USE TO APPLY OUR
INTAKE RATIO TO UM AND THEN I
WILL TURN IT OVER TO, UH, DEPUTY
DIRECTOR PHILINA FOR QUESTION
FOUR. SURE THANK YOU SO MUCH.
MISS RAMSEY. I'LL BE PROVIDING
THE UPDATES ON THE VARIOUS
INITIATIVES, INCLUDING, UM THE
ELIGIBILITY FOR MINOR RECIPIENTS
. UM THE STATE THE STAKEHOLDER
PROCESS TO EXPLORE REGIONAL AND
STATEWIDE COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
FOR I S¼ S¼ PROVIDERS. THE
IMPLEMENTATION UM E, VÆ VÆ AND
ALSO THE, UM SO GIVE SOME
UPDATES ON THE BACKUP PROVIDER
SYSTEM. SO FOR MINOR RECIPIENTS,
WE DID ISSUE AN A èC L IN
DECEMBER. 21ST 2023, THERE WAS A
60 DAY IMPLEMENTATION TIME FRAME
, WHICH ENDED AT THE END OF
FEBRUARY. UM OUR UNDERSTANDING
AND WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH THE
COUNTIES AND AS WELL AS OUR
STAKEHOLDER PARTNERS, UM, THAT
THE IMPACT OF CASES ARE BEING
REASSESSED AND AT AT THE TIME OF
REASSESSMENT AND OR AT THE
REQUEST OF A STAKEHOLDER, UH,
YOU KNOW, LIKE A LEGAL ADVOCATE
OR EVEN AT THE REQUEST OF A
PARENT, AND SO WE'RE SEEING THAT
THAT IS HAPPENING. UM NÓ. THERE
HAVE BEEN NÓ CONCERNS RAISED TO
US FROM ANY ADVOCATE IN IN OUR
COMMUNITY AS OF NOW, AND SO
WE'LL CONTINUE TO MONITOR THIS.
UM WE'LL PROBABLY KNOW MORE AS
THE YEAR GOES ON AS WE SEE THESE
MINOR, UH, MINOR KIDS CASES WHO
DIDN'T HAVE A PROVIDER BEFORE,
WILL PROBABLY HAVE A PROVIDER
NOW WHERE THE PRO THE PARENT WAS
NOT ABLE TO BE A PROVIDER
BECAUSE OF THE RULES, AND NOW
BECAUSE OF THE STREAMLINING,
THEY'RE ABLE TO BE A PROVIDER
NOW, SO WE'LL BE MONITORING THIS
THROUGHOUT THE YEAR, UM, FOR
STATEWIDE COLLECTIVE BARGAINING.
WE HAVE MADE A LOT OF, UM
HEADWAY IN THIS WE HAD OUR FIRST
LEVEL SETTING MEETING ON
FEBRUARY 22ND WITH THE GROUP. SO
WE FORMED THE GROUP. ALL OF THE
MEMBERS OF THE GROUP. UM WE
BEFORE THE ACTUAL RECRUIT DOES,
UM, KICKS OFF THE FORMAL
MEETINGS. WE'RE DOING THREE
LEVEL SETTING MEETINGS WITH THE
TEAM, SO THAT WAY THEY CAN TO
PROVIDE LIKE A BASIC Ó OVERVIEW
OF I HÌ S¼ S¼ TO DO AN OVERVIEW
OF THE PROGRAM FUNDING AND THE M
Ó E THE COUNTY M Ó E, WHICH IS
REALLY, REALLY, UM, COMPLICATED
AND THEN LEVEL SETTING MEETING
ABOUT THE CURRENT BARGAINING AND
HOW THAT WORKS NOW. UM THE WORK
GROUP IS EXPECTED TO FORMALLY
CONVENE IN APRIL, AND WE PLAN AT
LEAST HAVING MONTHLY MEETINGS
THROUGH AUGUST, UM, DIVIDING THE
MEETINGS BY TOPICS SO THAT WE
CAN HIT ALL OF THE REQUIREMENTS.
UM, IN THE LEGISLATION FOR THE
REPORT. UH, WE ARE IN THE
PROCESS OF CONTRACTING WITH TWO
CONSULTANTS AT THIS 0.1 IS HIGH
ROAD ALLIANCE, SO WE ARE
BRINGING THEM ON TO BE A
FACILITATOR FOR THE WORK GROUPS
SO THEY WILL HELP US DO A LOT OF
THE FACILITATION. A LOT OF THE
CONVERSATIONS, BE ASKING THE
QUESTIONS AND THEN WE'RE ALSO
BRINGING ON UM U èC BERKELEY
LABOR CENTER FOR OUR RESEARCHER,
SO WE ARE IN THE PROCESS OF ALL
OF THAT, UM, EVERYTHING IS
MOVING FORWARD. AND UM, I DON'T.
I DON'T SEE WE ARE NOT
EXPERIENCING. ME DELAYS AS OF
RIGHT NOW. UH, FOR E, VÆ VÆ, UM,
WE BEGAN THE CERTIFICATION
PROCESS WITH èC M S¼ IN JANUARY
OF 2024. WE'RE NOT. WE HAVE
ASKED ALL THE QUESTIONS
SUBMITTED ALL OF OUR
DOCUMENTATION. UH, CURRENTLY 57%
OF NONLIVING PROVIDERS ARE
UTILIZING E VÆ VÆ, UM, WE HAVE
SOME WORK TO DO IN COMPLIANCE.
SO WHAT WE CONTINUE TO FOCUS ON
IS REALLY INCREASING THAT
COMPLIANCE RATE BY SENDING
LETTERS, EMAILS, SOCIAL MEDIA
POSTS BANNER. ON THE ELECTRONIC
SERVICES PORTAL. AND ALSO WE
CONTINUE TO HOLD, UM, TRAINING
WEBINARS AND PROVIDE TRAINING
MATERIALS TO PEOPLE JUST IN CASE
ACCESSING THE SYSTEM IS A
BARRIER AND WE ARE PROVIDING
THOSE MATERIALS IN IN THE
THRESHOLD LANGUAGES RIGHT NOW,
UM AND THEN FOR THE BACKUP
PROVIDER SYSTEM, SO WE HAVE BEEN
UP FOR A YEAR. A LITTLE OVER A
YEAR. UH, WE REVIEWED THE
UTILIZATION OF THE OF THE SYSTEM
AND IT WAS LOWER THAN IN THAN
EXPECTED. SO WHAT WE HAVE DONE
IS WE SENT A SURVEY TO THE
COUNTIES AND PUBLIC AUTHORITIES
TO IDENTIFY POTENTIAL CHALLENGES
WITH THE CURRENT BACKUP SYSTEM
AND ITS ADMINISTRATION,
INCLUDING BARRIERS FOR ACCESS.
WE JUST CLOSED THE SURVEY ON
FEBRUARY 29TH AND WITH 31
COUNTIES, ACTUALLY PROVIDING US
RESPONSES, WHICH WAS A PRETTY
GOOD RESPONSE RATE. SOME OF THE
PRELIMINARY TAKEAWAYS WERE THAT
THERE WERE DIFFICULTIES WITH
FINDING ENOUGH PROVIDERS TO
PROVIDE BACKUP SERVICES DUE TO,
UM IS PROVIDER AVAILABILITY
DISTANCE. SOMETIMES THERE WERE
LANGUAGE BARRIERS, AND
OCCASIONALLY THERE WERE
RECIPIENTS RECIPIENT REFUSALS AS
WELL. UM SO WE THEY AS PART OF
THAT SURVEY, THERE WAS ALSO A
REQUEST TO US FROM THE COUNTIES
AND PUBLIC AUTHORITIES TO
PROVIDE SOME MATERIALS, UM, TO
BE PROVIDED AT PROVIDER
ORIENTATIONS TO DO LIKE
RECRUITMENT. LIKE, HEY, THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT YOU CAN DO. YOU
CAN BE A BACKUP PROVIDER AND
ALSO TO PROVIDE TO ELIGIBLE
RECIPIENTS AT REASSESSMENT SO
THAT THEY ARE AWARE THAT THEY
CAN ACCESS THESE THESE SYSTEMS
AND HOW TO DO THAT. UM SO WE
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
COUNTIES AND PUBLIC AUTHORITIES
ON ON THIS. WE REALLY ARE
COMMITTED TO MAKING THE SYSTEM
WORK FOR FOLKS. WE KNOW IT'S
IMPORTANT AND WE REALLY WANT TO
REMOVE THOSE BARRIERS AS AS WE
MOVE FORWARD, AND ALSO REALLY
TRY TO DO, UM, GIVE A LOT OF
SUPPORT FOR THE RECRUITMENT OF
PROVIDERS AS WELL. AND THEN I'M
ALSO GONNA RESPOND TO THE, UM TO
QUESTION NUMBER FIVE, WHICH IS
WITH REGARDS TO THE IMPACTS OF
THE RESUMPTION OF MEDI RED
DETERMINATIONS ON THE HÌ S¼ S¼
POPULATION, SO THIS WAS
SOMETHING WE HAVE DONE A LOT OF
FOCUS ON OVER THE LAST YEAR. UM
WE CONTINUE TO MONITOR. UH, ALL
THE PROGRESS DATA. WE'RE LOOKING
AT IT CONSTANTLY AND TO PROMOTE,
WE'RE REALLY PROMOTING.
INFORMATION TO RECIPIENTS BY
DOING OUTREACH WHERE LEVERAGING
THE MATERIALS THAT ARE PARTNERS
AT THE HÌ èC S¼ CREATED IN ALL
THE DIFFERENT LANGUAGES, WE'RE
DOING SOCIAL MEDIA POSTS. WE'RE
ALSO, UM, PUSHING ME, YOU KNOW,
PUSHING THOSE MESSAGES TO OUR
RECIPIENTS, AND WE'RE ALSO
PROVIDING A MONTHLY FILE TO
COUNTIES OF THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
DUE FOR THE FOLLOWING MONTH SO
THAT THEY CAN DO OUTREACH TO
THOSE INDIVIDUALS AND WORK WITH
PEOPLE WHO MAY BE HAVING
DIFFICULTIES. UM WITH THEIR RED
DETERMINATIONS. WE ARE SEEING,
UM THE AVERAGE NUMBER OF FOLKS
WHO ARE LOSING THEIR I HÌ S¼ S¼
DUE TO NÓ MEDICAL IS
SIGNIFICANTLY LOWER THAN IT WAS
PREPA. SO ON AVERAGE, IT'S ABOUT
200 A LITTLE OVER 200 PEOPLE
LOSING THEIR MEDICAL WHEN,
BEFORE IT WAS CLOSER TO 1300
PEOPLE PER MONTH FOR THIS REASON
, SO ALL OF THOSE EFFORTS I
THINK ARE REALLY PAYING OFF AS
WELL AS THE EFFORTS THAT OUR
PARTNERS AT DHCS ARE DOING AS
WELL IN THIS AREA. UM THAT ARE
MAKING THINGS EASIER FOR
COUNTIES TO PROCESS AND MAKING
IT EASIER FOR PEOPLE TO RESPOND
TO THE TO AND FILL OUT THEIR
PACKET AND GET THEM SUBMITTED.
SO WE'RE REALLY SEEING, UM SOME
GREAT STRIDES HERE, AND I DID
ALSO WANT TO MENTION THAT WE'LL
BE PROVIDING A MORE IN DEPTH.
BRIEF BRIEFING ON THIS TOPIC ON
MARCH 14TH FOR THE LEGISLATURE,
SO THAT IS PLANNED NEXT WEEK.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE ANY ADDITIONAL COMMENTS
YOU'D LIKE TO ADD? ITALY'S PEREZ
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NÓ FURTHER
COMMENTS. THANK YOU. HE, LEO.
YES JUAN TROTTER WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST OFFICE. UM
SO WHILE THERE ARE NÓ NEW MAJOR
PROPOSALS, UM, FOR IN HOME
SUPPORT SERVICES. THERE ARE, UM,
A COUPLE OF THINGS THAT WE ARE
CONTINUING TO MONITOR. UM AND
EXPECT TO HAVE UPDATES FOR AT
THE REVISION. UM FIRSTLY, WE
ALWAYS MONITORING, UM, CASE
LOADS AND CHECKING THE
ADMINISTRATION'S, UM, ESTIMATES,
UM, TO MOST RECENT, UM, ACTUAL
CASE LOAD DATA. UM ONE THING WE
WERE CONTINUING TO TRACK. UM AS
WAS MENTIONED BEFORE IS, UM
SINCE COVID THIS DECLINE IN THE
PERCENTAGE OF AUTHORIZED, UM
AUTHORIZED CASES THAT ARE
SUBMITTING TIME SHEETS AND
RECEIVING PAID SERVICES. SO AS
THE AGENDA NOTED, UM PRIOR TO
COVID-19, ABOUT 91% OF
AUTHORIZED CASES WERE RECEIVING
SERVICES, WHEREAS, UM, POST
COVID, UM, THAT NUMBER DROPPED
ABOUT 88% IN ADDITION TO SOME OF
THE REASONS THAT WERE MENTIONED,
UM WE ALSO BELIEVE THAT ONE
REASON COULD BE THAT BOTH
RECIPIENTS AND PROVIDERS MAY BE
MORE HESITANT TO, UM INTERACT
WITH FOLKS OUTSIDE OF THEIR
HOUSEHOLD DUE TO, UM PUBLIC
HEALTH CONCERNS. AS OF COVID, UM
, BUT REGARDLESS OF THE REASONS
AND DESPITE SOME MONTHLY
FLUCTUATIONS, UM THIS TREND HAS
CONTINUED TO HOLD. AND SO THIS
IS SOMETHING WE DO WANT TO
CONTINUE TO MONITOR AND GET BACK
TO YOU, UM, BEFORE THE MAY
REVISION. SECONDLY WE ARE
CONTINUING TO MONITOR THESE, UM,
EXPANSIONS TO ME, UM, AND THEIR
IMPLICATIONS FOR WHO IS ELIGIBLE
FOR IN HOME SUPPORT SERVICES. UM
AS KNOWING THE AGENDA. SOME OF
THESE EXPANSIONS, UM INCLUDE THE
REPEAL OF THE MEDICAL ASSET
LIMIT. UM THE CONTINUED
EXPANSION OF FULL SCOPE ME TO,
UM, UNDOCUMENTED, INTIMATE
INDIVIDUALS, REGARDLESS OF
IMMIGRATION STATUS, UM AND AS
WELL AS THE RESUMPTION OF THE
MEDICARE DETERMINATION PROCESS
THAT WAS TEMPORARILY PAUSE DUE
TO COVID. UM LASTLY, WE'RE ALSO
CONTINUING TO MONITOR UM, THE
IMPLEMENTATION AND UTILIZATION
OF THESE NEWER, I S¼ PROPOSALS.
SO THE PERMANENT BACKUP PROVIDER
SYSTEM AS WELL AS THE
ELIMINATION OF THE MINOR
RECIPIENT, UM, PROVIDER
ELIGIBILITY REQUIREMENTS. AND SO
GIVEN THE SIGNIFICANT BUDGET
PROBLEMS, UM WE ARE LOOKING AT
THESE NEW INITIATIVES AND THESE
CASE LOADS UNDER THE LENS OF
TRYING TO DETERMINE WHETHER, UM
ACTUAL COSTS ARE COMING IN LINE
WITH BUDGET EXPENDITURES. AND IF
THESE BUDGET EXPENDITURES UM OR
THESE ACTUAL COSTS ARE COMING IN
BELOW BUDGET EXPENDITURES, UM WE
BELIEVE THAT THROUGH KIND OF
RIGHT SIZING THE BUDGET THERE
COULD BE SAVINGS TO BE HAD IN
THE BUDGET. UM AND SO WE WILL
CONTINUE TO MONITOR UM, THIS
DATA AS IT COMES IN, AND, UM,
EXPECT TO PROVIDE FURTHER
UPDATES AT THE MAY REVISION.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH. I
KNOW THERE'S NÓ BUDGET SOLUTIONS
HERE, BUT I THINK THERE COULD
POTENTIALLY BE SOME SAVINGS AND
EVEN BUDGET SOLUTIONS FOR THE
CURRENT YEAR AND THE NEXT FISCAL
YEAR. I'M REALLY, UM, INTERESTED
IN THE PERMANENT BACKUP PROVIDER
SYSTEM. THE PAID SICK LEAVE
UTILIZATION IN THE STREAMLINING
ELIGIBILITY TO PROVIDE A
RECIPIENTS FINDING SAVINGS IN
THOSE THREE CATEGORIES AS WE
KNOW E, ESPECIALLY WITH THE
ELIGIBILITY FOR MINOR RECIPIENTS
. THAT PROGRAM STARTED SIX
MONTHS PAST THE, UH, THE TIME
THAT WE ANTICIPATED THAT'S
CURRENT. SAVINGS AND THEN
LOOKING AT, UH, FUTURE
ALLOCATION TO THESE PREVIOUS TWO
PROGRAMS PERMANENT, BACK UP AND
PAID SICK LEAVE AND HOW MUCH WE
REALLY NEED TO ALLOCATE MOVING
FORWARD. THERE'S NOT GONNA BE A
LOT OF OPPORTUNITIES WE'RE GOING
TO SEE IN SUB THREE WHERE WE'RE
GOING TO FIND SOME EXTRA FUNDING
LIKE THIS AND HOW WE CAN UTILIZE
THAT TO, UM MAKE WHOLE OTHER
PROGRAMS, UM, WOULD BE REALLY
IDEAL FOR US. COLLEAGUES.
ANYTHING ELSE? SENATOR ROTH. SO
YOU WERE RIGHT TODAY, HUH? YOU
WERE YOU WERE YOU WEREN'T GONNA
SPEAK TODAY. UM OK? YEAH. THAT'S
MY ONLY COMMENT ON ON ON THOSE
ITEMS THERE. MOVING ON TO ISSUE
NUMBER FIVE IN HOME SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES CAREER PATHWAYS
PROGRAM. UM HELLO AGAIN. CLAIRE
RAMSEY FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES. UM I'M GONNA
PROVIDE, UM AS REQUESTED, UH, AN
OVERVIEW AND UPDATE OF THE I HÌ
S¼ S¼ CAREER PATHWAYS PROGRAM.
UM AS I THINK ALL OF YOU ARE
FAMILIAR THAT I HÌ S¼ S¼ CAREER
PATHWAYS PROGRAM WAS A NEW
TRAINING PROGRAM CREATED FOR
IN-HOME SUPPORTIVE SERVICES AND
WAIVER OF PERSONAL CARE SERVICE
PROVIDERS THAT WAS MEANT TO
INCREASE THE QUALITY OF CARE,
ASSIST WITH RECRUITING AND
RETAINING PROVIDERS AND PROVIDE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR CAREER
ADVANCEMENTS TO I HÌ S¼ S¼
PROVIDERS THROUGH THESE TRAINING
CLASSES. THE PROVIDERS CAN
COMPLETE CLASSES IN FIVE CAREER
PATHWAYS, UH, TO GENERAL
PATHWAYS, THE GENERAL HEALTH AND
SAFETY, UH, PATHWAY AND THE
ADULT EDUCATION PATHWAY AND THEN
THREE SPECIALIZED PATHWAYS, ONE
ON COGNITIVE IMPAIRMENTS AND
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH. ONE ON
COMPLEX CARE. EXCUSE ME, COMPLEX
PHYSICAL CARE NEEDS AND ONE ON
TRANSITIONING TO IN HOME CARE
AND COMMUNITY BASED LIVING, UM,
TO IMPLEMENT THIS CAREER
PATHWAYS PROGRAM. WE COMPLETED
TWO PROCUREMENTS TO BRING ON
TRAINING VENDORS. UM WE ALSO
BROUGHT ON A SEPARATE VENDOR TO
CREATE CAREER LATTICES TO HELP
PROVIDERS UNDERSTAND WHAT THEIR,
UM CAREER OPTIONS WERE BOTH IN
THE I HÌ S¼ S¼ PROGRAM AND
OUTSIDE OF IT IN OTHER HEALTH
CARE FIELDS AND WE PROVIDED ARE
PROVIDING COACHING SERVICES TO
ASSIST PROVIDERS. UM, WHO MAY BE
INTERESTED IN, UM, EXPLORING
SOME OF THOSE ADDITIONAL
HEALTHCARE OPPORTUNITIES. AH A
SMALL SET OF CLASSES LAUNCHED IN
OCTOBER OF 2022. THOSE CLASSES
WERE OFFERED BY SEVERAL OF OUR
COUNTY PUBLIC AUTHORITIES. UM
BUT THE CLASSES THEMSELVES WERE
MADE AVAILABLE STATEWIDE. IN
JANUARY OF 2023 ARE TWO VENDOR
ARE TWO TRAINING VENDORS, WHICH
ARE HOME BRIDGE AND THE CENTER
FOR CAREGIVER ADVANCEMENT. UM
BOTH CAME ON BOARD AND STARTED
OFFERING A MUCH BROADER ARRAY OF
CLASSES AND MANY MORE, UM,
ACTUAL CLASS INSTANCES OF THE
CLASSES. UM AND WE, UH, WERE
ABLE TO ADD ADDITIONAL CLASSES
IN MARCH OF 2023. UM THEN WE
ALSO MOST RECENTLY WORKED WITH
OUR TRAINING VENDORS TO DOUBLE
THE NUMBER OF CLASSES. UM,
STARTING IN JANUARY OF 2024. UM
OUR STATISTICS SO FAR AS OF
JANUARY 31ST 2024. WE HAVE HAD
13,000 THREE 140 PROVIDERS
COMPLETE AT LEAST ONE TRAINING
CLASS. BUT OUR EXPERIENCE, UH
FROM, UH OR OUR DATA IS SHOWING
THAT PROVIDERS ARE TAKING FAR
MORE THAN ONE CLASS, AND MANY
ARE COMPLETING ENOUGH CLASSES
TO, UH, EARN THE INCENTIVE
PAYMENTS. UM WHICH WE ARE
STARTING TO RECEIVE CLAIMS FOR.
UM, WE HAVE WORKED CONTINUOUSLY
WITH OUR TRAINING, UH, VENDORS
TO MAKE MORE CLASS CLASSES
AVAILABLE AND WE APPRECIATE BOTH
VENDORS FOR BEING OPEN TO
CONTINUING TO INCREASE THE
NUMBER NUMBER OF CLASSES. AS I
MENTIONED. WE HAVE DOUBLED THE
NUMBER OF CLASSES IN JANUARY,
AND WE ARE TRYING TO DETERMINE
KIND OF WHAT IMPACT THAT WILL
HAVE ON AVAILABILITY AND ACCESS
TO CLASSES FOR PROVIDERS. UM, WE
ARE SEEING GOOD RESULTS FROM
THAT, UM, WE LOOKED AT OUR DATA
BASICALLY THROUGH FROM JANUARY
AND THROUGH THE FIRST HALF OF
FEBRUARY AND WE SEE THAT WE HAVE
RECEIVED 40,000 CLAIMS FOR
TRAINING TIME. UM IN THOSE SIX
WEEKS, AND WE HAVE ALSO RECEIVED
2000 INCENTIVE PAYMENT CLAIMS
THAT WE ARE WORKING TO PROCESS
WE DO ALL THOSE PROCESSES, UM
MANUALLY. UM AND THEN WE HAVE
CONTINUED MONTHLY OUTREACH TO
PROVIDERS, UM THROUGH OUR
ELECTRONIC SERVICES PORTAL
THROUGH SOCIAL MEDIA AND THROUGH
EMAIL TO MAKE THEM AWARE OF NEW
CLASS AVAILABILITY AND TO
ENCOURAGE THEM TO ENROLL IN
CLASSES. UM AND UH, THE, UM,
AGENDA DID A GOOD JOB GOING OVER
ALL OF THIS, BUT I'LL JUST, UH,
FLAG THAT FOR THE INCENTIVE
PAYMENTS FOR INCENTIVE ONE,
WHICH IS COMPLETING 15 HOURS OF
TRAINING IN ONE OF THE PATHWAYS
WE HAVE, UM, NOW PROCESSED, UM,
OVER 14,600 CLAIMS FOR INCENTIVE
TWO. WHICH IS THOSE 15 HOURS. UH
PLUS WORKING FOR SOMEBODY FOR
ONE MONTH, WE HAVE PROCESSED
1177 CLAIMS AND THE THIRD
INCENTIVE WHICH IS LIKE SECOND
ONLY WORKING FOR SOMEBODY FOR
SIX MONTHS INSTEAD OF ONE MONTH.
WE HAVE PROCESSED 292 CLAIMS,
BUT WE EXPECT THOSE NUMBERS TO
KEEP INCREASING AS THOSE SIX
MONTHS. YOU KNOW, IT'S MORE
LIKELY THAT SOMEONE WILL HAVE
TAKEN THE CLASSES AND GOTTEN SIX
MONTHS OF TIME. UM IN 2024. UM
AND THE LAST THING I'LL JUST
FLAG IS THAT WE'VE PROCESSED
OVER THE SINCE, UH, THE END OF
JANUARY, MORE THAN 280,000
CLAIMS TOTAL UM I'LL MOVE ON TO
QUESTION TWO. WHICH IS HOW HAS
THE EXTENSION OF THE HÌ èC B S¼
SPENDING PLAN THAT WAS APPROVED
AS PART OF THE 23 BUDGET
AFFECTED THE CAREER PATHWAYS
PROGRAM. UM I'LL JUST SAY, UM IT
HAS BEEN A REALLY IMPORTANT
EXTENSION TO HELP US TO CONTINUE
THE PROGRAM. UM THIS PROGRAM WAS
ONLY STOOD UP UNDER THOSE
DOLLARS. SO UM, IT ALLOWED US TO
CONTINUE IT, UM, INTO 2024. WHEN
ORIGINALLY WE THOUGHT WE WOULD
HAVE TO CONCLUDE AT THE END OF
23. UM, AGAIN, AS I MENTIONED
JUST FROM THE FIRST SIX WEEKS OF
DATA, WE ARE SEEING A REALLY
HIGH NUMBER OF CLAIMS BEING
SUBMITTED. UM AND WE EXPECT
THOSE TRENDS TO CONTINUE WITH
THE INCREASED NUMBER OF CLASSES.
UM ON THE CURRENT SCHEDULE. THE
CLASSES ARE SCHEDULED TO END ON
SEPTEMBER. 30TH OF 2024
PROVIDERS WILL BE ALLOWED TO,
UM, CONTINUE TO COUNT THE MONTH
OF OCTOBER TOWARD THOSE
INCENTIVE PAYMENTS, PARTICULARLY
THE ONE MONTH AND SIX MONTH
INCENTIVE PAYMENTS AND THEN WE
ARE REQUESTING, UM, PROVIDERS TO
SUBMIT ALL CLAIMS BY NOVEMBER
15TH SO THAT WE CAN PAY THEM ALL
OUT BY THE END OF THE YEAR AND
CLOSE OUT OUR, UH, ACCOUNTING AS
REQUIRED UNDER THE HÌ èC B S¼
SPENDING PLAN. UH THEN I'LL GO
TO QUESTION THREE. OUR LATEST,
UM, THE LATEST DATA AVAILABLE.
WE'RE SHOWING ONLY $40 MILLION
OF THE 295 MILLION HAD BEEN
SPENT. AND SO WHAT WAS THE PLAN
ADMINISTRATION'S PLAN TO ENSURE
THIS FUNDING WAS FULLY SPENT. SO
I WOULD JUST LIKE TO POINT OUT
THAT THAT 40 MILLION IS TIMED
OFF OF THE END OF SEPTEMBER. SO
THE END OF, UM UH, ONLY THREE
QUARTERS OF LAST YEAR, SO WE ARE
WORKING TO PROVIDE, UM, UPDATED
NUMBERS. UM WE WILL BOTH BE ABLE
TO PROVIDE UPDATED, UM,
EXPENDITURE DATA SOONER AND THEN
WE'LL BE ABLE. WE BELIEVE BY MAY
REVISION TO HAVE ENOUGH DATA
FROM ALL THE INCREASED CLASSES
TO DETERMINE WHETHER THERE WILL
BE ANY REMAINING FUNDS BY THE
END OF THE YEAR. UM AND WE ARE
CONTINUING TO MONITOR OUR CLASS
ATTENDANCE TRAINING AND
INCENTIVE CLAIMS SO THAT WE HAVE
ABILITY TO UPDATE OUR
PROJECTIONS BASED ON ACTUALS. UM
AND I GOT AHEAD OF MYSELF A
LITTLE JUST SAY THAT THOSE
UPDATED NUMBERS WE THINK WE CAN
BASICALLY PROVIDE YOU WITH DATA
THROUGH, UM, AT LEAST THE END OF
LAST YEAR. UM, PROBABLY BY THE
END OF THIS MONTH, SO WE'LL HAVE
SOME UPDATED EXPENDITURE DATA.
THEN, UM AND, UM WE REALLY AGAIN
WANT TO ENCOURAGE, AND, UH WE
KEEP DOING OUR OUTREACH AND
MAKING SURE THAT PROVIDERS KNOW
ABOUT THE CLASSES THAT THEY HAVE
ACCESS TO THE CLASSES. UM,
TRYING TO ELIMINATE, UM PEOPLE
WAIT, GETTING WAITING LISTS OR
SEEING CLASSES AS CLOSED. UM AND
WE REALLY WANT EVERYONE TO TAKE
FULL ADVANTAGE OF THIS
OPPORTUNITY. UM, WHILE WE
CONTINUE TO RUN IT THROUGH THIS
YEAR, AND WITH THAT I WILL
PAUSE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO
MUCH, UM, MOVING OVER TO ITALY.
FROM THE FINANCE. YOU KNOW
BETTER DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
NOTHING FURTHER TO ADD. THANK
YOU, UM JOAN. YOU WANT DAUGHTER
THAT, UM, ANALYSTS OFFICE. UM SO
, AS WE NOTED LAST YEAR, THIS
PROGRAM HAS BEEN SLOW TO START.
UM AND THOUGH AS WAS ALLUDED,
THE SPENDING HAS BEGUN TO PICK
UP. UM, OVER THE LAST COUPLE OF
MONTHS. UM, WE STILL DO HAVE
SOME QUESTIONS ON IF IT IS
POSSIBLE TO, UM, EXPAND ALL OF
THE LOT OF FUNDS BY THE, UM
CLOSE OF THE PROGRAM. AND SO I
JUST NOTED IN THE AGENDA, THE
JOINT LEGISLATIVE BUDGET
COMMITTEE HAS BEEN WORKING WITH
THE, UM, ADMINISTRATION ON THIS
TOPIC. UM AND GATHERING MORE
INFORMATION ON, UM SOME
SPENDING. UM THE SPENDING TRENDS
AND PROPOSED TIMELINES FOR
SPENDING IN THE NEXT COUPLE OF
MONTHS. UM HOWEVER, WE DO AND I
GUESS WITH THAT WE, UM WE DO
BELIEVE THAT THE EARLIER WE CAN
GET THAT INFORMATION BACK. UM AS
WAS NOTED IN, UM, GET SOME OF
THOSE ANSWERS. THE BETTER OFF
THE LEGISLATURE WILL BE IN KIND
OF DEVELOPING A PLAN FOR HOW, UM
TO BEST EXPEND THOSE FUNDS IN A
WAY THAT BEST, UM, ALIGNS WITH
THE LEGISLATURE'S, UM
PRIORITIES. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
BEFORE WE GO MOVE INTO QUESTIONS
. UM TIFFANY WINNING FROM IS
GONNA BE JOINING US IS JOINING
US FROM S¼ èC IU. TIFFANY WHITE
WITH THE èC IU, CALIFORNIA ON
BEHALF OF OUR 700,000 WORKERS
ACROSS THE STATE, BUT IN
PARTICULAR OVER 400,000 LONG
TERM CARE WORKERS, THE MAJORITY
OF WHICH ARE I HÌ S¼ S¼
PROVIDERS, THE HOME CARE
WORKFORCE, INCLUDING THE I HÌ S¼
S¼ WORKFORCE CONSISTS
DISPROPORTIONATELY OF WOMEN OF
COLOR IN IMMIGRANT WORKERS WHO
HAVE HISTORICALLY BEEN EXCLUDED
FROM BASIC WORKER PROTECTIONS
AND BEEN SUBJECT TO POOR JOB
QUALITY. IT IS A WORKFORCE THAT
HAS BEEN TOO LONG, UNSEEN AND
UNDERAPPRECIATED. THIS
UNDERSCORES THE OF THE I HÌ S¼
S¼ CAREER PATHWAYS PROGRAM, A
PAID AND INCENTIVE TRAINING
PROGRAM FOR I HÌ S¼ S¼ AND WP
èC S¼ PROVIDERS HELPING TO
ADVANCE RACIAL, GENDER AND
LINGUISTIC EQUITY BY REFRAMING
AND REPOSITIONING THE WORKFORCE
AS ONE TO BE INVESTED IN VALUED
AND TREATED WITH DIGNITY. THE
PROGRAM AIMS AIMS TO PROVIDE
HIGH QUALITY ACCESSIBLE TRAINING
TO I HÌ S¼ S¼ AND WP èC S¼
PROVIDERS STATEWIDE TO STABILIZE
THE WORKFORCE AND ENCOURAGE THE
RECRUITMENT AND RETENTION OF TO
IMPROVE THE QUALITY OF CARE FOR
CONSUMERS AND TO PROVIDE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR CAREER
ADVANCEMENT IN HOME AND HEALTH
CARE. THE èC PP ALIGNS WITH
CALIFORNIA'S MASTER PLAN ON
AGING 2324 INITIATIVES TO
DIVERSIFY THE PIPELINE OF DIRECT
CARE WORKERS BY TESTING AND
SCALING EMERGING MODELS TO
EXPLORE OPPORTUNITIES TO EXPAND
CAREER PATHWAYS FOR DIRECT CARE
WORKERS AND TO DEVELOP AN
INVENTORY OF EVIDENCE BASED
TRAINING, CAREER LADDER AND
CERTIFICATE CERTIFICATION
PROGRAMS THAT ARE ACCESSIBLE,
PERSON CENTERED AND CULTURALLY
AND LINGUISTICALLY RESPONSIVE.
THE I HÌ S¼ S¼ CAREER PATHWAYS
PROGRAM. OR èC PP RESPONSE, UM,
SPECIFICALLY TO THE INDUSTRY'S
LACK OF OPPORTUNITIES FOR
TRAINING AND CAREER ADVANCEMENT
FOR I HÌ S¼ S¼ PROVIDERS NÓ
FORMER CAREER LADDER EXISTS
WITHIN I HÌ S¼ S¼ AND PROVIDERS
SEEKING CAREER ADVANCEMENT HAVE
TO LOOK OUTSIDE OF THE I HÌ S¼
S¼ PROGRAM OR OTHER PROFESSIONS
IN INDUSTRIES AS THE PROGRAM
CONTINUES TO EXPAND TO CARE FOR
MORE POPULATIONS IN NEED. WE
MUST WORK TO STABILIZE AND
UPLIFT THE WORKFORCE BY
FORMALIZING TRAINING
OPPORTUNITIES AND BUILDING OUR
CAREER. PATHWAYS WITHIN I HÌ S¼
S¼, WHICH IS EXACTLY WHAT èC PP
HAS BEEN WORKING TOWARDS. THE
BENEFITS OF TRAINING ARE FAR
REACHING AS PROVIDERS ARE
EMPOWERED WITH KNOWLEDGE AND
FOUNDATIONAL AND SPECIALIZED
SKILLS THROUGH èC PP. CONSUMERS
CAN BENEFIT IMMENSELY FROM AN
IMPROVED CARE EXPERIENCE. THE
èC PP PROVIDES A REMARKABLE AND
HISTORIC AMOUNT OF FUNDING FOR
TRAINING THE HOME CARE WORKFORCE
, WHICH IN RETURN WILL ENHANCE
THE DELIVERY SYSTEM AND PROVIDE
IMPROVED CARE FOR THE CONSUMERS
OF THE PROGRAM. WE IMPLORE THE
STATE TO DO EVERYTHING IT CAN TO
UTILIZE EVERY DOLLAR ALLOCATED
TO THE PROGRAM AND MADE GOOD ON
THE INTENT OF THE PROGRAM AS WE
CAN DO SO BY HAVING AN 18 MONTH
EXTENSION TO USE ALL THE FUNDS.
I SAT BEFORE YOU ALL LAST YEAR
IN MARCH ON THE SAME ISSUE, AND
ONLY 2.7 MILLION OF THE 295
MILLION WAS SPENT. WE WERE TOLD
THE DOLLARS WOULD DEFINITELY BE
UTILIZED IN THE INITIAL TIME
FRAME. BY MARCH, 2024. THE
PROGRAM WAS NOT ON TRACK TO
UTILIZE THE FUNDING IN THAT TIME
FRAME, SO WE REQUESTED AN
EXTENSION, WHICH IS THE CURRENT
DECEMBER 2024 DEADLINE, BUT WITH
ONLY 41 MILLION BEING SPENT TO
DATE, IT SEEMS LIKE WE ARE AGAIN
NOT ON TRACK TO REALIZE THE
TOTAL FUNDING AND THUS THE TRUE
INTENT OF THE PROGRAM. GIVEN
THERE ARE CLAIMS NOT ACCOUNTED
FOR, AND MORE TO COME. IT STILL
DOESN'T SEEM LIKE THE MONEY WILL
GET OUT THE DOOR BY THE END OF
THE YEAR. WHILE WE APPRECIATE
ALL THAT GOES INTO MAKING THE
PROGRAM WORK, SIGNING CONTRACTS
WITH VENDORS, INCREASING THE
AMOUNT OF CLASSES THAT ARE HARD
TO GET IN, I MIGHT ADD, UM, AND
PROCESSING OF CLAIMS, STOPPING
THE PROGRAM PREMATURELY BECAUSE
WE COULDN'T GET ALL THE FUNDING.
UM OUT THE DOOR IN A GIVEN TIME,
SEES CONTRADICTORY TO THE GOALS
OF THE MASTER PLAN ON AGING AND
THE INTENT OF THE PROGRAM. WE
WOULD LIKE TO CONTINUE TO WORK
IN PARTNERSHIP WITH THIS
WONDERFUL COMMITTEE Dð Ó, F Dð,
S¼ S¼ AND Dð HÌ èC S¼ TO ENSURE
THAT PROVIDERS ARE GIVEN THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARPEN THEIR
CRAFT, INCREASE THEIR KNOWLEDGE
AND ULTIMATELY BETTER SERVE
THEIR CONSUMERS. WE ARE
COMMITTED TO EXPLORING THE
BARRIERS OF THE PROGRAM AND HOW
WE CAN MITIGATE THEM. WE TRULY
BELIEVE THAT èC PP IS A
VALUABLE RESOURCE. THAT SHOULD
BE A FORMAL TOOL EMBEDDED IN THE
I HÌ S¼ S¼ PROGRAM, NOT ONLY FOR
THIS SHORT PERIOD OF TIME, BUT
ONGOING AS IT IS IMPERATIVE THAT
WE GET RIGHT. WE HAVE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE IN PLACE AND
PROVIDERS THAT ARE MORE THAN
WILLING TO ENGAGE. ALL WE NEED
TO DO IS GET THE MONEY OUT THE
DOOR TO KEEP THE PROGRAM GOING.
UM SO THAT ALL CAN REAP THE
BENEFITS OF SUCH A GREAT
PROGRAM. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK IN FRONT OF
YOU TODAY. THANK YOU SO MUCH,
STEPHANIE. YOU KNOW, LAST YEAR
DURING THIS HEARING, WE HAD
UTILIZED ABOUT $2.7 MILLION OF
THE FUNDING. WE HAVE JUMPED UP
TO 41. I DO RECOGNIZE THOSE ARE
NUMBERS UNTIL SEPTEMBER, BUT
THAT TREND IS ABOUT $3 MILLION A
MONTH. I DID THE MATH AND WE
WOULD HAVE TO DO 30. $1 MILLION
A MONTH TO HIT ALL THAT NUMBER.
I'M STILL VERY CONCERNED THAT
WE'RE NOT GONNA HIT IT AND I
KNOW WE CAN'T DO AN EXTENSION IN
THE SITUATION LIKE WE WERE LAST
YEAR. THIS IS A FEDERAL DEADLINE
AND I HEAR YOU, BUT I WE CAN'T
SO I'M DEALING WITH THIS REALITY
OF. OF COURSE, LET'S UTILIZE IT
AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE FOR CAREER
PATHWAYS. BUT AS I HEARD FROM L
A Ó THE JLB èC IS TALKING, UH
TO THE ADMINISTRATION ON HOW
ELSE WE CAN USE THIS FUND
BECAUSE I DON'T WANT TO LEAVE A
DOLLAR OR 50 CENTS ON THE ON THE
TABLE. WHEN WE'RE PROPOSING, UH,
DDS RATE REFORM PUSHBACK. SO
THAT'S THE FIRST THING THAT CAME
TO MIND DIRECTOR. I KNOW YOU'RE
NOT HERE, BUT IT'S THE FIRST
THING THAT CAME TO MIND CAN WE
USE AND THEN WE'VE DONE THIS IN
THE PAST WHERE WE'VE COME TO THE
ADMINISTRATION WHERE WE'VE
ALLOCATED A SHIFT IN FUNDS UNDER
HÌ, Dð B S¼, AND I'M WONDERING,
I DON'T WANT TO WAIT TILL THE
MAY REVISE. I DON'T KNOW WHAT
THOSE CONVERSATIONS LOOK LIKE.
AND WE USE SOME OF THAT TO DO
ONLY A SIX MONTH DELAY FOR G Dð
S¼ RATE REFORMS BECAUSE WE COULD
UTILIZE SIX MONTHS FUNDING UNDER
HÌ èC B S¼. IT'S COMPLEX. I
UNDERSTAND THAT, BUT THE
CONVERSATION WE NEED TO START
NOW AND NOW IN MAY NOW SHIFTING
BACK TO THE PRIORITY AT HANNAH
EIGHT CAREER PATHWAYS. I KNOW
THAT'S THE NUMBER ONE PRIORITY,
AND I APPRECIATE THE CLASSES
HAVE BEEN DOUBLING. UM, MY
SISTER TAKES A CLASS. SHE'S SO
EXCITED. SHE TELLS ME ABOUT THE
CLASSES SHE'S TAKING AND STIPEND
. SO SHE CONTINUES TO TAKE, UH,
CLASSES BECAUSE SHE'S A I HÌ S¼
S¼, UH, PROVIDER. UM CARE,
HEALTH CARE PROVIDER. UM AND I
KNOW WE'RE STILL HERE HAVING
SOME BARRIERS, UM, FOR
INDIVIDUALS. WHAT ARE WE DOING?
NOW DIFFERENTLY. WE WERE ABLE TO
RAMP UP. WE'RE STARTING. WHAT
NOW? ARE WE DOING TO BE SPEEDY
GONZALEZ AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE TO
GET EVEN MORE. CLASS IS GOING,
UM, REMOVING THE LAST BARRIERS
THAT WE HAVE, POTENTIALLY ON
GETTING THESE PEOPLE, UM, IN
THESE CLASSES TO HIT BECAUSE
IT'S I DON'T THINK WE'RE GONNA
MAKE IT. I REALLY DON'T THINK
WE'RE GOING TO MAKE IT. BUT WHAT
DO YOU ENVISION IS NEEDED TO
MAKE TO MAKE IT. APPRECIATE THAT
QUESTION AND APPRECIATE JUST
FLAGGING THAT THAT LARGER
QUESTION ABOUT SHIFT IN FUNDING
RIGHT IS SUCH A LARGER QUESTION
AROUND THE HÌ èC B S¼ FUNDING
THAT èC Dð S¼ S¼ IS NOT THE
LEAD THERE. SO UH, SORT OF, UM,
BUT BUT WE'LL TAKE THAT BACK, UH
, AS THE ADMINISTRATION TO
DISCUSS THAT, UM I. I REALLY
THINK WE HAVE UNLOCKED WHAT WE
NEEDED TO UNLOCK, UM, IN TERMS
OF DOUBLING THE CLASSES. WE DID
SEE THAT THERE WERE WE DID NOT
LIMIT THE NUMBER OF CLASSES
PEOPLE COULD TAKE IN THE PROGRAM
, AND ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WAS
CHALLENGING ABOUT THAT IS THAT
PEOPLE WHO WERE MAYBE EARLY
ADOPTERS AND WERE IN AND UM,
WERE ABLE TO KIND OF KNOW THE
SYSTEM, UNDERSTAND THE SYSTEM
AND GET INTO CLASSES QUICKLY,
WHICH IS BOTH GREAT. WE WANT
PEOPLE TO TAKE THE CLASSES, BUT
IT MEANT THAT PEOPLE MAYBE WHO
WERE FINDING OUT ABOUT IT NEWLY
OR WEREN'T FAMILIAR WITH THE
SYSTEM MADE BY THE TIME THEY GOT
THERE, WHEN, WHEN A NEW, UM
TRANCHE OF CLASSES OPENED UP
CLA. A LOT OF CLASSES WERE
CLOSED. SO THAT WAS, I THINK THE
BIGGEST BARRIER WE WERE TO
SEEING TO REALLY EXPANDING THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO COULD
ACCESS THE CLASSES, AND THAT'S
WHY WE DID DOUBLE THE CLASSES IN
JANUARY, UM TO YOUR QUESTION
ABOUT THE RATE OF SPENDING. UM
WE ALSO, UM ANTICIPATE THAT
REALLY IT'S NOT, UM GOING TO BE
LINEAR BECAUSE THE INCENTIVE
CLAIMS ARE REALLY WHERE THE BIG
DOLLAR AMOUNTS ARE GOING TO
START COMING. SO ONE OF THE
THINGS YOU KNOW WE WERE KIND OF
LOOKING AT WAS, UM WHILE WE ARE
PAYING OUT WAGES THAT'S ONE HOUR
AT A TIME IS A SMALL AMOUNT FROM
THAT. HUGE UH, $295 MILLION
ALLOCATION. BUT AS WE START
PAYING OUT INCENTIVES OF 500
MORE DOUBLE 502,000 WILL START
TO SEE THE MONEY REALLY RAMP UP
AT A MUCH HIGHER RATE. SO THAT'S
WHY WE'RE TRYING TO LOOK AT OUR
ACTUALS TO SEE TO YOUR POINT. IF
WE SORT OF STARTED SLOW AND NOW
ARE REALLY AT, UH UH, INFLECTION
POINT AND CURVING UP, AND WE ARE
COMMITTED TO SPENDING ALL THE
DOLLARS WITHIN OUR PROGRAM AS
MISS WHITE AND SAID UM THIS IS A
REALLY IMPORTANT PROGRAM. WE
WANT TO SUPPORT OUR I HÌ S¼ S¼
PROVIDERS. WE DON'T HAVE A
PROGRAM WITHOUT THEM. THEY'LL
PROGRAM ONLY WORKS WHEN WE HAVE
BOTH SIDES, AND SO, UM, WE
COMPLETELY UNDERSTAND WHAT
YOU'RE ASKING ABOUT SHIFTING OF
FUNDS, AND I WOULD JUST SAY AS
THE DEPARTMENT WE'RE REALLY
COMMITTED TO THIS PROGRAM AND TO
SPENDING THE FUNDS AND TO MAKING
SURE THAT ALL OF OUR  N HÌ S¼ S¼
PROVIDERS HAVE THE BENEFIT OF
THESE CLASSES AND OF THE
INCENTIVE AND, UH, TRAINING
DOLLARS. ON THE SAME PAGE. UH,
AS YOU AT WHAT POINT DO WE SOUND
THE ALARM? DO WE HAVE AN
INTERNAL MONTH. ARE WE WAITING
TILL THE MAY REVISE TO
POTENTIALLY SOUND ALARM IF WE'RE
HALFWAY THROUGH THE MONTH. IS
THERE SOMETHING IN AN INTERNAL
MARK WE'RE LOOKING FOR WHERE
WE'RE GONNA BE REALLY WORRIED.
WE THINK THAT THE MAY REVISION
WILL BE THE RIGHT MOMENT TO
DETERMINE WHETHER OR NOT THE
FULL EXPENDITURE CAN HAPPEN BY
THE END OF THE YEAR AND WHETHER
THERE'LL BE ANY REMAINING FUNDS.
IF THE CHAIR WOULD LIKE TO ASK
FOR A DIFFERENT DATE. WE'RE OPEN
TO, UM, REVISITING SOONER, BUT
THAT'S WHAT WE THINK WILL
REALISTICALLY HAVE A GOOD SENSE.
OK? I'M JUST WONDERING, YOU KNOW
, THE MARY RIVER? UH, REVISE
COMES OUT AND IT'S BLINK OF AN
EYE, RIGHT? THERE'S GONNA BE
HALF A BREATH LEFT TO MAYBE
POTENTIALLY SHIFT IF WE CAN DO
THAT. I FEEL THAT IT'S A LITTLE
TOO LATE. FOR THIS. I WOULD LIKE
TO GET SOMETHING SOONER. UM AND
WHATEVER WE HAVE, WHETHER IT'S
JUST SUPER RAW, NOT FULLY COOKED
, BUT JUST SOMETHING TO, UM, BE
PREPARED FOR THE MAY REVISE.
THANK YOU. WE WILL GET YOU, UM
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION SOONER.
UM, IS WILL WORK WITH WITH
ELIZABETH TO FIGURE OUT THANK
YOU. SENATORS, SENATOR R. WAS
THIS THE PROGRAM THAT WE SPENT A
LOT OF TIME ON LAST YEAR. YES.
YES, IT WAS. YES, IT IS. YOU
KNOW, I. I REMEMBER BACK WHEN?
DURING MY DAYS IN THE MILITARY
AND I'M NOT SURE THAT THOSE THAT
WERE IN CHARGE OF PLANNING
PLANNED VERY WELL. BUT YOU NEVER
QUITE KNEW WHETHER YOU'RE GONNA
HAVE A BUDGET SURPLUS AND THEY'D
ASK THE AGENCIES AND THE WORK
SECTIONS TO SUBMIT REQUESTS
PROCUREMENT REQUESTS FOR MOSTLY
EQUIPMENT, NOT PROGRAMS, AND
THEY'D STACK THEM UP. AND THEN
IF THEY DECIDED IF WE DIDN'T
SPEND ALL THE MONEY, THEY JUST
GO THROUGH THE STACK FROM TOP TO
BOTTOM, AND WHETHER YOU NEEDED A
NEW COMPUTER OR NOT, OR YOU
NEEDED A NEW DESK CHAIR OR NOT,
YOU'D GET A NEW COMPUTER. YOU'D
GET A NEW DESK CHAIR, AND THEY'D
LINE THEM UP IN THE HALLWAYS,
SORT OF A WASTEFUL WAY TO DEAL
WITH GOVERNMENT SPENDING AND
TAXPAYER MONEY. YOU'RE ASKING US
TO BE LIKE OPRAH, RIGHT? YOU GET
A AND III. I GUESS MY QUESTION
LAST YEAR. I REALLY CAN'T
REMEMBER THEM. BUT I SUSPECT
THAT BUT THEY WERE WERE TIED TO
TRYING TO PLAN THIS OUT. AND I
REALIZED THAT YOU KNOW THERE ARE
VARIABLES IN WHAT YOU DO. BUT
I'M HOPING STARTING TODAY WE CAN
FIGURE OUT A PLAN. UM AND I'M
I'M NOT THE SURE OF ANYTHING
HAVING TO DO WITH BUDGET. AND SO
I WOULDN'T BE THE ONE TO BE
CONTACTED. BUT I'M HOPING
THERE'S CONSTANT COMMUNICATION
WITH THE BUDGET STAFF ON WHERE
WE ARE ON THIS EXPENDITURE PLAN
AND THAT THERE HAS HAS BEEN
SINCE LAST THE LAST TIME WE CAME
TO THE PARTY HERE TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION BECAUSE IT WOULD BE
UNFORTUNATE IF WE EITHER SPENT
MONEY ON STUFF. THAT REALLY
ISN'T CRITICAL TO THE MISSION
BECAUSE THIS IS A VERY CRITICAL
PROGRAM IN OUR STATE. UM AND IT
WOULD ALSO BE EQUALLY
UNFORTUNATE IF WE DIDN'T USE THE
MONEY, UH, THAT WERE PROVIDED.
SO THOSE ARE JUST MY COMMENTS,
MADAM CHAIR FOR WHAT THEY'RE
WORTH. I I'M I'M HOPING WE ARE
VERY TALENTED PEOPLE HERE IN THE
ADMINISTRATION AND PARTICULARLY
WORKING THIS ISSUE, AND I KNOW
YOU CAN FIGURE THIS THING OUT SO
LOOKING FORWARD TO A SUCCESSFUL
OUTCOME AND SPENDING THE PROGRAM
DOWN TO ZERO. YOUR THOUGHTS ARE
WORTH A LOT. SENATOR ROTH. UM
AND I'M JUST GONNA ASK A OUT OF
THE BLUE QUESTION. DO WE HAVE
THE ABILITY TO INCREASE THE
AMOUNT OF THE STIPENDS THAT GO
OUT? THANK YOU FOR THAT
QUESTION. AND SENATOR ROTH.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS. UM
WE CAN TAKE THAT BACK AND LOOK
AT IT. THE AMOUNTS WERE NOT SET
IN STATUTE. WE WERE, UM
DETERMINING THEM BASED ON WHAT
WE THOUGHT WOULD, YOU KNOW,
ALLOW A LARGE NUMBER OF PEOPLE
TO COME IN AND US NOT TO RUN OUT
OF MONEY, AND THAT'S NOT JUST A
SENATOR ROSS POINT IT WAS A, UM
WE HAVE DONE A LOT OF PLANNING,
BUT IT WAS A VERY LARGE PROGRAM
TO SET UP UNDER A VERY, VERY
TIGHT TIMELINE. SO UM, WE CAN
CERTAINLY TAKE THAT QUESTION
BACK AND PROVIDE THE, UH, CHAIR
WITH ADDITIONAL INFORMATION ON
THAT QUESTION. THANK YOU SO MUCH
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS? OK GREAT.
WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO ISSUE
NUMBER. UH, SIX. OUR FINAL ISSUE
UNDER THIS. SECTION. APS
PLANNING AND DEVELOPMENT OF A
DATA WAREHOUSE. HELLO GOOD
AFTERNOON, MADAM CHAIR. UH,
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. MY NAME IS
JAMES TRE. I'M THE PROGRAM
ADMINISTRATOR OF ADULT
PROTECTIVE SERVICES. AND I'M
HERE TO TALK ABOUT THE BUDGET
CHANGE PROPOSAL REGARDING THE ÁP
S¼ DATA WAREHOUSE. UH, I THINK
THE AGENDA DID A REALLY GOOD JOB
OF GIVING AN OVERVIEW OF THIS
PROPOSAL AND I WILL JUST COVER
SOME OF THE HIGHLIGHTS.
CALIFORNIA WAS ALLOCATED
APPROXIMATELY $1.4 MILLION BY
THE FEDERAL ADMINISTRATION FOR
COMMUNITY LIVING IN THE ELDER
JUSTICE ACT TO SUPPORT THE
STATE'S APS PROGRAM. THE
SUBMITTED PROPOSAL IS FOR THE
AUTHORITY TO SPEND THE FEDERAL
DOLLARS ON TWO POSITIONS WITHIN
èC Dð S¼ S¼ TO SUPPORT AND
BUILD THE DATA WAREHOUSE TO BE
HOUSED AT CDSS FOR THE PURPOSE
OF GATHERING AND REPORTING ON
CASE LEVEL DATA FROM COUNTY ÁP
S¼ PROGRAMS AS REQUESTED BY A
C'S NATIONAL ADULT MALTREATMENT
REPORTING SYSTEM, UH, COMMONLY
KNOWN AS NAMES. IT'S ANTICIPATED
THAT THE DATABASE WILL BE
LAUNCHED IN JANUARY OF 2026. OUR
PLAN IS TO WORK WITH THE
COUNTIES AND èC W Dð A TO
DEVELOP REQUIREMENTS AND DEFINE
BUSINESS PROCESSES WITH THE
SHARED GOAL OF REDUCING COUNTY
WORKLOAD AS ASSOCIATED WITH THE
DATA REPORTING. AS WELL AS
BUILDING A DATABASE, AN
INTERFACE THAT WILL CONNECT
EXISTING COUNTY CASE MANAGEMENT
SYSTEMS, AUTOMATE DATA TRANSFERS
AND COLLECT CASE LEVEL DATA
DIRECTLY FROM COUNT DATABASES,
MAKING FEDERAL REPORTING AND
TREND ANALYSIS MORE ACCURATE.
IT'S ANTICIPATED THAT THIS
SOLUTION WILL BRING CDS SS INTO
COMPLIANCE WITH THE NAMES, DATA
AND REPORTING REQUIREMENTS AND
LEAD TO CONSISTENT STATEWIDE
DATA REPORTING BY ALL COUNTIES.
HAVING CASE LEVEL TIMELY DATA
WILL INFORM AND IMPACT OUTREACH
APS WORKER TRAINING AND MAKE
SURE THAT ÁP S¼ PROGRAMS
RESPONSE TO ABUSE ALLEGATIONS OR
MORE TIMELY, EFFECTIVE AND
EQUITABLE FOR PROGRAM CLIENTS.
WITH AGGREGATE DATA. THERE IS NÓ
WAY TO ANALYZE THE
INTERSECTIONAL FEATURES OF THESE
CASES TO SEE IF THERE ARE
TARGETED INTERVENTION
INTERVENTIONS THAT CAN BE
DEPLOYED TO ADDRESS THE NEEDS OF
THESE CLIENTS. CASE LEVEL DATA
WILL ALLOW THE PROGRAM TO BETTER
IDENTIFY AND RESOLVE DISPARITIES
WITHIN THE COMMUNITY WHILE
IMPROVING EQUITABLE OUTCOMES IN
CALIFORNIA FOR OLDER,
INDEPENDENT ADULTS, ESPECIALLY
THOSE FROM DISENFRANCHISED
COMMUNITIES. IT WILL ALLOW THE
CDSS TO REPORT ACCURATE AND
COMPLETE DATA TO NAMES TO HELP
INFORM AND PREVENT INTERVENTION
PRACTICES ON THE NATIONAL LEVEL
OF THE ADULT MALTREATMENT FIELD.
THE RESOURCES WILL AID
CALIFORNIA IN ITS ABILITY TO
EXAMINE THE TRENDS AND PATTERNS
OF ABUSE STATEWIDE FOR THE FIRST
TIME IN A P S¼ PROGRAMS IN THE A
P S¼ PROGRAM'S HISTORY. MISTER
PRESIDENT. PERMANENT FINANCE ANY
FURTHER COMMENTS. THE LEAST THAT
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NOTHING
FURTHER TO ADD. LEO. JUAN Dð
LEGSL A OFFICE WE HAVE NÓ
CONCERNS ARISE AT THIS POINT.
ARE YOU NEW TO L? A Ó? I AM
YES. WELCOME. THANK YOU. A GREAT
JOB. THIS IS ON THE FLOOR. WE
WOULD CALL A SUPPORT SUPPORT. SO
WE HAVE NÓ QUESTIONS NÓ
QUESTIONS ON THIS ITEM. WE'RE
GONNA HOLD IT OPEN AND MOVE ON.
I WAS JUST KIDDING. I HAVE ONE
MORE ISSUE UNDER THIS SECTION
ISSUE. SEVEN. A COMMUNITY CARE
LICENSING OVERVIEW. RAMSEY WITH
èC Dð S¼ S¼ AND MY COLLEAGUE
KEVIN GAINES IS COMING UP AS
WELL. GOOD AFTERNOON. KEVIN
GAINES. SOCIAL SERVICES,
COMMUNITY CARE. LICENSING UH,
DRESSING THE THREE QUESTIONS ON
THE AGENDA? UM FIRST THE
OVERVIEW OF THE 2425 BUDGET, UH,
FOR COMMUNITY CARE. LICENSING OF
THE AGENDA DOES A GREAT JOB OF
SPELLING OUT THE, UH, 270
MILLION ITEMIZING? UM UM, THOSE
REVENUES THAT SUPPORT UM CCL, Dð
AND CUTTING, INCLUDING, UH, OUR
FEDERAL FUNDS. STATE FUNDS THE,
UH, SPECIAL FUNDS MIX THAT
COMPRISE THAT, UH, THAT AMOUNT.
UH, THESE DOLLARS ARE EXPANDING,
UH OR EXPANDED ON 1571 STAFF AND
16 UNIQUE LOCATIONS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA. UM STAFF THAT ARE
CONDUCTING APPROXIMATELY 34,000
INSPECTIONS. 15,000 CASE
MANAGEMENT VISITS INVESTIGATION
INTO DISPOSITION ON 17,000
COMPLAINTS THE PROCESS OF, UH
250,000 BACKGROUND CHECKS. UM
7000 APPLICATIONS FOR NEW
LICENSURE AND PROCUREMENT ON TWO
MAJOR, I Tð PROJECTS. UM A
NUMBER OF THINGS GOING ON IN IN
FISCAL YEAR. UH UH, 2220. WE PO
NÓ NEW SPENDING OR NÓ, NÓ? UH,
NEW, UH, PROPOSALS FOR, UH, FOR
2425. UM THE QUESTION OF, UM UH,
GUARDIAN BACKLOG. UM PLANNING
ACTIVITIES FOR A REPLACEMENT TO
THE GUARDIAN SYSTEM THAT
PROCESSES UH BACKGROUND CHECKS
AND CONTROLS THAT WORKLOAD. UH
AS OF, UH, JANUARY 2024. THERE
WERE 3013 CASES. THAT UH, THAT
WE WOULD, UH, PUT IN THAT
BACKLOG, WHICH IS CONSIDERED 120
DAYS PAST. UM UH, 120 DAYS OLD
OR OLDER. WE'VE CONTINUED TO
MAKE PROGRESS. WE'VE DONE A LOT
OVER THE LAST YEAR TO, UH UM TO,
UH, GET THAT NUMBER DOWN. UM AND
WE'VE SEEN, UM UH, SOME REALLY
GOOD OUTCOMES OVER THE PAST YEAR
ATTRIBUTED TO THREE DIFFERENT
FACTORS. ONE IS THE, UM
ADDITIONAL STAFFING THAT WAS
GRANTED IN THE 20 THREE BUDGET
ACT. SECOND WAS A B, UH, 1720,
WHICH WAS IMPLEMENTED, UH, AT
THE BEGINNING OF 2023, WHICH,
UH, SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASED THE
NUMBER OF STANDARD EXEMPTIONS
THAT COULD BE PROCESSED AS
SIMPLIFIED EXEMPTIONS. AND JUST
GENERALLY IN INCREASED KNOWLEDGE
AND SUFFICIENT, UH,
SOPHISTICATION IN THE NAVIGATION
OF THIS GUARDIAN SYSTEM, BOTH ON
THE PART OF STAFF AND ON THE
PART OF STAKEHOLDERS. THERE'S A
THERE'S A HUGE UH UH, DO IT
YOURSELF, UH, SET OF FUNCTIONS
WITHIN GUARDIAN AND SO WE'VE
BEEN WORKING REALLY HARD TO, UM
TO, UH, PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND TRAIN OUR, UH,
OUR LICENSES AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS. UH, WE'RE IN THE
AS FAR AS, UH, GUARDING
REPLACEMENT. UH, WE'RE IN STAGE
TWO OF THE FOUR STAGE. UH,
PROJECT APPROVAL LIFE CYCLE AND
WE'RE NEARING COMPLETION OF THE
DISCOVERY AND RESEARCH. UH, THAT
WILL HELP US, UH, PERFORM SOME
MARKET RESEARCH AND, UH, PROVIDE
SOME ALTERNATE SOLUTIONS. UH, AS
A GUARDIAN REPLACEMENT BY THE
END OF THIS CALENDAR YEAR. UM
WE'VE CONTRACTED WITH THE
GUARDIAN VENDOR, AND WE'VE
COMPLETED A NUMBER OF
ENHANCEMENTS THAT YOU KNOW,
INCLUDE UPDATES AND
NOTIFICATIONS. UH, THAT WERE NOT
PREVIOUSLY PREVIOUSLY PART OF
THE, UH, THE GUARDIAN FEATURE
PACKAGE. UM SOME CANNED REPORTS
AND ADDITIONAL NAVIGATION, UH,
ENHANCEMENTS THAT, UH, HELP
IMPROVE THE USER EXPERIENCE.
UNLESS THERE ARE QUESTIONS I'LL
GO ON TO THE THIRD QUESTION. ALL
RIGHT. UM REGARDING THE HOME
CARE FUND AND ACTIONS THAT WE'VE
TAKEN TO OVERSEE AND STABILIZE
THE HOME CARE. UH, SERVICES, UH,
PROGRAM. UM AS YOU KNOW, THE,
UH, THE 23 BUDGET ACT PROVIDED
US THE ABILITY THE ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES THAT WOULD HELP US TO
EXPAND OUR CAPABILITIES AND
EXPAND FROM A BUREAU TO BRANCH
LEVEL. UH, WE'VE WE'VE GOT WE
GOT 1515 POSITIONS IN THAT
BUDGET. NONE OF THOSE POSITIONS
SO FAR HAVE BEEN HIRED. UH, SIX
ARE STILL UNDER RECRUITMENT. UM,
THE ADDITION OF THOSE STAFF IS,
UH, IS PROVIDING US THE ABILITY
TO INVESTIGATE BUSINESSES. ARE
PROVIDING UNLICENSED CARE
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA AND TO
ISSUE CIVIL PENALTIES, WHICH
WILL HOPEFULLY HELP US GENERATE
ADDITIONAL REVENUE TO STABILIZE
THE PROGRAM. WE'RE CONTINUING TO
MEET WITH COMMUNITY PARTNERS AND
BUILD, UH, LINES OF
COMMUNICATION SO THAT YOU KNOW
WE'RE WE'RE, UH, WE'RE SEEING
AND ACCEPTING. UM UH UH UH,
OPPORTUNITIES FOR, UH, THE
IMPROVEMENTS THAT WOULD HELP TO
POPULATE THE REGULATION AND
INTERNAL POLICY PACKAGES THAT WE
HAVE UNDER FORMATION, AND WE'RE
FINALIZING APPROVAL FOR THE
FIRST. UH UH, QUARTERLY REPORT.
UM, TO THAT'S DUE TO YOU. UM AS
A MATTER OF FACT, I BELIEVE WE
SUBMITTED THAT ALREADY. SO UM,
UNLESS THERE ARE QUESTIONS UM
THOSE ARE THAT THOSE CONCLUDE MY
REMARKS. UM THANK YOU TO, UM I
WAS MOSTLY INTERESTED IN THE
GUARDIANSHIP. UM THE GUARDIAN.
THE GUARDIAN OF THE WAY YOU SAID
IT WRONG GUARDIAN CENTER
BECAUSE, YOU KNOW WE TALKED
ABOUT THIS A LOT LAST YEAR. WE
SPENT A LOT OF TIME ON THAT. AND
I'M I'M GLAD TO SEE THAT. WE'RE
TRENDING THE RIGHT WAY. UM DO WE
CONTINUE TO TREND THE RIGHT WAY
AND ON I DON'T KNOW IF I'M
LOOKING FOR AN AVERAGE, BUT I
KNOW THE NUMBERS ARE FROM
COMPARED TO JULY. 2022 DO WE
HAVE ANYTHING THAT WE'RE
COMPARING TO JUST LAST YEAR AND
HOW MUCH GREATER THAT IS AND IS
A 70% DECREASE. MORE FROM WHAT
WE BEFORE. WHAT BEF I'VE LOST
COMPLETELY. WHAT I SAID, IS THE
TREND THAT WE'RE SEEING NOW. DO
WE ATTRIBUTE IT MORE TO PRIOR TO
WHAT WE DID LAST YEAR. OR DO WE
JUMP UP TO 70% DECREASE BECAUSE
OF WHAT WE DID LAST YEAR. WE
THINK WE THINK THAT, UM, THE
ADDITION OF THE STAFF UM, WE HAD
, UH, 12 POSITIONS THAT, UH,
THAT WE WERE ABLE TO, UM, UH, TO
HIRE INTO, UH, TO PROCESS, UH,
EXEMPTIONS TO HANDLE PHONE CALLS
, HANDLE EMAILS AND HELP WITH
SELF SERVICE. UM WE ALSO I. I
THINK A GOOD PORTION OF THAT WAS
THE HUGE AMOUNT OF CALLS THAT
WE'RE ABLE TO APPLICATIONS THAT
WE'RE ABLE TO MOVE INTO THE
SIMPLIFIED EXEMPTION PROCESS
THROUGH A B 1720. UM THAT HELPED
US SINCE SINCE, UH UH THE
ENACTMENT OF 1720 WE'VE
COMPLETED OVER 20,000 SIMPLIFIED
EXEMPTIONS INTERNAL GOAL TO HIT
THAT WE'RE LIKE, OH, WE'RE
COMFORTABLE WITH HAVING MAYBE 10
, 20/100 AND 20 DAYS. THAT'S
SOMETHING WE CAN GET RID OF. I
THINK I BELIEVE WE CAN, UM, I
THINK, GIVEN OUR CURRENT
STAFFING, EVEN WITH THE 12
ADDITIONAL THAT WE WERE THAT WE
HIRED OVER THE LAST YEAR, UM,
THAT THAT MAY BE A MULTIYEAR
PROCESS. UM, BUT WE'RE AGAIN.
WE'RE WE'RE AS WE NAVIGATE THE
SOFTWARE MORE EFFECTIVELY AS WE,
UH AS THE OUR OUR STAKEHOLDERS
AND PUBLIC USERS OF THE SYSTEM
BECOME MORE SAVVY. UM WE? WE
BELIEVE THAT THAT, UH, THAT
BACKLOG WILL WILL REDUCE ON ITS
OWN. UH, THROUGH NATURAL MEANS
YOU YOU'RE THINKING A COUPLE OF
MILES. WE'RE WHILE WE'RE
CONTINUING PLANNING AND
PROCUREMENT ACTIVITIES ON THE
NEXT ON THE REPLACEMENT SYSTEM
THAT HOPEFULLY WILL BE EASIER TO
NAVIGATE FOR EVERYONE, OK?
NOTHING FURTHER ON THIS END.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THAT
CONCLUDES THE PRESENTATIONS FROM
THE DEPARTMENT. WE HAVE ONE
ISSUE FOR PROPOSAL OF
INVESTMENTS. THE COUNTY WELFARE
DEPARTMENT WILL BE PRESENTING
UNDER THREE MINUTES ON THEIR
EMERGENCY SERVICES DISASTER
RESPONSE FUNDING. GOOD AFTERNOON
. UH, SENATORS. THANK YOU. MY
NAME IS EILEEN KANKI I'M THE
INTERIM EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TO THIS
ISSUE TODAY, AND I'D ALSO LIKE
TO THANK SENATOR DODD FOR
CHAMPIONING THIS REQUEST ON OUR
BEHALF AND TO HIS STAFF FOR
THEIR SUPPORT ON THIS ISSUE. IS
REQUESTING 14 MILLION GENERAL
FUND ANNUALLY TO PROVIDE
DEDICATED FUNDING AND RESOURCES
TO BOLSTER COUNTY HUMAN SERVICES
DEPARTMENTS, EMERGENCY SERVICES
AND DISASTER PREPAREDNESS AND
RESPONSE. OVER THE PAST SEVEN
YEARS, THE STATE HAS EXPERIENCED
AN UNPRECEDENTED NUMBER OF
EMERGENCIES AND DISASTERS.
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES INTENSIVE
STORMS WITH SEVERE FLOODING AND
WINDS. COVID-19 CALIFORNIA WILL
BE RECOVERING FROM THESE COMPLEX
DISASTERS FOR AT LEAST THE NEXT
DECADE, WHILE CONTINUING TO ON
TO AND RECOVER FROM FUTURE
DISASTERS, COUNTIES AND COUNTY
HUMAN SERVICES AGENCIES IN
PARTICULAR AT THE FRONT LINES OF
THESE RESPONSE EFFORTS. THE
CALIFORNIA STATE EMERGENCY PLAN
PLACES THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF SOCIAL SERVICES AS THE LEAD
STATE ENTITY FOR MASS CARE AND
SHELTER DISASTER RESPONSE. THE
STATE STRUCTURE, HOWEVER, ADOPTS
A LOCAL FIRST EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT SYSTEM, PUTTING LOCAL
GOVERNMENT EMERGENCY PLANS AT
THE FOREFRONT OF EMERGENCY
RESPONSE. THEREFORE WHEN
DISASTERS OCCUR, COUNTY HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCIES HAVE
RESPONSIBILITY UNDER EMERGENCY
RESPONSE PLANS FOR THE MASS CARE
AND SHELTER OF THEIR COUNTY
RESIDENTS. COUNTY HUMAN SERVICES
AGENCY STAFF ARE DIVERTED FROM
THEIR REGULAR DUTIES TO
COORDINATE HUMAN AND MATERIAL
RESOURCES TO ESTABLISH MASS CARE
AND SHELTER SERVICES. UH THEY
CONDUCT NOTIFICATIONS AND
OUTREACH OF DISASTER SERVICES.
THEY ASSIST PROGRAM RECIPIENTS
WITH DISASTER ASSISTANCE
APPLICATIONS. THEY HANDLE
TRANSPORTATION OF PROGRAM
CLIENTS. THEY PROVIDE SERVICES
TO PERSONS IN NEED OF TARGETING
AND OR SPECIAL SERVICES.
ADDITIONALLY MOST COUNTY HUMAN
SERVICES DEPARTMENTS ARE TASKED
WITH THE LEAD DEPARTMENT. FOR
POST DISASTER RESPONSE, RECOVERY
AND SERVICES, WITH ONE THIRD OF
THEM REPORTING THAT THEY PROVIDE
THESE POST DISASTER RECOVERY
SERVICES FOR MORE THAN 12 MONTHS
AFTER AN EVENT AND THIS IS JUST
OUR FORMAL DISASTER WORK.
INCREASINGLY THE STATE IS ASKING
COUNTY HUMAN SERVICES AGENCIES
TO PROVIDE SHELTERING SERVICES
TO THE UNHOUSED POPULATION
DURING EXTREME WEATHER EVENTS
AND OTHER EMERGENCIES, AND ALL
OF THIS IS DONE ON TOP OF COUNTY
STAFFS. REGULAR DUTIES. AND
SINCE THERE IS NÓ DEDICATED
STAFF, IT'S COVERED ON AN AD HOC
BASIS WITHIN COUNTY STRUCTURES.
THE VAST MAJORITY OF THIS WORK
GOES UNREIMBURSED BY FEDERAL
DISASTER FUNDS. AND SO COUNTY
HUMAN SERVICES AGENCIES ARE LEFT
TO FUND THESE ACTIVITIES WITH
THEIR OWN DEPARTMENT FUNDS
OUTSIDE OF ALL THE STATE
ALLOCATIONS THAT WERE PROVIDED
SO WE'RE NOT REQUESTING FUNDING
TO COVER ALL THESE COSTS OF ALL
THE REDIRECTED STAFF AND THE AND
THE RESOURCES THAT WE USE FOR
MASS CARE AND SHELTERING. RATHER
WE'RE SEEKING RESOURCES FOR JUST
ONE DEDICATED STAFF PERSON PER
COUNTY HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY TO
PROVIDE THAT CONTINUITY OF STAFF
WHOSE PURPOSE IT IS TO HELP THEM
BETTER PLAN AND COORDINATE LOCAL
RESOURCES PRIOR TO DISASTER,
STRIKING SO THAT DURING BOTH THE
DISASTER AND THE RECOVERY WE
HAVE A MORE EFFICIENT AND
EFFECTIVE RESPONSE. IT'S A BAD
BUDGET YEAR AND I DON'T ENVY
YOUR DECISIONS. UNFORTUNATELY
DISASTERS DON'T CARE ABOUT THE
BUDGET, AND WE WILL ALWAYS
RESPOND AS WE NEED TO DURING
DISASTERS. SO I THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION OF THIS
REQUEST. IT IS VERY IMPORTANT TO
OUR MEMBERS, UM, TO PROVIDE
THESE CRITICAL SERVICES.
APPRECIATE IT. THANK YOU.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ANY
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS? GET OUR
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THIS THIS,
UH, PROPOSAL IS NOT PART OF THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. SO WE HAVE NÓ
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU. HELLO. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS
ANGELA SHORT WITH THE L A Ó NÓ
COMMENTS ON THIS PROPOSAL. NÓ
QUESTIONS FROM US. THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR PRESENTATION. I
JUST DON'T WANNA I WANNA KNOW
THERE ARE THREE ITEMS THAT ARE
ON YOUR AGENDA LIVED S¼ S¼. I S¼
S¼ P GRANTS AND REVIVE THE
SPECIAL CIRCUMSTANCES PROGRAM. I
S¼ S¼ PARTICIPATION CAP UPDATE
AND I S¼ COUNTY ADMINISTRATIVE
BRIDGE FUNDING. UM THAT ON THE
AGENDA BUT NOT ELIGIBLE FOR
PRESENTATION. I MEAN, AND I DO
WANNA DO KIND OF LIKE A PUBLIC
SERVICE ANNOUNCEMENT. WE HAVE TO
BE VERY MINDFUL OF NEW
INVESTMENTS YOU'RE SEEING UP
HERE. WE'RE JUST WE'RE TRYING TO
FIGHT JUST TO KEEP PREVIOUS
INVESTMENTS INTO THE BUDGET. SO
A, UH, WITH, UH, MOVING FORWARD.
WE ARE GONNA BE RE EVALUATING
HOW WE'RE GONNA BE LOOKING AT
PROPOSAL INVESTMENTS FOR ALL THE
STAKEHOLDER PROPOSALS TO STILL
AGAIN BE MINDFUL OF OUR BUDGET
SITUATION. OK, NOW WE'RE GONNA
DO PUBLIC. COMMENT ON ISSUES TWO
THROUGH EIGHT. IF EVERYONE'S
STANDING IS GOING TO DO A PUBLIC
COMMENT, WE'RE GOING TO LOWER
THE THRESHOLD TO 45 SECONDS. OK
IF YOU CAN DO IT, 30 TO 45 WOULD
BE REALLY GREAT. GREAT REBECCA
I'M REBECCA GONZALEZ WITH THE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY. BUT I'M HERE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIANS FOR
S¼ S¼ I COALITION WHICH IS A
COALITION OF OVER 200 GROUPS. UM
I'M GONNA GO STRAIGHT TO WHAT
WE'RE ASKING FOR. WE ASK THE
LEGISLATURE. UM AND WE KNOW IT'S
HARD BUDGET TIMES, BUT WE IT IS
NECESSARY TO LIFT GRANTS TO 100%
OF THE POVERTY LEVEL OVER THREE
YEARS. WE KNOW THE DEEP CUTS
THAT HAVE BEEN MADE TO THIS
PROGRAM IN THE PAST, AND NOW THE
GRANT IS ONLY AT 94% OF THE
FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL. UM CYBER
RECIPIENT STILL STRUGGLE TO MAKE
ENDS MEET THEY RELY ON FOOD
BANKS MEDICAL DOES NOT COVER ALL
THEIR EXPENSES. RENTS ARE RISING
, UM AND LOS ANGELES. THE FAIR
MARKET RAN FOR A STUDIO
APARTMENT IS ABOUT 1.5 TIMES.
THE S¼ S¼ I GRANT. UM SO, UH, WE
DO. WE DO URGE THE LEGISLATURE
TO LOOK AT THE REVENUE SIDE OF
THE BUDGET IN ORDER TO MAKE SOME
INVESTMENTS POSSIBLE. THANK YOU.
AND I APOLOGIZE. WE'RE GONNA CUT
IT AT 30 SECONDS. WE STILL HAVE
A LOT OF THINGS TO GO OVER
TODAY. SO WE'RE GONNA 30 SECONDS
AND IF YOU JUST WANNA DO ME TOOS
JUST DO ME TOOS. IF SOMEONE IN
FRONT OF YOU IS SAID THE SAME
THING. THANK YOU. GO AHEAD.
EILEEN KANKI, AGAIN WITH THE
COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION WANTED TO PUT A PLUG
IN FOR THE OTHER PROPOSAL FOR
INVESTMENT THAT WE HAVE FOR I HÌ
S¼ S¼ ADMINISTRATION. $51
MILLION IN ONE TIME FUNDS TO
BRIDGE TILL WE GET A NEW
METHODOLOGY. WE ALSO HAVE A
TRAILER BILL REQUEST FOR THAT.
AND I DID JUST WANNA, UM, ALSO
SAY THAT, UH, WITH RESPECT TO
THE HOUSING CONVERSATIONS. WE
ARE WORKING VERY CLOSELY WITH
THE DEPARTMENT AND OUR COUNTY
MEMBERS. I DID WANT TO JUST
REITERATE THAT WE ARE TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT HOW WE CAN MAKE THAT
PROPOSAL. UM, WORK AND AT WHAT
LEVEL SO I JUST WANTED TO WEIGH
IN ON THAT AS WELL. THANK YOU.
PERFECT TIMING. MY NAME IS JUDY
JACKSON AND I AM 78, YEAR OLD
RECIPIENT OF ALL THESE PROGRAMS,
AND I WANT YOU TO KNOW THAT THE
ALAMEDA COUNTY SOCIAL SERVICES
COALITION SAYS THAT S¼ S¼, I IS
STILL $34 BELOW THE POVERTY
LEVEL FOR THE AVERAGE RECIPIENT
AND THAT IT IS $375 BELOW THE
FAIR MARKET RATE FOR A STUDIO,
SO WE NEED THE INCREASES THAT
WERE PROMISED. AND WE THANK YOU
FOR THE ONES WE'VE GOTTEN. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. HØI TR FUN WITH,
UH, JUSTICE AND AGING IS
SUPPORTING LIFTING S¼ S¼ I
GRANTS AND REVIVING THE SPECIAL
CIRCUMSTANCES PROGRAM. THE
RECENT GRANT INCREASES ARE NOW
BRINGING THE GRANTS BACK FROM A
RECESSION LOWS IN ORDER TO HOLD
ON TO THE REAL VALUE OF THESE
INCREASES IN COOL INCREASE THIS
YEAR WOULD HELP S¼ S¼ I GRANTS
ARE USED FOR BASIC NEEDS. THE
COALITION SPOKE WITH S¼ S¼ I
RECIPIENTS IN LOS ANGELES LAST
WEEK AND ASKED WHAT THEY WOULD
USE A GRANT INCREASE FOR 250.
PEOPLE RESPONDED, 40% SAID, RENT
ABOUT A THIRD SAID FOOD, MEDICAL
EXPENSES 13% AND 15% OTHER.
THANK YOU. HØI CHAIR AND MEMBERS
GABBY DAVIDSON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF FOOD
BANKS HERE TO UPLIFT A BUDGET
REQUEST FROM THE CALIFORNIANS
FOR S¼ S¼ I COALITION FIRSTLY
JUST WANT TO THANK THE
LEGISLATOR FOR THE S¼ S¼ P GRANT
THAT TOOK PLACE IN JANUARY AND
THAT THERE'S NÓ CUTS PROPOSED TO
S¼ S¼ P GRANTS THIS YEAR AND TO
SUPPORT OUR MOST VULNERABLE. WE
ALSO WANT TO ENSURE THAT THERE
ARE NÓ CUTS TO OTHER SAFETY NET
PROGRAMS AND WHEN INVESTMENTS
ALLOWING WANT TO SUPPORT OUR
OLDER ADULTS AND PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES BY REVIVING THE
SPECIAL CIRCUMSTANCES PROGRAM.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ROTHSCHILD
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF PUBLIC
AUTHORITIES FOR I HÌ S¼ S¼ IN
SUPPORT OF THE PUBLIC, UH,
PUBLIC AUTHORITY, ADMIN FUNDING
AND THE BACKUP PROVIDER ADMIN
FUNDING AS IT COULD TAKE 6 TO 8
HOURS FOR PUBLIC AUTHORITY STAFF
TO STORE ON ONE BACKUP PROVIDER
CASE ALSO IN SUPPORT OF èC W Dð
A S¼ REQUEST FOR 50 51 MILLION
IN BRIDGE FUNDING. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU. HØI BRUNO LAUSA
I'M WITH, UM, HOME MATCH AND
NONPROFIT HOME SHARING PROGRAM.
UM, WE SUPPOSED TO SPECIFICALLY
ARE CONCERNED WITH AGING IN
PLACE AND HOMELESSNESS
PREVENTION. I JUST WANT TO SAY
THAT HOME SAFE IS A VITAL NEED.
UM AND THEN I ASK THE COMMITTEE
TO MAKE A COMMITMENT TO PROTECT
THE FUNDING OF HOUSING ADVOCACY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, MADAM CHAIR, SENATORS
AND THE COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS
GAVI. LOPEZ LOOMIS. I'M AN I HÌ
S¼ S¼ PROVIDER FOR MY SON IN
NEVADA COUNTY. UH, LESTAT,
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT FOR ISSUES. UH NUMBER
FIVE AND I HÌ S¼ S¼ CAREER
PATHWAYS FOR THE PROGRAM. UM AND
THE I HÌ S¼ S¼ STATE
PARTICIPATION CAP UNDER ISSUE
EIGHT. THANK YOU SO MUCH. KELLY
BROOKS ON BEHALF OF THE URBAN
COUNTIES OF CALIFORNIA, THE
BOARDS OF SUPERVISORS OF
RIVERSIDE AND VENTURA COUNTIES
IN SUPPORT OF èC W Dð A S¼. I
HÌ S¼ S¼ ADMIN PROPOSAL JUST
WANT TO KNOW WE HAVE URBAN
COUNTIES WITH SOCIAL WORKERS
CARRYING CASE LOADS OF THREE TO
500 Kò. I HÌ S¼ S¼ CASES, WHICH
MEANS OUR REASSESSMENTS ARE
GOING SLOW AND PEOPLE MAY NOT BE
GETTING THE FULL AMOUNT OF
SERVICES THAT THEY'RE ENTITLED
TO. SO I JUST WANNA PUT A PIN IN
THIS. WE TOTALLY UNDERSTAND THE
BUDGET SITUATION, BUT I THINK
THE PROPOSAL INCLUDES TRAILER
BELL LANGUAGE THAT WILL PUT US
ON A PATH TO GETTING TOWARD, UM,
BETTER CASE LOADS. THANKS. YOU.
HØI DANIELLE BRADLEY ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES. UH, èC
S¼ A JOINED èC W Dð A AS A
COSPONSOR OF THE BUDGET QUEST
FOR 51 MILLION IN ONE TIME FOR I
HÌ S¼ S¼ ADMINISTRATION, UM,
ALIGNING OUR COMMENTS WITH èC W
Dð A AND U èC èC, UH èC S¼ A
ALSO STRONGLY SUPPORTS THE HUMAN
SERVICES DISASTER PROPOSAL. UH,
HUMAN SERVICES AGENCIES PLAY A
CRITICAL ROLE BEFORE, DURING AND
AFTER, AND THIS FUNDING IS
CRUCIAL TO UPLIFTING THAT WORK
AND FINALLY SEES CONCERNS OF
FUNDING DELAYS PROPOSED FOR HOME
SAFE IN HD APP THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON, MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS, MARTHA GUERRERO,
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS.
ALSO IN SUPPORT OF THE I HÌ S¼.
UM UH, BRIDGE COUNTY
ADMINISTRATION FUNDING PROPOSAL
LINE IN OUR COMMENTS WITH URBAN
COUNTY CAUCUS, èC WJ AND èC S¼
A THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON. MY
NAME IS BRENDA GARNER. I'M A
HOME CARE PROVIDER AND I WANNA
COME AND TALK TODAY ABOUT THE
CAREER PATHWAY. IT IS THAT HOME
CARE PROVIDERS SUCH AS MYSELF
LEARN MORE AS POSSIBLE THAT WE
CAN LEARN SO WE CAN BE ABLE TO
HELP OUR OUR FELLOW RECIPIENTS
IN CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SO MUCH, BRENDA. GOOD
AFTERNOON. I'M UH, DAPHNE
DUNSTON. I AM AN ITS S¼ PROVIDER
. I JUST WANT TO, UH, TELL YOU
THAT I EXPERIENCED A HARD TIME
GOING TO THAT CAREER PATHWAYS
PROGRAM. WOULD YOU PLEASE MAKE
IT EASIER FOR US? BECAUSE FOR ME
, I'M TAKING CARE OF MY TWO
SPECIAL NEED BOYS, AND IT'S NOT
EASY FOR ME TO, YOU KNOW,
NAVIGATE FOR THE CAREER PROGRAM
AND I REQUEST FOR LIKE EXTENSION
OF THIS. WE HAVE, LIKE ALMOST
HALF MILLION. PROVIDERS THAT'S
LIKE ACCESSING THE CAREER
PATHWAYS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. UM, GOOD AFTERNOON TO
ALL MY NAME IS CONSTANCE HILL. I
AM ALSO AN I HÌ S¼ S¼ PROVIDER.
I AM ALSO IN SUPPORT OF THE
CAREER PATH PROGRAM. UM, IT'S
VERY IMPERATIVE THAT AN
EXTENSION WOULD BE KINDLY GIVEN
IT IS NECESSARY. UM, I'M TRYING
TO GET MY FEET COMPLETELY IN IT
AND EMERGE 100% SO I CAN BE A
BETTER, UM, PROVIDER CAREGIVER
AND TO TAKE CARE OF MY CLIENTS
AS WELL. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON. MY NAME IS BELINDA
WELLS, AND I'M A CARE PROVIDER
IN EL DORADO COUNTY, AND I
SUPPORT THE CAREER PATHWAYS. I
HAVEN'T HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO DO
IT YET. AND SO I AM PLANNING ON
DOING IT. SO IF YOU CAN HONOR
THAT EXTENSION, THAT WOULD BE
AWESOME. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON. MY NAME IS HANNA
Dð AND AN M I HÌ S¼ S¼ PROVIDER
FROM PLAZA COUNTY. I'M CARING
FOR MY BOTH PARENTS WHO ARE LIKE
, UH, MOSTLY DISABLED. SO UH,
THE CAREER PATHWAY PROGRAM IS
REALLY HELPED ME TO GET CARE OF
THEM, ESPECIALLY FOR MY DAD
BECAUSE HE HAD CANCER, AND, UH,
THEY REMOVED THE WHOLE BLADDER
FROM HIM. SO ONE OF THE CLASS
HELPED ME HOW TO GET A CARE OF
HIS STOMACH AND HELP HIM THROUGH
THAT. SO, UM, I REALLY RESPECT
TOTALLY REQUEST TO SUPPORT FOR
ISSUE NUMBER FIVE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR BEING A CAREGIVER.
THANK YOU. OK MY NAME IS TRACY
HAMMOND. AND I'M FROM COUNTY.
I'M A I HÌ S¼ S¼ WORKER AND I
BELIEVE THE CAREER PATH. UM, IS
VERY IMPORTANT TO HAVE TRAINING
FOR THE WORK THAT WE DO. THANK
YOU. MY NAME IS AUDREY WILLIAMS.
I AM A CARE PROVIDER. I HAVE
BEEN FOR EIGHT YEARS. I TAKE
CARE OF MY MOTHER WHO IS
DISABLED. UM THE CAREER PATHWAYS
IS VERY IMPORTANT TO PROVIDERS
LIKE ME. BECAUSE WITHOUT IT
THERE, WE WOULDN'T REALLY KNOW
WHERE TO GO OR WHAT TO DO WHEN
IT COMES TO OUR CLIENTS, AND
THAT'S THE MOST IMPORTANT THING
FOR US. THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. GOOD AFTERNOON. MY NAME IS
CARLOS TASSI. I'M A I S¼
PROVIDER FOR MY FIANCE. FROM
CALVER COUNTY. UM ANGELS CAMP
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
PARTICIPATING AND TO CAREER
PATHWAYS, AND I THINK IF WE
COMMUNICATE OUT TO MORE
PROVIDERS, WE COULD, UH, SPEND
MORE OF THAT MONEY. THANK YOU,
SIR. GOOD AFTERNOON COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. MY NAME IS COREY
CROSON. I'M AN I HÌ S¼ S¼
PROVIDER FOR MERCED COUNTY WHERE
I PROVIDE CARE FOR MY SPECIAL
NEEDS CLIENT IN MY COMMUNITY. I
HAVE BEEN AN IHSS PROVIDER FOR
16 YEARS AND I'VE SEEN A LOT OF
CHANGES SOME GOOD, SOME NOT SO
GOOD, BUT THE IHSS CARE CAREER
PATHWAYS PROGRAM IS GOOD AND
EXTENDING THE TRAINING IS VERY
BENEFICIAL TO I HÌ S¼ S¼
PROVIDERS, AND I'M ASKING FOR
YOUR SUPPORT ON EXTENDING THE
CAREER PATHWAY PROGRAM AND TO
ALSO LIFT THE STATE
PARTICIPATION CAP ON I HÌ S¼ S¼
WAGES SO PROVIDERS CAN NEGO
NEGOTIATE. UM, LIVABLE WAGES AND
BENEFITS. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON, MADAM CHAIR AND THE
COMMITTEE MEMBER. MY NAME IS P.
SO I, I S¼ PROVIDER FOR ME, SAID
COUNTY I TAKING CARE OF MY MOM
SINCE 2014. I AM HERE TO
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THE ISSUE FILE. I IS
HOME CARE PART WAY. UH, SOLID A
CARE HARDWARE PROGRAM AND ISSUE
A AND I BELIEVE IN LONG LIFE
LEARNING, AND I THINK EVERYONE
BE ALL COURIER. WE WANT TO BE
THE PROFESSIONAL. SO PLEASE,
CONSIDERING ABOUT THIS PROGRAM
AS YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH. GOOD
AFTERNOON. MY NAME IS GREG
BARNEY. I'M A RETIRED MILITARY
MEMBER AND I S¼ PROVIDER FROM
ME, SAID COUNTY UM I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THE ISSUE. FIVE. THE
I IS THE I HÌ S¼ S¼ CAREER
PATHWAYS PROGRAM AND THE I HÌ S¼
S¼ STATE PARTICIPATION CAP ON
THE ISSUE. EIGHT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE, SIR.
GOOD AFTERNOON, MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MALIK
BYNUM WITH W. ASK ME LOCAL 3930
GRATEFUL THE DISCUSSION TODAY
AND THE INCLUSION OF THE CAREER
PATHWAYS PROGRAM AND THE STATE
PARTICIPATION CAP PROPOSAL IN
THE AGENDA, WHICH IS ECHOED THE
REMARKS MADE BY MY COLLEAGUE
TIFFANY WHITTON. BUT JUST ADD
THAT 200 MILLION OF THE $295
MILLION ARE GENERAL FUND DOLLARS
AND NOT SUBJECT TO THE SAME 2024
DEADLINE. UM, AND WE JUST ALSO
JUST ECHO THE REMARKS OF ALL OF
OUR INCREDIBLE PROVIDERS UP HERE
. RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR, UM,
SUPPORT ON THESE PROPOSALS AS
THEY MOVE THROUGH THE BUDGET
PROCESS. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON. MY
NAME IS JILL FREELAND. I'M AN I
HÌ S¼ S¼ PROVIDER AMADOR COUNTY,
CALAVERAS COUNTY. ALSO ON THE
BARGAINING TEAM FOR S¼ EIU 2015.
AND A ACTIVE PARTICIPANT IN THE
CAREER PATHWAYS PROGRAM, AND
EACH OF THE PATHWAYS REQUIRES
THAT AMOUNT OF TIME TO COMPLETE
TO GET THE INCENTIVE AT THE END,
SO THE EXTENSION OF THAT WOULD
ALLOW US TO RECEIVE THOSE WHICH
IS A B A BONUS FOR US, SINCE WE
DON'T MAKE A WHOLE LOT OF MONEY
AS A PROVIDER, AND I'M IN THE
MIDDLE OF A PATHWAY I HAVEN'T
COMPLETED YET SO AND AT THE END,
THEY PROBABLY STILL BE PLENTY OF
FUNDS LEFT FOR EVERYBODY. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. GOOD AFTERNOON. MY
NAME IS JOSEPH MONTEZ. I'M AN A
I HÌ S¼ S¼, UH, CAREGIVER, AND
I'M ALSO ASKING YOU FOR THE
SUPPORT OF THE CAT WAY. UH,
CAREER PATHWAY PROGRAM ALSO, UM
I. I FOUND IT TO BE VERY
BENEFICIAL TO THE, UH, DAILY
EVERYDAY DAILY CARE TO ER
SITUATIONS, WHICH HAS HELPED ME
VERY MUCH IN MY KNOWLEDGE OF
TAKING CARE OF MY RECIPIENTS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, SIR. NÓ
EVERYONE. UH, MY NAME IS FIN. I
COME FROM SACRAMENTO COUNTY M. I
HÌ S¼ S¼ PROVIDER. AND UH, I'M
TAKING CARE OF MY PARENTS WHO
HAD A DIMENSION AND THE DIABETES
. UM SINCE I TOOK THE MANY
COURSES FROM THE, UH CARE, UH
CARE, PER, UH, CARE PATHWAY
PROGRAM, UM I KNOW I'M NOT A LOT
OF KNOWLEDGE AND HOW TO TAKE
CARE OF MY PARENTS BETTER AND
NOW THEY FEEL A LOT BETTER. SO I
WANT TO SAY PLEASE KEEP GOING
TO, YOU KNOW, TO SUPPORT THE
PROGRAM. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON, MADAM
CHAIR AND ALL MY NAME IS STACEY
TRINIDAD. A FAR I'M A SOCIAL
WORKER TRAINEE FOR LOS ANGELES
COUNTY MEMBER OF THE S¼ èC IU
LOCAL 721. LAST YEAR. MIKE
KESLER WAS THREE 120 CASES THIS
YEAR. MY CASE LOAD IS 550. PLUS
THAT'S WHY I'M HERE. LIKE MY
OTHER COLLEAGUES IN SUPPORT OF
THE BRIDGE FUNDING ONE TIME ASK
OF $51 MILLION FOR I HÌ S¼ S¼.
IN THE MEANTIME, THE METHODOLOGY
GETS UPDATED AND THE I HÌ S¼ S¼
PROGRAM IS APPROPRIATELY FUNDED.
THIS WEEK. WE ALSO MET WITH
OTHER LEGISLATORS AND HAVE
KINDLY REQUESTED TO KEEP I HÌ S¼
S¼ IN MIND WHEN MEDICAL UPDATES
ARE MADE SUCH EXPANSION OF
MEDICAL FOR IT DIRECTLY IMPACTS
I HÌ S¼ S¼. THE I HÌ S¼ S¼
PROGRAM SERVES AS A CUSHION FOR
THE STATE TO AVOID HIGH COST
LONG TERM CARE AND COST OF
HOSPITALIZATIONS. THANK YOU FOR
I HAVE A LEAVE BEHIND IF YOU CAN
KINDLY ACCEPT IT. YOU COULD GIVE
IT HANDED TO THE SERGEANTS OVER
THERE. HAPPY SOCIAL WORK MONTH.
I DON'T EVEN KNOW IF IT'S HAPPY
BECAUSE YOU HAVE THREE 100
CASES. OVER 500 CASES. OH, MY
GOSH. DEFINITELY NOT HAPPY
SOCIAL WORKER MONTH. HELLO I'M
SUSANNA VIAN AND I'M ALSO A
SOCIAL WORKER FOR IN HOME
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES WITH LOS
ANGELES COUNTY AND I'M MOST IN
SUPPORT OF THE PROPOSAL BY èC W
Dð A AND I AGREE WITH MY
COLLEAGUES STATEMENT EARLIER.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. ROUGH I MEAN, UH TO M S¼ W
S¼ WERE LICENSE OVER THERE. IT'S
GO AHEAD. SORRY GOOD MORNING. MY
NAME IS MARIA VASQUEZ FROM UH,
IN HOME SUPPORT SERVICES SOCIAL
WORKER FOR LOS ANGELES COUNTY, A
MEMBER OF S¼ EIU LOCAL 721. AND
I'M HERE. ALSO AGREEING WITH MY
COLLEAGUES, UM, REGARDING THE
èC W Dð A PROPOSAL. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING COMMITTEE MEMBERS. MY
NAME IS FEL WHITE. I AM A SOCIAL
WORKER WITH IN HOME SUPPORT
SERVICES. LOS ANGELES COUNTY. UH
YES, HAPPY SOCIAL WORKERS MONTH
AND I DO ALIGN MY SUPPORT WITH
MY FELLOW COLLEAGUES AND I YIELD
TO THE FLOOR. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, SOCIAL WORKERS FOR COMING
UP HERE. I KNOW Y'ALL DO
EVERYTHING UNDER THE SUN. GOOD
AFTERNOON, MADAM CHAIR, SENATORS
. MY NAME IS STEVEN. I AM A èC
IU EXECUTIVE BOARD MEMBER AND
ALSO I HÌ S¼ S¼ SOCIAL SERVICES
SUPERVISOR. AND WE ARE. WE WERE
HERE YESTERDAY, UH, TO TALK TO
YOUR STAFF, AND WE THANK YOU AND
YOUR STAFF FOR HELPING US, UH,
IN THIS 35 YEARS, IN MY
EXPERIENCE, I NEVER SEEN SUCH A
WONDERFUL COLLABORATION BETWEEN
THE A èC IU AND THE
ADMINISTRATION WORKING TOGETHER.
HERE WE ARE TODAY AND FOR ONE
COAST ON THE TO HELP THE ELDERLY
AND DISABLED. THANK YOU, SIR.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON. MY NAME IS RAY RAMA.
I'M A REGIONAL DIRECTOR FROM Dð
P S¼ S¼ LOS ANGELES COUNTY. I'M
HERE TO EXPRESS MY SUPPORT FOR
èC W Dð A BRIDGE FUNDING. THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON. MY NAME IS
MONICA. JIM I AM A REGIONAL
MANAGER FOR L A COUNTY Dð P S¼
S¼ IN SUPPORT OF THE èC W Dð A
AND THE AT THE METHODOLOGY.
THANK YOU DO TAKE A BUS FROM L,
A COUNTY. AND THE CARS IN THE
HOUSE. WE ACTUALLY DID. MY NAME
IS I'M KIDDING. MY NAME IS CARLA
SHAW. I'M A I'M, A REGIONAL
DIRECTOR WITH LOS, AN LOS
ANGELES COUNTIES AND HOME
SUPPORT SERVICES PROGRAM. AND
I'M HERE IN SUPPORT OF THE èC W
Dð A S¼ PROPOSAL FOR THE 51
MILLION AND AN UPDATE IN THE
METHODOLOGY. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. GOOD AFTERNOON. MY
NAME IS JENNIFER KAISER. AND I
AM AN INSTRUCTOR THROUGH, UM
HOMEBRIDGE FOR CAREER PATHWAYS.
I CAN'T GIVE YOU BUDGET NUMBERS.
BUT WHAT I CAN TELL YOU IS THAT
I TEACH 66 0 CLASSES A MONTH AND
EVERY SINGLE ONE OF MY CLASSES
IS FILLED. THESE ARE SKILL BASED
CLASSES FOR THESE FOLKS AND THE
WAITLISTS ARE ALSO FULL FOR
THOSE AND EVERY TIME I TEACH A
CLASS, I HAVE SOMEBODY TELLING
ME HOW IMPORTANT THIS IS FOR
THEM. THERE ARE MANY, MANY
PARENTS WHO ARE TAKING CARE OF
DISABLED CHILDREN OR DISABLED
PARENTS WHO HAVE DEMENTIA AND
THEY NEED THESE TO KEEP THEM OUT
OF THE HOSPITALS AND OUT OF THE
FACILITIES. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
HELLO, EVERYONE. MY NAME IS
GINETTA COOK HUDDLESTON. I'M
ALSO AN INSTRUCTOR AT HOMEBRIDGE
AND I TAKE. I'M PROUD TO TEACH
THE MENTAL HEALTH COURSES. I
DON'T HAVE TO EXPLAIN TO YOU
GUYS THE IMPORTANCE OF, UM,
EDUCATING PEOPLE ON MENTAL
HEALTH. UM MY CAREGIVERS ARE
GETTING A LOT OUT OF THIS.
THEY'RE EMPOWERED. JUST THE
OTHER DAY. I HAD A STUDENT TELL
ME THAT I WAS ABLE TO RECOGNIZE
MAJOR DEPRESSION IN MY CONSUMER
BECAUSE OF YOUR COURSE SO I CAN
GET MY CONSUMER HELP. I'M ASKING
YOU TO EXTEND THE PROGRAM. AND
BE A PART OF CONTINUING THIS
NARRATIVE. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
SHARING. HELLO UH, MY NAME IS
PRISCILLA CORREAS. AND I WORK
FOR HOMEBRIDGE, WHICH IS
IMPLEMENTING THE I HÌ S¼ S¼
CAREER PATHWAYS PROGRAM. I'M
HERE TO EXPRESS MY DEEP SUPPORT
FOR THE EXTENSION TO THE PROGRAM
. UM I WORK DAILY WITH THE
PROVIDERS GETTING THEM INTO THE
COURSES AND EVERYTHING IN THE
MAIN. THE MAIN MESSAGE TO THEM
IS THAT THEY NEED MORE AND WANT
MORE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON. UH, MADAM CHAIR AND
SENATORS. MY NAME IS ERIN SABER.
I'M REPRESENTING HOMEBRIDGE, UH,
ONE OF THE PROVIDERS OF THE
CAREER PATHWAYS PROGRAM. WE'VE
BEEN HONORED, UM, TO DO A HUGE
RAMP UP FOR THIS TRAINING. WE
WANNA THANK THE SENATE, THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR THE VISION IN
SUPPORTING THE CAREGIVING
WORKFORCE AT THIS JUNCTURE WHEN
WE HAVE A GROWING NUMBER OF
OLDER ADULTS AND PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES WHO NEED QUALITY
CARE, WE SEE IT AS A LIFELINE OF
HELPING PEOPLE TO STAY AND
REMAIN HOUSED AND AT HOME WITH
THE KIND OF CARE THEY NEED. SO
THANK YOU FOR SUPPORT FROM Kò
FOR COMING. GOOD AFTERNOON. UH
MY NAME IS CHERYL WARD. I'M THE
DIVISION CHIEF FOR I HÌ S¼ S¼.
UH L A COUNTY AND I'M HERE TO
SUPPORT THE èC W Dð A BRIDGE
FUND AND JUST SO YOU KNOW, WE
HAVE A TOTAL OF BETWEEN 5, 56
100 AND 50 CASES AND WE'RE ONE
OF THE VERY LARGE COUNTIES SO
YOU CAN IMAGINE, AND WE WANNA
PROVIDE QUALITY CARE AND WE ALSO
NEED TO CHANGE THE MYOLOGY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS AND
STAFF. MY NAME IS LISA COLEMAN.
I'M WITH THE CALIFORNIA
COMMISSION ON AGING. LAST YEAR,
THE COMMISSION HAD A FORUM ON
HOUSING TARGET. DOCTOR KRICHEL
WAS ONE OF OUR KEYNOTE SPEAKERS.
SO I WANNA BRING TO YOUR
ATTENTION. THE HOME SAFE PROGRAM
THE STATE HAS PUT THE INVESTMENT
IN. IT HAS BEEN ESTABLISHED IN
THE COMMUNITY AND IT IS DOING
GOOD. IT WOULD BE SHORT SIGHTED
TO TAKE THAT AWAY. ALSO WITH THE
èC èC E PROGRAM. WE ARE SEEING
POSITIVE RESULTS IN THAT AREA.
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT PEOPLE BEING
INSTITUTIONALIZED SOME OF THAT
INSTITUTIONAL AND IS GOING INTO
èC èC RESIDENTIAL CARE
FACILITIES FOR THE ELDERLY, AND
THAT IS A SIGNIFICANTLY LESS
EXPENSIVE PROGRAM THAN GOING
INTO SKILLED NURSING. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS. MY NAME IS A KARAJAN
AND I AM A REGIONAL DIRECTOR
FROM L A COUNTY. I'M HERE TO
KINDLY. UH UH, REQUIRE NOT ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT FOR THE 51
MILLION AND ALSO FOR THE NEW
METHODOLOGY TO BE CREATED, BUT
THAT WHICH IS THE RECOMMEND
RECOMMENDATION. SOME CDS THE NEW
METHODOLOGIES NEEDED BECAUSE
CURRENT METHODOLOGY IS NOT
DECODING ALL THE WORKLOAD THAT
OUR WORKERS ARE DOING. FOR
EXAMPLE, 7000 APPLICATIONS THAT
WERE RECEIVED BY COUNT. IN THE
MONTH OF JANUARY, WHICH WAS 27%
INCREASE FROM THE 2020 JANUARY
IS NOT INCLUDED IN THE CURRENT
METHODOLOGY. THANK YOU. HELLO,
MADAM CHAIR AND TO THE COMMITTEE
. MY NAME IS MONICA KIRKLAND. I
AM THE, UH, STATE POLICY
DIRECTOR FOR ALAMEDA COUNTY. UM,
AND SENIOR SERVICES. UH,
COALITION OF ALAMEDA COUNTY. AND
I AM HERE TO JUST, UH WE'VE
EXPERIENCED A LOT OF INDIVIDUALS
THAT ARE PART OF OUR
ORGANIZATION, WHICH REPRESENTS
OVER 40 NONPROFIT AND COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS THAT HAVE
BEEN IMPACTED BY HOME SAFE, AND
THAT INCLUDES LEGAL SER SERVICES
. HOUSING OF SUCH AND BECAUSE OF
THAT WE ARE ASKING FOR A
COMMITMENT TO CONTINUE FUNDING
IN THAT ARENA. UH AND ALSO WE
ARE OPPOSED TO THE DELAYED
FUNDING FOR, UH, THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, MADAM. CHAIR MEMBERS
ANDREW SHANE AND CHILD POVERTY
CALIFORNIA WE ALIGN WITH S¼ èC
IU AND èC WG AND HÌ HÌ S¼ S¼
AND WITH THE CALIFORNIANS FOR S¼
S¼ I ON ON THEIR REQUEST, I
WOULD JUST REMIND THAT IT'S
OFTEN OVERLOOKED. THERE'S NEARLY
100,000 CHILDREN ON S¼ S¼ I AND
SO WE CAN ACHIEVE OUR MISSION
AND CHILD POVERTY WITHOUT
INCREASING THIS S¼ S¼ P GRANT.
THANK YOU. HELLO. MY NAME IS
MONIQUE HOOKS. I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR AT DAYBREAK. ADULT CARE
. WE ARE A HOME SAFE PROVIDER IN
ALAMEDA COUNTY. AND I WOULD JUST
LIKE TO ECHO THAT HOME. SAFE
FUNDING IS VITAL FOR OUR UH UH,
THE ELDERS IN OUR COMMUNITY WHO
ARE THE MOST VULNERABLE AS WELL
AS THE SUPPORT OF SERVICES THAT
GO ALONG WITH IT. THANK YOU. SO
MUCH FOR YOUR COMMENTS. HØI. MY
NAME IS ROBERT COPELAND. I
BELONG TO THE S¼ S¼ I COALITION
UH, THERE'S A LOT OF PEOPLE ON
S¼ S¼ I THAT ARE AT RISK OF
BECOMING HOMELESS OR LIVING
SUSTAIN HOUSING, SO INCREASE THE
COLOR AMOUNT AND ALSO PROPERLY
FUND THE HOME SAFE. AND, UH HÌ
STAFF PROGRAMS THAT WOULD HELP A
LOT OF PEOPLE THAT ARE HOMELESS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
YOU KNOW OTHER PUBLIC COMMENT.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO THE
NEXT DEPARTMENT, DEPARTMENT OF
COMMUNITY SERVICES AND
DEVELOPMENT. STARTING ON WITH
THE ISSUE ONE AND THE ONLY ISSUE
AND UNDER THIS DEPARTMENT.
FEDERAL TRUST FUND AUTHORITY
AUGMENTATION.
SEE THAT YOU MAY BEGIN. GOOD
MORNING. IT IS. NÓ NÓ. IT'S ON
NOW. OK THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING.
UM I MEAN, GOOD AFTERNOON, MADAM
. CHAIR MEMBERS. UM, I'M JASON
WEMBLEY. UH THE ACTING DIRECTOR
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF COMMUNITY
SERVICE AND DEVELOPMENT AND
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TODAY TO PRESENT UH èC S¼ Tð
S¼, UH, BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSAL.
THE MISSION OF èC S¼ Dð IS TO
REDUCE POVERTY IN CALIFORNIA
THROUGH THE ADMINISTRATION OF
PROGRAMS DESIGNED TO STRENGTHEN
THE ECONOMIC SECURITY OF
VULNERABLE TO LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS. WE WORK WITH
COMMUNITY PARTNERS ACROSS THE
STATE TO HELP LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS MEET THEIR BASIC
AND BASIC NEEDS ACHIEVE ECONOMIC
INDEPENDENCE MANAGER HOME ENERGY
COSTS AND REDUCE THEIR ENERGY
USE TO ENERGY EFFICIENCY
UPGRADES AND ACCESS TO CLEAN
RENEWABLE ENERGY. OUR PRIMARY
PROGRAMS ARE FEDERALLY FUNDED
BLOCK GRANTS, SUCH AS A
COMMUNITY SERVICES BLOCK GRANT
AND THE LOW INCOME HOME ENERGY
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM. WE
ADMINISTER FEDERAL AND STATE
FUNDED WEATHERIZATION AND ENERGY
EFFICIENCY PROGRAMS FOR LOW
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS, INCLUDING
FARM WORKERS AND MULTI FAMILY.
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. WE HAVE ONE
BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSAL THIS YEAR
, IT PROPOSES INCREASING THE
DEPARTMENT'S FEDERAL TRUST FUND
BASELINE AUTHORITY FOR LOCAL
ASSISTANCE TO BETTER ALIGN WITH
THE CURRENT FUNDING LEVELS FOR
OUR CORE FEDERAL GRANTS. IF
APPROVED THIS B èC P WILL
ELIMINATE THE NEED FOR èC S¼ Dð
TO ENGAGE THE SECTION 28 PROCESS
TO SECURE ADDITIONAL AUTHORITY
AND ENSURE A TIMELY TIMELIER
RELEASE OF FEDERAL GRANT FUNDS
BY THE DEPARTMENT TO ITS NETWORK
OF COMMUNITY PARTNERS OR SUB
GRANTEES. THERE IS NÓ FUNDING
ASSOCIATED WITH THIS B èC P. SO
I THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME TODAY
AND HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE HELLO.
ANY COMMENT? YES ANGELA, SHORT
WITH THE L A Ó. UH, WE'VE
REVIEWED THE DEPARTMENT'S B èC
P, AND WE FIND IT REASONABLE FOR
A FEW KEY REASONS. UM FIRST AS
YOU HEARD FROM THE DEPARTMENT,
IT SEEKS TO ALIGN èC S¼ Dð S¼
CURRENT. UH EXCUSE ME FEDERAL
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY, WITH ITS
ACTUAL ANTICIPATED AWARD AMOUNTS
. UM, SECOND, THE DEPARTMENT IS
PROPOSING THAT THIS WOULD BE
LIMITED TERM AND THEY WOULD
REVIEW THE INCREASED AUTHORITY
IN THREE YEARS AND ADJUST AS
NEEDED. AND THEN FINALLY
REGARDING THE SECTION 28. LETTER
PROCESS. UH, THIS PROCESS IS
INTENDED TO ENSURE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE IS INFORMED WHEN A
DEPARTMENT MAY RECEIVE
UNANTICIPATED FEDERAL DOLLARS
ABOVE THE BASELINE AWARDS. BUT
IN THIS CASE, THE DEPARTMENT IS
ANTICIPATING THAT ITS AWARDS
WILL CONTINUE TO EXCEED CURRENT,
UH, BASELINE AUTHORITY. SO FOR
THESE REASONS, WE FIND THE
PROPOSAL TO MAKE SENSE. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. WOULD YOU LIKE TO
ADD ANY OTHER COMMENTS
DEPARTMENT OMAR SANCHEZ
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NOTHING
FURTHER TO ADD NOTHING FURTHER
ON ON OUR END, WE'RE GONNA HOLD
THE ITEM OPEN. THANK YOU SO MUCH
. èC S¼ Dð FOR COMING UP. WE'RE
MOVING ON TO OUR LAST, UH,
DEPARTMENT OF THE DAY, UH,
DEPARTMENT OF AGING.
START OFF WITH ISSUE NUMBER ONE
AN OVERVIEW OF, UH, DEPARTMENT
OF AGING. GOOD AFTERNOON, MADAM
CHAIR. SENATOR ROTH, SENATOR
AKMAN. I'M SUSAN DE MORRIS,
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF AGING. I'LL BE
ADDRESSING THE FIRST THREE
QUESTIONS ON THE AGENDA AND OUR
CHIEF DEPUTY, MARK BECK, BECKLEY
AND DEPUTY NICOLE SHIMAO WILL
FOLLOW WITH THE BALANCE OF THE
ITEMS. SO THE FIRST QUESTION UH,
THE PROPOSED èC Dð A BUDGET
REFLECTS A LEVELING OF OUR WORK
FOLLOWING THE DEPARTMENT'S
UNPRECEDENTED GROWTH OVER THE
PAST FEW YEARS AS WE RESPONDED
TO THE COVID-19 PANDEMIC AND
FORMALIZED OUR LEAD ROLE IN
STANDING UP THE GOVERNOR'S
MASTER PLAN FOR AGING. OUR HARD
WORKING èC Dð STAFF IS
DILIGENTLY STEWARDING 46 NEW AND
ONE TIME INITIATIVES MADE
POSSIBLE BY FEDERAL ARPA AND HCB
S¼. DOLLARS AS WELL AS GENERAL
FUND SUPPORT. SIMULTANEOUSLY WE
ARE POSITIONING THE DEPARTMENT
TO MEET THE NEEDS OF ONE IN FOUR
CALIFORNIANS WHO WILL BE AGED 60
OR OLDER. BY 2030. IN CLOSE
PARTNERSHIP WITH LOCAL AGENCIES
OFFERS A WIDE RANGE OF CORE
PROGRAMS TO OLDER ADULTS. PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES AND FAMILY
CAREGIVERS. OUR DEPARTMENT
SUPPORTS THE POPULATION IN FOUR
WAYS WE CONNECT, SUPPORT,
PROTECT AND CONVENE. WE CONNECT
PEOPLE TO INFORMATION ASSISTANCE
AND REFERRALS, DIRECTING
INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES TO THE
COVERAGE, BENEFITS AND SERVICES
THEY NEED TO AGE IN PLACE AT
HOME IN THEIR COMMUNITY. WE
SUPPORT INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES
WITH NUTRITIOUS MEALS,
CAREGIVER, EDUCATION AND
RESPITE. LEGAL SERVICES AND TWO
MEDICAID WAIVER PROGRAMS, ADULT
DAY HEALTH CARE AND
MULTI-PURPOSE SENIOR SERVICES.
WE PROTECT INDIVIDUALS WITH OUR
NEWLY ESTABLISHED OFFICE OF THE
PATIENT REPRESENTATIVE AND THE
LONG TERM CARE OMBUDSMAN PROGRAM
LED BY BLANCA CASTRO. WE CONVENE
STAKEHOLDERS TO ENSURE EQUITY IS
AT THE CENTER OF OUR WORK,
ADDRESSING DISPARITIES BASED ON
AGE DISABILITY, RACE, ETHNICITY,
LANGUAGE, IMMIGRATION STATUS,
GENDER IDENTIFICATION, SEXUAL
ORIENTATION INCOME, VETERANS
STATUS, RURAL GEOGRAPHY AND
OTHER DEMOGRAPHIC
CHARACTERISTICS. MOVE NOW TO
QUESTION NUMBER TWO. PLEASE
PROVIDE AN OVERVIEW OF THE
LATEST MASTER PLAN FOR AGING
REPORT. WE WERE PROUD TO PRESENT
THE THIRD ANNUAL MASTER PLAN FOR
AGING REPORT TO THE LEGISLATURE
ON JANUARY 25TH. THIS DOCUMENT
SUMMARIZES CALIFORNIA'S WHOLE OF
GOVERNMENT WHOLE OF SOCIETY
APPROACH WITH CONTINUED
ENGAGEMENT WITH THE GOVERNOR,
SENIOR ADVISER, CABINET
SECRETARIES, STATE DEPARTMENTS
STAKEHOLDERS, COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS AND PHILANTHROPY.
A FEW ITEMS OF NOTE. WE'VE
DEEPENED OUR TIES TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENT WITH 21, LOCAL AGING
AND DISABILITY ACTION PLANNING
GRANTS. AND WE'VE BROADENED OUR
SCOPE TO INCLUDE A NUMBER OF
STRATEGIC FEDERAL PARTNERSHIPS
RELATING TO HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS, ALZHEIMER'S AND
DEMENTIA AND STREAMLINING
SERVICES UNDER A NÓ WRONG DOOR
LEADERSHIP COUNCIL. WE'VE
SHARPENED OUR FOCUS ON EQUITY
DEVELOPING OUR FIRST MP, A
EQUITY FRAMEWORK AND EQUITY
INDEX BOTH FOUNDATIONAL TO OUR
WORK TO PRODUCE BENCHMARKS AND
KEY OUTCOME MEASURES. AND WE ARE
PROUD TO HAVE WELCOMED THE
DEPARTMENT'S FIRST TRIBAL
AFFAIRS MANAGER AND LAUNCHED
CALIFORNIA'S FIRST EVER L GB Tð
QI, A PLUS OLDER ADULT SURVEY
WITH SUPPORT FROM THE L GB Tð Q
CAUCUS, AND WE'RE PLEASED TO
REPORT THAT WE'VE HAD OVER 3500
RESPONDENTS TO DATE AND OUR GOAL
WAS 2000. WE REMAIN COMMITTED TO
TRANSPARENCY WITH OUR REAL TIME
MASTER PLAN FOR AGING INITIATIVE
TRACKER AND DATA DASHBOARD ON
AGING. IN THE PAST YEAR, WE
WELCOMED THE OVERSIGHT OF THE
LITTLE HOOVER COMMISSION AT TWO
PUBLIC HEARINGS, AND WE CONTINUE
TO ALIGN THE ADMINISTRATION WITH
THE MP IMPACT COMMITTEE, A STATE
COLDER GROUP THAT MONITORS OUR
PROGRESS AND RESULTS. AND
FINALLY ON THE POLICY FRONT WERE
ACCELERATING OUR MP A WORK
RELATED TO LONG TERM SERVICES
AND SUPPORTS LTS S¼ SYSTEM
CHANGE WITH INITIATIVES UNDERWAY
RELATED TO NAVIGATION, ACCESS,
WORKFORCE AND AFFORDABILITY. WE
ARE PARTNERING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES ON THE STATE'S FIRST
HOME AND COMMUNITY BASED
SERVICES, GAP ANALYSIS AND
ROADMAP. AND OUR COW GROWS.
INITIATIVE OFFERS FREE CAREGIVER
TRAINING IN NINE LANGUAGES WITH
OVER $2 MILLION AWARDED TO
DIRECT CARE WORKERS AND
INCENTIVES TO DATE. JUST THIS
WEEK, WE SIGNED A CONTRACT TO
EMBARK ON THE VERY IMPORTANT
WORK, UM, AUTHORIZED BY THE
LEGISLATURE TO COLLECT DATA AND
EXPLORE FINANCING SOLUTIONS TO
MEET THE GROWING NEEDS OF THE
MISSING, MIDDLE OR FORGOTTEN
MIDDLE POPULATION. MOVE TO
QUESTION NUMBER THREE DIRECTOR.
UM EVEN THOUGH I JOKED EARLIER
ABOUT BEING HERE TILL 10, I
ACTUALLY DO ALSO HAVE TIME
RESTRAINTS FOR A FLIGHT. SO
WE'RE GONNA SKIP NUMBER THREE.
OK AND MOVE ON TO NUMBER FOUR,
OK? IN THAT CASE, I'M PLEASED
TO, UM, TURN THE MICROPHONE OVER
TO MARK BECKLEY, OUR CHIEF
DEPUTY DIRECTOR. GOOD AFTERNOON,
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS. MY NAME IS
MARK BECKLEY. I'M THE CHIEF
DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR THE
DEPARTMENT. UM SO AN UPDATE ON
THE BRIDGE TO RECOVERY, UM,
PROGRAM SO THE BRIDGE TO
RECOVERY PROGRAM. ITS GOAL IS TO
PROVIDE AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
CENTERS TO RESUME. UM IN CENTER,
UH, CON SERVICES POST PAMIC TO
HELP MEET THE NEEDS OF THE MOST
VULNERABLE CALIFORNIANS AND
THEIR FAMILIES THROUGH OUR
COMMUNITY. ADULT SERVICES, ADULT
DAY AND PROGRAMS FOR THE CARE
FOR THE ELDERLY OR PACE PROGRAMS
. UM, SOME OF THE ITEMS THAT ARE
ELIGIBLE TO FUND UNDER THIS
INITIATIVE INCLUDES STIPENDS AND
TRAININGS FOR STAFF. AND UM,
INFECTION CONTROL. UH
INFRASTRUCTURE CHANGES AND
EQUIPMENT. TO DATE. THREE 157
GRANT APPLICATIONS HAVE BEEN
AWARDED WITH 317 APPLICANTS
ACCEPTING THEIR GRANT AWARDS.
WE'RE CURRENTLY WORKING ON THE
CONTRACTING PROCESS WITH THESE
AWARDEES. UH, TODAY WE HAVE
FINALIZED AND SENT OUT GRANT
CONTRACTS FOR 74 OF THESE
CENTERS. THERE IS 84 CONTRACTS
THAT ARE CURRENTLY IN THE
PROCESS OF BEING EXECUTED, AND
WE HAVE AN ADDITIONAL 159
CONTRACTS THAT ARE CURRENTLY
UNDER REVIEW. IT'S OUR GOAL TO
HAVE THESE CONTRACTS COMPLETED
BY THE END OF THIS MONTH. THAT'S
MY UPDATE. THANK YOU SO MUCH
PARTNER FINANCE ANY ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS? THORE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. NOTHING TO ADD. HELLO.
OK, THERE WE GO, JUAN J
ALLEGEDLY AND HIS OFFICE. WE
HAVE NOTHING AT AT THIS TIME.
JUST EXCITED ABOUT THIS SURVEY
THAT'S GOING OUT. THAT'S ALL.
OK, THANK YOU SO MUCH. WE'RE
GONNA MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER
TWO. FOR ISSUE NUMBER TWO AND
ISSUE NUMBER THREE. WE CAN DO A
SHORT PRESENTATION ON BOTH OF
THESE NÓ PROBLEM. UH GOOD
AFTERNOON, MADAM. CHAIR MEMBERS.
THANK YOU, UM NICOLE SHIMO, AA
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
ADMINISTRATIVE SERVICES. SO UM,
FOR HEALTHIER AT HOME REVERSION.
THIS WAS A $12.5 MILLION PILOT.
10.6 MILLION WAS GOING TO GO TO
THE LOCALS ARE A BALANCE WAS
GONNA BE FOR OUR ADMINISTRATION.
AT THIS TIME. WE'VE ONLY SPENT
610,000 ON ADMINISTRATION. THE
INTENT OF THIS WOULD WOULD HAVE
BEEN THAT SEVEN SPECIFIED
COUNTIES WOULD HAVE, UH,
RECEIVED A REGISTERED NURSE AND
COMMUNITY HEALTH WORKERS, UM, AT
SELECTED SENIOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING SITES WITH THE GOAL OF
JUST HELPING THESE FOLKS WITHIN
THESE AFFORDABLE HOUSING SITES
TO AVOID INSTITUTIONALIZATION
AND AGE IN PLACE. THIS WAS NOT A
PILOT THAT PROVIDED HOUSING OR
ANYTHING OF THAT NATURE. THIS
WAS TO, UM EMPOWER THEM WITH,
YOU KNOW, HEALTH SYSTEM
NAVIGATION, CHRONIC CONDITIONS,
DISEASE MANAGEMENT COACHING, UM,
THINGS OF THIS NATURE THAT WOULD
AGAIN JUST HELP THEM TO AGE WITH
DIGNITY AND THEIR THEIR HOMES.
AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE NOT
INITIATED THE WORK, SO THERE IS
NOT AN IMPACT TO THE LOCALS.
THANK YOU. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
I JUST WANTED TO ECHO THOSE
COMMENTS. UM GIVEN THAT THIS
BUDGET SOLUTION DOESN'T DISRUPT
ANY LOCAL SERVICES, AND, UH,
GIVEN SOME OTHER OBSTACLES
IDENTIFIED BY èC Dð A IN THEIR
WORK WITH STAKEHOLDERS, UH WE
FELT THAT THIS WAS AN IMPORTANT
BUDGET SOLUTION. THANK YOU, A
LEO. YOU WANT YOUR LEGISLATIVE
AND HIS OFFICE? UM YEAH, GIVEN
THE UM, BUDGET CONDITION AND THE
FACT THAT VERY LITTLE MONEY HAS
GONE OUT THIS TIME WE HAVE NÓ
CONCERNS. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
WE'RE GONNA HOLD THE ITEM OPEN
AND MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER
THREE. THANK YOU. ISSUE NUMBER
THREE. IS CAL. FRESH HEALTHY
LIVING? UM THIS IS REALLY A
TECHNICAL, UH, REQUEST. IT'S AN
INCREASE IN REIMBURSEMENT
AUTHORITY. THIS WOULD AFFORD US
ONE PERMANENT MONITORING
POSITION WITH THE BALANCE OF,
UH, 1.8 JUST OH, JUST UNDER 1.9
MILLION GOING IN LOCAL
ASSISTANCE. UH, FUNDING TO OUR
LOCAL PARTNERS. WE CURRENTLY
HAVE 20 AREA AGENCIES ON AGING
PARTICIPATING IN THIS IN 37
COUNTIES. YOU MIGHT REMEMBER,
UH, THIS, UH, PROPOSAL FROM LAST
YEAR. ALSO RECEIVED AN INCREASE
THEN AND THIS IS JUST REALLY TO.
UM UH INCREASE, UM, EDUCATION
AND TRAINING ABOUT HEALTHY
LIVING GOOD NUTRITION AND HOW TO
MAKE HEALTHY FOOD CHOICES ON A
LIMITED BUDGET TARGETED AT OLDER
ADULTS. PART OF FINANCE ANY
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS. NOTHING.
HELLO? NÓ CONCERNS. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. WE'RE GONNA HOLD THE ITEM
OPEN AND MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER
FOUR. THANK YOU. UM SO THE
OVERVIEW OF THIS ONE IS THAT WE
ARE REQUESTING THAT THE HEALTH
INSURANCE COUNSELING AND AD
ADVOCACY PROGRAM ALSO KNOWN AS
HIGH CAP, WHICH IS ADMINISTERED
STATEWIDE BY 26 OF THE AREA,
AGENCIES ON AGING, UH, RECEIVE A
CONTINUATION OF FUNDING THAT WAS
INITIATED IN, UM 20 JULY 21.
WHAT WE'RE SEEKING TO DO IS, UM,
WE WANT TO AND EXPAND THE HIGH
CAP PENETRATION RATE HERE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE HAVE A
RATE OF ABOUT 1. NATIONALLY
OTHER STATES HAVE THREE TO 7%
THIS PROPOSAL WOULD MAINTAIN THE
FUNDING FOR LOCAL PARTNERS TO
HAVE ONE FULL TIME VOLUNTEER
COORDINATOR BECAUSE 74% OF THE
PROGRAM IS, UH, RUN BY
VOLUNTEERS. SO IT'S A VERY, VERY
IMPORTANT THAT WE, UM HAVE
DEDICATED SUPPORT FOR THEM AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL. WE DID SEE
THROUGHOUT COVID THAT THE
VOLUNTEERS, UH STEEPLY DECLINED
AND WE DO HAVE PLANS TO INITIATE
AN EFFORT TO GO AHEAD AND
ENHANCE THAT THE VOLUNTEER
ACCOUNT AND THEN AT THE STATE
LEVEL, WE'RE REQUESTING THREE.
POSITIONS ONE FOR DATA, ONE FOR
FISCAL AND ONE FOR TRAINING AND
MONITORING. UM THIS IS A
CONTINUATION OF THE EFFORTS THAT
WE'VE ASKED, BEGINNING IN JULY
OF 21. THERE IS A SECOND
QUESTION HERE ABOUT OUR PLAN
LONG TERM AND WE DO HAVE AN
ACTIVE EFFORT UNDERWAY TO
DEVELOP A STRATEGIC PLAN TO
MODERNIZE AND EXPAND. UM, WE
CONTRACTED WITH A CONSULTANT TO
CONDUCT A SWOT ANALYSIS AND
DEVELOP GOALS AND OBJECTIVES.
UH, WE'VE ALSO, UM INITIATED THE
WORK AND THE REQUEST FOR
PROPOSAL ACTUALLY TO BRING A
CONSULTANT ON TO HELP US. UM,
WITH THIS EFFORT. WHAT WE'D LIKE
TO DO IS RAISE PUBLIC AWARENESS
OF THE HIGH CAP SERVICES THROUGH
MARKETING AND OUTREACH. WE'D
LIKE TO INCREASE THE NUMBER OF
HIGH CAP STAFF IN ORDER TO
EXPAND SERVICES AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL, ENHANCE THE HIGH CAP
TOOLS AND INFORMATIONAL
RESOURCES AND THEN CONTINUALLY
UPDATE THE TRAINING. UM,
ESPECIALLY BECAUSE THE
COMPLEXITY IN MEDICARE ADVANTAGE
AND LONG TERM CARE INSURANCE AND
OTHER PLAN OFFERINGS. UH, JUST
JUST CONTINUES TO GET MORE
COMPLEX. WE WANNA ENSURE THEY'RE
EMPOWERED AT THE LOCAL LEVEL,
AND WE WILL BE WORKING WITH A
COALITION OF STAKEHOLDERS TO
INFORM AND THIS PLAN, WHICH WE
PLAN TO BRING TO YOU NEXT FISCAL
YEAR. IN IN RESPONSE TO YOUR
QUESTIONS ON THE STATUS. THE
CONDITION OF THE HIGH CAP
SPECIAL FUND. UH, EXPENDITURES
FROM THE HIGH CAP SPECIAL FUND
ARE PROJECTED TO BE 4.4 MILLION
IN THE CURRENT YEAR. IT'S
EXPECTED TO CARRY A BALANCE OF
17.1 MILLION INTO THE 2425
FISCAL YEAR. UH, CURRENT LAW
REQUIRES THAT ALL REVENUES
RECEIVED IN THE FUND ARE
EXPENDED ON HIGH CAP UM AND èC
Dð. A'S EFFORTS TO MODERNIZE THE
HIGH CAP PROGRAM ARE EXPECTED TO
INCREASE EXPENDITURES AND DRAW
DOWN ON THAT RESERVE. CAN YOU
REPEAT THAT LAST PART? UH,
EXPENDED THE EFFORTS THAT THE
èC Dð IS UNDERGOING TO
MODERNIZE THE HIGH CAP PROGRAM
ARE EXPECTED TO INCREASE
EXPENDITURES, WHICH WILL DRAW
DOWN ON THE CURRENT RESERVE.
THANK YOU. A LEO ANY COMMENT ON
THIS? OH, YEAH, NÓ CONCERN AT
THIS TIME. SO I KNOW IN THE PAST
. WE'VE UM TAKEN A LOAN $5
MILLION FROM THIS FUND. ARE WE
LOOKING AT THIS DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND IS ANOTHER POTENTIAL
LOAN TO HELP WITH THEIR CURRENT
SITUATION? THAT'S THAT'S NOT A
SOLUTION THAT WE'VE INCLUDED IN
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET THIS YEAR.
UM, BUT SOMETHING WE COULD WE BE
HAPPY TO TALK ABOUT IF THAT'S
THAT'D BE INTERESTED. YOU KNOW,
WE'RE DEPLETING OUR SAFETY
RESERVE. UH FUND. I MEAN, IF
THIS IS A FUND THAT WE CAN
BORROW THE REALLY IDEAL TO LOOK
AT PERHAPS INCLUDING THE MAY
REVISE. ANY OTHER QUESTIONS. OK?
WE'RE GONNA HOLD THE ITEM OPEN
AND MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER
FIVE. THANK YOU. ISSUE FIVE IS
THE OFFICE OF THE LONG TERM CARE
PATIENT REPRESENTATIVE? WOULD
YOU LIKE ME TO KEEP MOVING
QUICKLY? OH, OK. SO UM, SO
OFFICER LONG TERM CARE PATIENT
REPRESENTATIVE JUST MARKED ITS
ONE YEAR ANNIVERSARY OF BEING
THIS ONE CAN GO BE A SHORT ONE.
OK NOT THE NEXT ONE. SO THIS IS
ALSO TECHNICAL BY NATURE. UM
WHAT WE'RE SEEKING TO DO IS
INITIALLY WHEN WE OPENED THIS
PROGRAM. WE HAD WANTED TO SEEK
CONTRACTORS AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
TO CARRY OUT THE WORK. UM WE DID
FIND TWO. BUT THAT OBVIOUSLY
WASN'T GONNA BE A STATEWIDE
COVERAGE. SO WE, UH HIRED STAFF
INSTEAD TO COMPLETE THE WORKLOAD
THAT'S WORKED TREMENDOUSLY. SO
WHAT WE'RE SEEKING TO DO IS MOVE
FUNDING FROM LOCAL SYSTEMS IN
THE STATE OPS AND KEEP THOSE
EIGHT STAFF MEMBERS ON
PERMANENTLY TO SUSTAIN THE
PROGRAM. PERMANENT FINANCE.
NOTHING. I HELLO. HELLO NÓ
CONCERNS IN THIS TIME. WE'RE
GONNA HOLD THE ITEM OPEN AND
MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER SIX.
THANK YOU. SO OUR ADVANCING
OLDER ADULT BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
UPDATE. UM THIS ONE IS COMPRISED
OF THREE MAJOR INVESTMENTS, ALL
OF WHICH ARE CURRENTLY UNDERWAY.
UH, THE FIRST INVESTMENT WAS 4.5
MILLION FOR THE CONTINUATION OF
WHAT WE'VE CALLED THE FRIENDSHIP
LINE OR THE OLDER ADULT WORM.
UH, BEHAVIORAL HEALTH BEHAVIORAL
LINE. UM AND WHAT WE'VE FOUND IS
WE DID CONDUCT THE RFP TO FIND A
VENDOR TO CONTINUE THE WORKLOAD.
AFTER THE EXISTING CONTRACT
ENDED. IT HAPPENED TO BE THE
INSTITUTE ON AGING WHO HAD
PREVIOUSLY WORKED ON THE
FRIENDSHIP. LINE AND THERE HAVE
BEEN NÓ INTER INTERRUPTIONS IN
SERVICES AND THAT IS UNDERWAY
RIGHT NOW, UM, WE ALSO HAVE
ENTERED INTO A $10 MILLION
ETHNIC MEDIA OUTREACH CAMPAIGN,
UM, WITH A VENDOR US THAT WE'VE
WORKED ON WITH SEVERAL OF OUR
COMMUNICATION EFFORTS, AND WE'VE
BEEN INITIATED THE WORK ON
LITERATURE REPORT REVIEWS LAYING
DOWN P FOUNDATIONAL WORK TO MAP
OUT THE RESEARCH AND MARKETING
PLAN OVER THE NEXT THREE YEARS.
UM, BECAUSE OUR AIM IS TO REACH
MARGINALIZED COMMUNITIES THAT
HISTORICALLY LACK SUPPORT FOR
HEALTH RESOURCES. UM, WE WANNA
BE ABLE TO DISSEMINATE
INFORMATION AND UNDERSTAND THE
UNIQUE NEEDS AND PERSPECTIVES OF
THESE ETHNIC COMMUNITIES. SO UM,
THE THERE IS QUITE A BIT OF
RESEARCH UNDERWAY SO THAT WE CAN
GO AHEAD AND, UM, PROPERLY
IMPLEMENT THIS TO REACH THE
TARGETED AUDIENCE, AND LASTLY,
WE HAVE THE CAPACITY BUILDING
GRANTS UNDERWAY, WHICH WILL BE A
THREE PRONGED APPROACH OF
TRAINING AND EDUCATION,
STRENGTHENING LOCAL
ORGANIZATIONS, CAPACITY TO
ADDRESS BEHAVIORAL HEALTH NEEDS
AND THEN ADVANCING INNOVATIVE
PROGRAMS. WE, UM, ANTICIPATE
THAT WE'RE ENGAGE WITH THE
STAKEHOLDERS THIS SPRING, AND
WE'D LIKE TO SEE OUR REQUEST FOR
APPLICATIONS OUT LATE, UH, LATE
SUMMER EARLY FALL. NOTHING. NÓ
CONCERNS AT THIS TIME. LA. I
HAVE CONCERNS WITH THIS. UM SO
I'VE BEEN TRYING TO FIND IF
THERE'S A PATTERN WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION AND WHAT WE'RE
PROPOSING TO CUT DELAY AND I
THOUGHT THE PATTERN WAS, UM WELL
, I'VE SEEN A PATTERN WHERE SOME
OF THESE THINGS THAT WE'RE
PROPOSING TO KEEP ON HAVEN'T
EVEN STARTED. AND THEN THE ONES
THAT WERE CUTTING HAVE STARTED
ALREADY. I'M BEATING THIS HORSE
TO THE GROUND ON FURS ON COW
WORKS ON WELL, FOSTER SOAPS.
INCREASE HASN'T BEEN HAPPENING,
BUT THE PROGRAM IS EXISTING. UM
THIS IS ALSO MY TOP FIVE ON
OLDER, A ADULT BEHAVIOR, HEALTH
MEDIA CAMPAIGN AND THE CAPACITY
BUILDING GRANTS TO BE CALLED
BACK. EVEN THOUGH THAT WE HAVE
ENTERED INTO A VENDOR CONTRACT
FOR THE OLDER ADULT BEHAVIORAL.
WE ALSO HAVE ON ISSUE NUMBER TWO
WHERE WE'VE SPENT ALREADY
$610,000. THIS IS ANOTHER THING
THAT WE PEOPLE'S LIVES WON'T
REALLY BE AT RISK. IF WE CALL
BACK. I DON'T SEE A
JUSTIFICATION DIRECTOR ON MOVING
FORWARD WITH CLOSE TO $50
MILLION HERE WHEN THAT COULD
FUND FIRST, UM AND I KNOW NOT
UNDER THIS DEPARTMENT, BUT THAT
COULD FUND A PROGRAM THAT REALLY
HELPS AND MOVING FORWARD. SO I
WANNA FIND A WAY WHERE EITHER
WE'RE CUTTING FROM THIS
COMPLETELY DEPLETING IT, AND
WE'RE FUNDING IT, AND WE'RE
FUNDING PROGRAMS THAT ARE
ALREADY EXIST. UM SO JUST
FLAGGING THAT THIS IS ON MY LIST
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THAT WE
SHOULD NOT BE CONTINUING MOVING
FORWARD WITH, UM, BECAUSE THESE
ARE PROGRAMS THAT HAVE NOT
STARTED. OK, WE'RE GONNA HOLD
THAT ITEM OPEN MOVE ON TO ISSUE
NUMBER SEVEN. THANK YOU. SO
ISSUE NUMBER SEVEN IS THE HÌ èC
B S¼ SPEND PLAN. UM AND THERE'S
A QUESTION UH, JUST ABOUT THE
UPDATES FOR THE PROGRAMS AND
THEN JUST, UM, PROGRAMS THAT
HAVE LOW SPENDING. UH AT THIS
TIME, ALL OF THE PROGRAMS ARE
FULLY IMPLEMENTED. AND NOW IN
THEIR MAINTENANCE STAGE, IF YOU
WILL OF THE LIFE OF THE PROGRAM,
UH MANY OF THEM TOOK A
CONSIDERABLE AMOUNT OF TIME TO
STAND UP BECAUSE, UM, OUR LOCAL
PARTNERS WERE HAD MORE FUNDING
THAN THEY REALLY EVER SEEN,
ESPECIALLY DUE TO THE FEDERAL
FUNDS THAT INFLUX THAT CAME
THROUGH, UM, ALSO PRODUCTION AND
, UM, THE ABILITY TO SUBCONTRACT
THROUGHOUT COVID REALLY MADE IT.
CHALLENGING TO START THE
PROGRAMS. THEY ARE ALL
OFFICIALLY UNDERWAY. WE DO A
FULLY EXPECT THAT WE'RE GOING TO
SEE QUITE HIGH VOLUMES OF
EXPENDITURES OVER THE SUMMER, A
PRIME EXAMPLE WOULD BE THE
SENIOR NUTRITION INFRASTRUCTURE
PROGRAM, WHICH IS THINGS LIKE
VEHICLES, REFRIGERATION SYSTEMS.
FREEZERS UM, PRODUCTION WAS A
HUGE HINDRANCE TO US GETTING
THOSE INVOICES UH, PARTICULARLY
BECAUSE THEY WANT TO INVOICE US
UNTIL A GOOD WAS RECEIVED. BUT
NOW WE KNOW THAT THOSE ARE
STARTING TO ROLL IN, AND WE DO
EXPECT TO SEE MUCH HIGHER
EXPENDITURES MOVING FORWARD. UH
OUR èC GROWS PROGRAM WAS 100
AND $50 MILLION. IT WAS OUR
LARGEST ONE. IT WAS FOR DIRECT
CARE AT TRADING AND STIPENDS.
THEY UM THAT ONE, TOO. HAD A
SLOW ROLL OUT. UH JUST OVER
THIS. LAST WEEK, WE SAW DOUBLE
THE NUMBER OF APPLICATIONS
SUBMITTED THAN WHAT HAD BEEN
PREVIOUSLY SUBMITTED AND WE DO
EXPECT THAT TREND TO CONTINUE
FORWARD. SO UM, MANY OF THESE
DID HAVE SOMEWHAT OF A SLOW
START FOR A VARIETY OF REASONS
AND CIRCUMSTANCES, BUT THEY ARE
UNDERWAY. AND IF THERE'S THIS
PARTICULAR PROGRAM YOU'RE
INTERESTED IN. I'M HAPPY TO, UM
TO DIVE INTO THAT ONE AS WELL.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. AND DUFFY
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. YOU HAD A
QUESTION ON THE PROCESS FOR
TRACKING AND ADJUSTING
EXPENDITURES TO ENSURE ALL THE
FUNDS ARE SPENT. UM, SO JUST
STEPPING BACK AS PART OF THE
2021 BUDGET ACT. UM CONTROL
SECTION 11.95 WAS INCLUDED AND
HAS SINCE BEEN INCLUDED IN THE
2022 AND 2023 BUDGET ACT IS ALSO
PROPOSED FOR THE 2425.
GOVERNANCE BUDGET AS WELL. THIS
CONTROL SECTION IS THE MECHANISM
THAT WE USE TO ADMINISTER THE HÌ
èC B S¼ SPENDING PLAN, WHICH
PROVIDED APPROXIMATELY $4.6
BILLION FOR 26 INITIATIVES
ACROSS SIX DEPARTMENTS. WE WORK
CLOSELY WITH DEPARTMENTS TO
EVALUATE, UM OF THE SPENDING OF
THE HÌ èC B S¼ DOLLARS, AS WELL
AS THE STATUS IMPLEMENTATION OF
ALL THE PROGRAMS. IN ADDITION,
DHCS SENDS QUARTERLY UPDATES TO,
UH èC M S¼, UM, FOR, UH,
PROGRESS UPDATES. UH, IN
ADDITION, WE SEND JOINT
LEGISLATIVE BUDGET COMMITTEE, UM
, NOTIFICATIONS TO THE
LEGISLATURE AND WORK DIRECTLY
WITH THE GLB èC ASSEMBLY AND
SENATE STAFF AS WELL, UM,
PROVIDING UPDATES AND NÓ CHANGES
OR ADJUSTMENTS ARE DONE. UM TO
THE INITIATIVES WITHOUT WORKING
WITH THE LEGISLATURE. UM, SO THE
ADMINISTRATION CONTINUES TO WORK
TO GET THESE DOLLARS OUT INTO
THE COMMUNITY AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET REFLECTS THAT ALL DOLLARS
WILL BE SPENT, UM BY THE
DECEMBER 31ST 2024 STATE
DEADLINE. HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS. IF YOU
HAVE THEM, I'LL COME BACK TO
YOU, AO YOU WANT TO WITH THE L A
Ó, UM, SO SIMILAR WITH THE
CAREER PATHWAYS PROGRAM WHERE
WORKING WITH THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE BUDGET COMMITTEE, UM
DO, UM ENSURE OR TO UNDERSTAND
THE ADMINISTRATION'S PLANS ON
ENSURING THAT ALL THE FUNDING IS
EXPENDED BY THE DEADLINE. UM SO
I MEAN, WE'VE MADE SOME PROGRESS
ON A LOT OF THESE PROGRAMS. UM
YOU KNOW, I THINK, I LOOK AT THE
TECHNOLOGY FOR SENIORS. WE'RE AT
18,000 NOW. 11.1 THE ONE THAT I
DON'T SEE A LOT OF PROGRESS MADE
SINCE LAST YEAR'S THE NÓ WRONG
DOOR ONE. I THINK WE ONLY BUMPED
UP $20,000 SINCE LAST YEAR AND
BARRIERS. ADDITIONAL BARRIERS
WERE SEEN ON THAT PROGRAM. UM SO
IN TERMS OF BEARERS, I, I
WOULDN'T SAY THERE'S BARRIERS.
WE HAD A LOT OF PLANNING LAST
YEAR WITH OUR A Dð R èC, UM,
PARTNERS, UH, WE DO HAVE PLANS
TO DO ADDITIONAL TRAININGS AND
ROLL OUT ADDITIONAL PROGRAMS IN
THE CURRENT YEAR OR SO. WE DO
THINK THAT WE'RE ON TRACK TO
FULLY EXPEND THOSE, UH, FUNDS.
WE'RE ALSO LOOKING TO SET UP A
STATEWIDE RESOURCE DIRECTORY
WITH THE FUNDING AS WELL. SO UM,
WE DEFINITELY HAVE PLANS
ACTIVELY UNDERWAY TO SPEND THE
FUNDING, YOU KNOW, DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. SO WHEN I LOOKING AT
THESE THINGS LIKE WE HEARD
EARLIER FROM HÌ Dð B S¼, THE
OTHER PART OF IT RIGHT? AND THEN
HERE IN AGING. WE'RE STILL
REALLY SHORT. I KNOW WE'RE ON
TRACK TO BUT WE'RE STILL VERY
SHORT IN, UM, UTILIZING ALL
THESE FUNDS. I WOULD RATHER
FOCUS ON UTILIZING THE FUNDS
THAT WE HAVE AVAILABLE TO US
HERE VERSUS TRYING TO ALL THESE
OTHER PROGRAMS UNDER THE MEDIA
CAMPAIGN, AND, UM, THE OTHER THE
CAPACITY BUILDING GRANTS LIKE
THAT'S WHERE I SEE FOR ME. I WAS
LIKE, OK, WE WANT MORE FUNDING
FOR NEW PROGRAMS WHERE WE'RE
SEEING ALL TAKE OFF SLOWLY. UM
IT DOESN'T ADD UP TO ME, WHEREAS
WE CAN PULL THAT FUNDING BACK
AND FUND THE PROGRAMS THAT
ALREADY EXIST. I'M JUST AGAIN
BEATING THIS HORSE TO THE GROUND
WHERE MAYBE. HOPEFULLY WE'LL
EXPAND ALL THE DOLLARS IN THIS
SECTION. UM BUT WHY NOT FULLY
FOCUS ON THE ONES THAT WE HAVE
RIGHT NOW? AND YOU? YOU DON'T
HAVE TO ANSWER THAT RIGHT NOW.
BUT AND THEN UTILIZE THAT EXTRA
FUNDING FOR PROGRAMS THAT
ALREADY EXIST. UH, BECAUSE I
MEAN, I DO HOPE WE CAN EXPEND
UTILIZE THE ENTIRE POCKET HERE.
BUT I'M JUST REPEATING AGAIN.
FOCUS ON THAT. THE FUNDING THAT
WE HAVE FROM HÌ Dð B S¼ THE
EXTRA FUNDING OF CLOSE TO $50
MILLION OR $45 MILLION USE IT
FOR GF AND GENERAL FUND AND
OTHER ISSUES. SENATORS. I WAS
LEFT ALONE TODAY. WHAT HAPPENED?
NÓ OH, GOSH. OK? UM NÓ FURTHER
COMMENTS. AND WE'RE GONNA HOLD
THE THIS IS THE INFORMATIONAL.
NEVER MIND. UM WE ARE GOING TO
MOVE ON TO THAT'S IT FOR THE
DEPARTMENT. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
DEPARTMENT OF AGING. I DIDN'T
THINK I WAS GONNA MAKE IT. I'M
GONNA MAKE MY FLIGHT, OK? I'M
GONNA MOVE FOR LIKE WE'RE GONNA
DO PROPOSALS FOR INVESTMENTS AND
WE HAVE TWO PROPOSALS HERE. I'D
LIKE TO FIRST WELCOME UP THE
PROPOSAL FOR UTILIZING RESERVES
FOR LONG TERM CARE OMBUDS.
PROGRAMS. HELLO. WOULD YOU LIKE
TO SIT HERE OR YOU OK THERE. BE
HAPPY TO SIT THERE.
HELLO YOU HAVE THREE MINUTES. GO
AHEAD. YEAH. GOOD AFTERNOON.
SENATORS THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT THIS
REQUEST, AND I WOULD BE REMISS
IF I DIDN'T THINK SENATORS DODD
IN BOTH FOR SPONSORING OUR
REQUEST TODAY, UM, THE LONG TERM
CARE OMBUDSMAN PROGRAM PROVIDES
FREE RESIDENT CENTERED ADVOCACY
SERVICES TO RESIDENTS OF OVER
9000 LONG TERM CARE FACILITIES
TO ENSURE RESIDENTS' HEALTH
SAFETY QUALITY OF LIFE AND 25%
OF THE PROGRAM'S CASE. CASE LOAD
ACTUALLY. INVOLVES INVESTIGATING
ABUSE AND NEGLECT REPORTS THAT
ARE NOT WITHIN APS JURISDICTION.
THE PROGRAM SAVES THE STATE
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
BY FILTERING OUT CONCERNS THAT
WOULD OTHERWISE BE ESCALATED TO
STATE LICENSING AGENCIES, AND IT
ALSO HELPS THE STATE RECOVER
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS THROUGH
ESCALATING EGREGIOUS CASES TO
REGULATE REGULATORS AND
PROSECUTORS WHO RECOVER
PENALTIES, DAMAGES AND
RESTITUTION. TO ADDRESS THE
SEVERE SHORTFALL OF STAFF AND
VOLUNTEERS IN THE PROGRAM. WE
ARE SEEKING A COMBINED $9.25
MILLION IN ADDITIONAL ANNUAL
FUNDING FROM TWO SPECIAL FUNDS
ADMINISTERED BY èC Dð, P HÌ
THAT ALREADY FUND THE PROGRAM
AND HAVE MORE THAN ENOUGH EXTRA
FUNDING EACH YEAR TO COVER THE
COSTS OF THIS REQUEST REVENUES
TO THE SPECIAL FUNDS FROM
REGULATORY PENALTIES AND
LICENSING FEES ARE NOT EXPECTED
TO DECREASE BUT INCREASE AND
WILL THEREFORE NOT BE IMPACTED
BY THE BUDGET DEFICIT THIS YEAR.
SENATORS CALIFORNIA'S AGING
INDEPENDENT ADULTS ARE
NEEDLESSLY SUFFERING IN LONG
TERM CARE FACILITIES WITHOUT
ACCESS TO OMBUDSMAN SERVICES.
THE STATE CURRENTLY HAS THE
RESOURCES TO PROVIDE THESE
SERVICES AND IS REQUIRED BY
FEDERAL LAW TO DO SO. WE
THEREFORE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT,
APPROPRIATE, APPROPRIATING AND
ADDITIONAL 9.25 MILLION ANNUALLY
FROM THESE TWO SPECIAL FUNDS,
AND I KNOW YOU HAVE A FLIGHT TO
CATCH. SO I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS. TRY TO GIVE YOU
THE SHORT VERSION. YOU. YOU
HAVEN'T MINUTE AND A HALF IF YOU
WANNA ADD ANYTHING ELSE. YOU OK?
YEAH I WOULD ADD. UM, IN
ADDITION TO THAT, I WOULD SAY
THE TWO FUNDS THAT WE'RE LOOKING
AT SPECIFICALLY ARE THE STATE
LICENSING èC STATE HEALTH
FACILITIES CITATIONS FUND, WHICH
IS FUNDED BY CITATIONS LEVIED
AGAINST èC Dð P AGAINST SKILLED
NURSING FACILITIES, AND THAT
FUND IS LEGISLATIVELY CAPPED AT
$10 MILLION, AND IT ROUTINELY
ENDS EACH YEAR WITH 10 TO $14
MILLION AS OF RECENT YEARS, SO
THERE'S A LOT OF MONEY THAT'S
BEING AND IT'S ACTUALLY JUST
BEING LOCKED UP IN THAT ACCOUNT
EACH YEAR NOT BEING ABLE TO BE
ROLLED OVER BECAUSE IT'S SORT OF
GOING THROUGH THIS THIS
APPROPRIATION CYCLE OVER AND
OVER. UM THE OTHER FUND IS THE
LICENSING AND CERTIFICATIONS FEE
FUND, WHICH IS SUPPORTED BY THE
REVENUES FROM LICENSING AND, UM,
APPLICATION AND RENEWAL FEES,
AND THAT FUND IS STARTING THIS
BUDGET YEAR WITH $130 MILLION IN
, UH IN RESERVES. SO BETWEEN
THESE TWO FUNDS, I MEAN, IF WE
PULL, UH, 4.75 MILLION DOLLARS
FROM EACH BOND OR SOMETHING LIKE
THAT. WE'RE REALLY NOT IMPACTING
THOSE FUNDS TOO MUCH. THAT MONEY
IS ALREADY EARMARKED FOR THIS
PURPOSE. AND, UM, WE DON'T
ENVISION THAT. SITUATION
CHANGING IN FUTURE YEARS, AND WE
ACTUALLY THINK IT WILL SAVE THE
STATE MONEY IN TERMS OF
PREVENTING PREVENTING WORK THAT
WOULD OTHERWISE GO TO LICENSING
EVERY TIME THE LICENSING AGENCY
HAS TO DEFEND A CITATION THAT
COSTS ABOUT, UH 25 TO $50,000,
AND THEY OFTEN SETTLE FOR LESS.
SO I THINK THAT THE OMBUDSMAN
PROGRAM IS A GREAT, UM, IN
BETWEEN IN TERMS OF INVESTING IN
QUALITY ASSURANCE, ACTIVE
QUALITY ASSURANCE, SO WE DON'T
HAVE TO SPEND MORE MONEY ON
RESOLVING THOSE PROBLEMS LATER.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE YOU HAVE TYLER ANY
UPDATE ON THESE TWO S¼ FUNDS ANY
INFORMATION? I DON'T KNOW IF YOU
HAVE NUMBERS. THAT UM, CONFIRM
THE AMOUNT OF THESE FUNDS AND
WHAT THEY'RE USED FOR. ANDREW
DUFFY DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. UM
WERE TAKING A LOOK AT THE, UH
PROPOSALS AND DON'T HAVE
ANYTHING ADDITIONAL SHARE AT THE
MOMENT WOULD JUST NOTE THAT
THESE ARE NOT PROPOSALS THAT ARE
INCLUDED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET. I JUST THOUGHT MAYBE YOU
KNEW SOMETHING ABOUT THE FENCE
AND OFF THE TOP OF YOUR HEAD.
OK, THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PRESENTATION. I'M
ASSUMING NÓ OK. THANK YOU. A
FINAL PRESENTATION. IT IS. YOU
KNOW, THESE ARE MEMBERS ARE
LEAVING AT THE END OF THE YEAR,
YOU KNOW? THEIR SENIOR YEAR.
YEAH THAT'S TRUE. THAT'S RIGHT.
TODAY IS NOT SENIOR DITCH DAY,
SO THEY'RE HERE WITH US. OKAY I,
I PROMISE TO BE, UH, BRIEF. UM
GOOD AFTERNOON. MY NAME IS
MICHAEL COSTA. I'M EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF AREA AGENCIES ON
AGING. ALSO KNOWN AS AAA. S¼. I
WANNA THANK YOU CHAIR MEN AND
SUBCOMITTEE MEMBERS EGM, ROTH
AND GROVE FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK TODAY ABOUT A èC FOR A Dð
R èC BUDGET ASK, I'D ALSO LIKE
TO THANK SENATOR HURTADO FOR
CHAMPIONING THIS ASK AND THE
CALIFORNIA FOUNDATION FOR
INDEPENDENT LIVING CENTERS FOR
THEIR PARTNERSHIP IN SUPPORTING
THIS ASK THE ORIGINAL VISION OF
THE AGING AND DISABILITY
RESOURCE CONNECTION, KNOWN AS A
Dð R èC S¼ WAS TO ESTABLISH
TRUSTED SOURCES OF INFORMATION
IN EVERY COMMUNITY WHERE PEOPLE
PARTICULARLY OLDER ADULTS, AND
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES COULD
TURN FOR INFORMATION ON A FULL
RANGE OF LONG TERM SERVICES AND
SUPPORT OPTIONS AND THUS HAVE A
MEANS TO ACCESS PUBLIC LONG TERM
SUPPORT SERVICES. CURRENTLY $10
MILLION IS OUT AT A ALLOCATED
ANNUALLY TO A Dð R. SEASON IN
CALIFORNIA TO ACCOMPLISH THIS
VISION. AS OF NOW, ALL 10
MILLION IS ALLOCATED AMONG 25
DESIGNATED AND EMERGING A Dð R
èC S¼ IN THIS FISCAL YEAR,
THERE IS NÓ ADDITIONAL FUNDING
AVAILABLE TO SUPPORT THE
ESTIMATED 16 AAA S¼ ARE
INDEPENDENT LIVING CENTERS WHO
ARE IN THE PROCESS OF APPLYING
FOR EMERGING STATUS. THEREFORE
FOR THE A Dð R èC PROGRAM TO
CONTINUE DEVELOPMENT AS A
CRITICAL ASPECT OF THE MASTER
PLANS. ATTEMPT TO DEVELOP A NÓ
WRONGDOER PROGRAM. THE
ALLOCATION MUST BE RAISED MUST
BE RAISED TO ACCOUNT FOR A
CURRENT INFLATION RATE OF 3.1%
IT MUST BE RAISED TO CONTINUE TO
EXPAND THE A Dð R èC PROGRAM
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA SO THAT
OLDER CALIFORNIANS AND
INDIVIDUALS LIVING WITH
DISABILITIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE HAVE ACCESS TO THE PROGRAM
. IT MUST BE RAISED SO THAT
THERE IS NOT A BRUTAL ZERO SUM
GAME THAT IS INEVITABLE WHEN
FUNDING IS CAPPED, BUT MORE AND
MORE PROGRAMS ARE ENTERING AND
COMPETING FOR A FIXED POT OF
MONEY TO FURTHER EXPANSION AND
INCREASE THE SUSTAINABILITY OF
THE ADR. èC PROGRAM IN
CALIFORNIA. WE ARE ASKING THAT
THE PROGRAM ALLOCATION BE RAISED
OVER TWO YEARS WITH $25,994,000
TO STATE FISCAL YEAR 2425 AND
$51,988,000 TO BE ALLOCATED IN
STATE FISCAL YEAR 2520. SIX AND
THEREAFTER. WITHOUT THAT
ADDITIONAL FUNDING OF FUNCTIONAL
STATEWIDE, UH, A Dð R èC
NETWORK AND THUS A NÓ WRONG DOOR
SYSTEM WILL NOT HAPPEN. UH, WE
DO HAVE NUMBERS THAT WE CAN
SUBMIT. IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO SEE
WE'VE KIND OF DONE THE MATH, UH,
BEHIND, UH, THOSE TWO NUMBERS.
UM THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK. AND I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. OK? UM THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PRESENTATION. SO THAT
CONCLUDES OUR PRESENTATIONS.
WE'RE MOVING ON TO PUT THE
COMMENT UNDER DEPARTMENT OF
AGING FOR ISSUES ONE THROUGH
EIGHT. THANK YOU. CHAIR
MENJIVAR. CHRISTINA BOSS
HAMILTON. THANK YOU. SENATOR
ROTH, SENATOR EDMAN. WE WILL
MISS YOU BOTH VERY MUCH, AND I
JUST WANT TO THANK YOU BOTH FOR
STILL BEING IN THIS HEARING
BECAUSE HONESTLY, LIKE HAVING
THE ALMOST MAJORITY OF THE
MEMBERS HERE IS REALLY NICE TO
SEE FROM AN ADVOCATE PERSPECTIVE
. THANK YOU FOR THAT CHRISTINA
BOSS, HAMILTON, REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION FOR ADULT
SERVICES, SPEAKING SPECIFICALLY
ON THE BRIDGE TO RECOVERY GRANT
PROGRAM. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
EMPHASIZING THAT AND STAYING ON
TOP OF THE THIS GRANT PROGRAM.
TWO YEARS AGO, WE CAME TO THE
LEGISLATURE AND WE'RE SO
GRATEFUL FOR THE MONIES THAT
WERE APPROPRIATED, AND WE REMAIN
GRATEFUL TO THE LEGISLATURE AND
TO THE ADMINISTRATION AND
UNDERSTANDING THAT èC Dð A WAS
HIT, NOT HIT, BUT GIVEN SO MANY
NEW PROGRAMS TO ADMINISTER AND
SO MANY, LIKE NEW THINGS IT HAD
TO DO. WE ARE ACKNOWLEDGING THAT
AND BASICALLY JUST WANTING TO
SHARE THAT THE FUNDING NEEDS FOR
THESE CENTERS REMAINS EXTREMELY
STRONG AND CONTINUES. IT'S EVEN
MORE SO THAN IT WAS TWO YEARS
AGO, AND WE ARE DEEPLY
DISAPPOINTED. THANK YOU WITH THE
PROCESS AND HOPE THAT WE CAN SEE
. SORRY SEE THESE MONIES
DISTRIBUTED AS SOON AS POSSIBLE.
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON. MY
NAME IS DÂN OKEN FUSS AND I'M,
THE PUBLIC POLICY MANAGER AT THE
CALIFORNIA FOUNDATION FOR
INDEPENDENT LIVING CENTER IS
HAPPY TO BE HERE. I'LL BE VERY
BRIEF HERE. I'M SPEAKING IN
SUPPORT OF THE PROPOSAL FOR
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR THE A Dð
R èC PROGRAM. THE AGING
DISABILITY RESOURCE CONNECTIONS,
UM AS A MEMBER OF èC, FIL èC,
UH, WE ARE THE OTHER HALF OF THE
EQUATION. YOU KNOW, THE WE HAVE
THE èC FOUR A S¼ AND THE AAA S¼
THAT ARE IN EACH COUNTY AND THEN
THE INDEPENDENT LIVING CENTERS
ARE ALSO PROVIDING SERVICES AND
SUPPORTS FOR PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES. UM SO MANY OF THE
INDIVIDUALS WE SERVE COME FROM
THE SAME CHALLENGES. THEY ASK
QUESTIONS LIKE I DON'T KNOW HOW
TO GET BENEFITS I CAN'T FIND IN
HOME CARE, HOUSING, FOOD,
TRANSPORTATION, HOME
MODIFICATIONS AND OTHER THINGS.
THEY NEED TO LIVE. I KNOW THEIR
RESOURCES OUT THERE, BUT I DON'T
KNOW WHERE TO START WHAT I'M
ELIGIBLE FOR OR HOW TO APPLY. I
CAN'T FIND ANYONE TO HELP ME.
THAT'S WHERE WE COME IN AT THE
DC S¼, AND WE'RE THERE ON THE
FRONT LINES, HELPING CONNECT
THOSE CONSUMERS TO THE, UH,
SERVICES THEY NEED SO A LITTLE
SMALL PORTION OF THE BUDGET CAN
GO A LONG WAY. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU SO MUCH. GOOD
AFTERNOON. MADAM CHAIR BLANCA
CASTRO, STATE LONG TERM CARE
OMBUDSMAN, AND WE ABSOLUTELY
NEED TO BUILD CAPACITY AT THE
LOCAL LONG TERM CARE OMBUDSMAN
PROGRAM. SO I'M HERE IN SUPPORT
OF THE REQUEST FROM THE, UM,
ASSOCIATION THAT REPRESENTS
THEM. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU FOR THAT. IS IT WORKING?
HEAR ME NOW. CHRISTO BARNETT
NELSON SENIOR ADVOCACY SERVICES.
I'M THE LONG TERM CARE OMBUDSMAN
AND ALSO THE HEALTH INSURANCE
COUNSELING ADVOCACY PROGRAM. I
THOUGHT TO TELL YOU QUICKLY. A
STORY ABOUT OMBUDSMAN IMAGINE
YOURSELF WAKING UP FROM A
MEDICAL INCIDENT AND YOUR FOG
CLEARS AND YOU'RE IN A LOCKED
DEMENTIA FACILITY. YOU HAVE NÓ
ACCESS TO YOUR FAMILY, THE
ADMINISTRATORS KEEPING THEM OUT
AND THE ONLY PERSON WHO COMES TO
VISIT YOU IS THE OMBUDSMAN. THIS
IS WHAT HAPPENED TO AN
INDIVIDUAL WHO WE HELPED TO
BASICALLY FREE HIM FROM HIS LOCK
DEMENTIA FACILITY BECAUSE HIS
POWER OF ATTORNEY WAS HIS EX
GIRLFRIEND, AND SHE LIKED HIM
THERE BECAUSE SHE HAD MOVED INTO
HIS HOME. WE WERE ABLE TO WORK
WITH THE FAMILY. WE WERE ABLE TO
WORK WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT. AND
THIS MAN NOW LIVES AT HOME WITH
HIS SON IN A HEALTHY ENVIRONMENT
. THIS IS WHAT OMBUDSMEN DO. AND
IF WE'RE NOT IN THOSE FACILITIES
, I CAN DO THIS ALL DAY. IF WE
HAVE GREAT STORIES, AND WE NEED
THE FUNDING TO DO SO. AND THANK
YOU AND FOR HIGH CAP
MODERNIZATION. I SURE WOULD LIKE
TO SEE SOME MODERNIZATION. I'M
NOT SURE WHAT'S HAPPENING. BUT
WHEN I GET A CALL, I TALK TO
SOMEONE FOR FIVE MINUTES. IT
TAKES ME 15 MINUTES TO GET THAT
DATA INPUT INTO THE SOFTWARE.
PLEASE FIX IT. THANK YOU FOR
WHAT YOU DO. GOOD AFTERNOON. UH,
MY NAME IS JACQUELINE FLORES.
I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
ADVOCATES FOR NURSING HOME
REFORM OR CANNER IN SUPPORT OF
THE BUDGET REQUEST FOR
CALIFORNIA'S LONG TERM CARE
OMBUDSMAN PROGRAMS FOR OVER 40
YEARS, KOR HAS ADVOCATED TO
IMPROVE QUALITY OF CARE AND LIFE
FOR LONG TERM CARE FACILITY.
RESIDENTS AND OMBUDSMEN HAVE
BEEN ALONGSIDE THE ENTIRE WAY.
OMBUDSMAN PROVIDE DIRECT
ADVOCACY WORK INSIDE NURSING
HOMES EVERY DAY AND SAVE THE
STATE MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
ANNUALLY BY INVESTIGATING AND
RESOLVING COMPLAINTS AND
ALLEGATIONS OF ABUSE THAT WOULD
OTHERWISE BE DELEGATED TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND REGULATORY OR
LICENSING AGENCIES. OMBUDSMAN
ADVOCATE TO UPHOLD THE RIGHTS OF
CALIFORNIA'S MOST VULNERABLE
POPULATION, AND THE FUNDING OF
THE LONG TERM CARE OMBUDSMAN
PROGRAM HAS NOT KEPT UP WITH THE
STATE'S GROWING AGING POPULATION
WITH COMPLEX HEALTH CARE NEEDS.
AS A FORMER OMBUDSMAN. I
PERSONALLY CAN ATTEST TO THE
IMPORTANCE OF FUNDING WOULD
BRING TO THE LONG TERM CARE
OMBUDSMAN PROGRAM. IT IS THE
STATE'S RESPONSIBILITY TO
PROTECT OUR OLDER, INDEPENDENT
ADULTS IN LONG TERM CARE AND
IMPROVING THIS BUDGET REQUEST
WOULD DO SO MUCH FOR A VITAL
PROGRAM. THANK YOU. PERFECT.
GOOD AFTERNOON, UH, CHAIR AND
MEMBERS RECCA MARCUS,
REPRESENTING LEADING AGE
CALIFORNIA, SPEAKING ON ITEM TWO
AS THE SPONSORS OF A B 2548 IN,
UH, 2022. WE ARE DISAPPOINTED IN
THE ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL TO
REVERT THE DOLLARS APPROPRIATED
TO THE HEALTHY HOMES PROGRAM
HEALTHIER HOMES PROGRAM. WE'RE
HOPEFUL THAT IN THE NEAR FUTURE,
THE STATE IMPLEMENTS A SIMILAR
PROGRAM THAT WOULD INTEGRATE
AFFORDABLE SENIOR HOUSING WITH
ON SITE, HEALTH AND SOCIAL
SERVICES, ALLOWING OLDER ADULTS
TO ASIAN PLACE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. HELLO. MONICA KIRKLAND,
STATE POLICY DIRECTOR FOR A
SENIOR SERVICES COALITION OF
ALAMEDA COUNTY. UM OUR ORIGINAL,
UH, RELIEF. UH WELL, LET ME
ACTUALLY JUST HEAR ABOUT S¼ S¼
èC. SO WE REPRESENT OVER
40,000. I MEAN, 40 ORGANIZATIONS
, WHICH HELPS, UH WITH HEALTH
AND ALSO SOCIAL SERVICES, AND IT
REALLY REPRESENTS ABOUT 89,000
OLDER INDIVIDUALS WITHIN ALAMEDA
COUNTY. AND UM, WE WERE
ORIGINALLY RELIEVED TO SEE THAT
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL. UH UH,
REALLY DIDN'T IMPACT THE, UH
DEPARTMENT OF AGING, BUT IT'S
KIND OF SHIFTED TO A BIT OF
CONCERN. UM JUST BASED OFF OF
THE INCREASE WITH THE CURRENT
DEFICIT, AND WITH THE, UH L A Ó
SUGGESTION TO CONSIDER, UH
PREVIOUS FUNDING THAT SUPPOSED
TO BE A ALLOCATED SO, ACTUALLY,
I'M SORRY. THE L A Ó SUGGESTION
TO CONSIDER PREVIOUSLY ALLOCATED
FUNDING OF èC Dð IS A BIT
ALARMING AND SO REALLY, WE'RE
JUST HERE TO SHARE OUR CONCERN
FOR THAT. AND TO ALSO ASK, UM,
THAT YOU GUYS WILL STAY
COMMITTED TO, UH, PROTECTING THE
FUNDS FOR DEPARTMENT OF AGING
AND FOR THE LOCAL AGING SERVICES
AND THANK YOU WHEN THE MAP WITH
RICE COMES OUT. GOOD AFTERNOON.
I'M WENDY PETERSON WITH THE
SENIOR SERVICES COALITION OF
ALAMEDA COUNTY. UM AND I'M
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF THE
PROPOSAL FOR UTILIZING RESERVES
FOR THE LONG TERM CARE OMBUDSMAN
. AS YOU HEARD, WE'RE VERY
CONCERNED THAT, UH, THE STATE
BUDGET DEFICIT IS GOING TO GROW
AND THE èC Dð. A LOCAL SERVICES
, ESPECIALLY ARE GOING TO BE
TARGETED IN THE MAY REVISE. UM,
BUT THE PROPOSAL FOR THE LONG
TERM CARE OMBUDSMAN DOES NOT.
ASK FOR NEW FUNDING, SO WE'RE IN
SUPPORT OF IT. THANKS. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. GOOD AFTERNOON. MADAM
CHAIR AND SENATORS. THANK YOU
FOR HEARING US TODAY. JANICE
ROBERTS. I AM THE DIRECTOR OF
MERCY BROWN BAG PROGRAM IN
OAKLAND. UM, WE SERVE ALL OF
ALAMEDA COUNTY WITH, UH, FRESH,
NUTRITIOUS GROCERIES TWICE A
MONTH TO 8600 LOW INCOME
SENIORS. THE AAA AND ALAMEDA
COUNTY AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
AGING IS IN FACT, OUR LARGEST
FUNDER. AND THEY MAY NOT NOT NOT
EVEN KNOW THAT. AND I WAS THE
GRATEFUL RECIPIENT LAST WEEK OF
A BRAND NEW, BEAUTIFUL,
REFRIGERATED TRUCK. THAT ARRIVED
BECAUSE OUR OLD REFRIGERATED
TRUCK WHERE WE CARRY FOOD TO
THOSE 8600 SENIORS TWICE A
MONTH. WAS NÓ LONGER LEGAL ON
CALIFORNIA HIGHWAYS. IT TOOK US
TWO YEARS TO GET THAT TRUCK.
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE TO WRAP UP,
MA'AM. THANK YOU. BUT I, I DID
ACTUALLY WANT TO SAY THAT I'M
HERE TO SUPPORT THE CONTINUED
FUNDS FOR THAT PROGRAM. WE ARE
AN EXISTING PROGRAM. WE ARE NOT
BRAND NEW. AFTERNOON ELISE
BREMMER I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE OMBUDSMAN
PROGRAM FOR SAN MATEO COUNTY. UM
IN SAN MATEO COUNTY. WE
REPRESENT 420 FACILITIES AND
NEARLY 10,000 RESIDENTS. WE
RESPOND TO ABOUT 1200 CASES PER
YEAR AND APPROXIMATELY 700 CASES
OF ABUSE. IN THE RECENT YEARS,
CASES HAVE BECOME MORE COMPLEX
AND TIME CONSUMING AND DEMANDS
ARE INCREASING. DESPITE THE
PROGRAM BEING FEDERALLY MANDATED
. OUR STATE FUNDING CURRENTLY
COVERS LESS THAN HALF OF COSTS
ARE LABOR COSTS, AND WE SPEND A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF OUR TIME
PIECE MAILING FUNDING FROM
SOURCES SUCH AS CITIES FOR AS
LITTLE AS FIVE. DOLLARS WE HOPE
YOU WILL CONSIDER THIS
ADDITIONAL FUNDING SO WE CAN
SPEND 100% OF OUR TIME
FULFILLING OUR MISSION. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
COMBATANT LISA COLEMAN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA COMMISSION ON AGING.
UM I DO NOT. UM, I DO NOT WANT
TO HAVE YOUR JOB. I DO NOT WANT
TO HAVE TO FIGURE OUT WHAT
THINGS WE CAN SPEND MONEY ON.
BUT I CAN SAY I WAS HERE IN 2009
AND THE AGING PROGRAMS TOOK SUCH
A SIGNIFICANT HIT. IT TOOK SO
LONG TO GET US BACK AND THE
THING I WANT TO POINT OUT WE
DON'T HAVE THE TIME TO GET IT
BACK IN SIX YEARS, THE OLDEST
BABY BOOMERS WILL BE 8585 IS THE
YEAR IN WHICH WE UTILIZE THE
MOST LONG TERM SERVICE. IS AT
THE AT THE GREATEST EXPENSE. SO
I JUST URGE YOU AS WE CONSIDER.
PLEASE CONTINUE TO INVEST IN
WHAT'S WORKING, AND THE
OMBUDSMAN PROGRAM IS CERTAINLY
ONE OF THOSE WITH THE COMMISSION
ON AGING AND I, ALSO AS A BOARD
MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA ELDER
JUSTICE COALITION, STANDING IN
SUPPORT, THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON SENATORS YASMIN PELLET
ON BEHALF OF JUSTICE AND AGING
IN SUPPORT OF THE LOCAL THINK
èC Dð AND THE LEGISLATURE FOR
THE ONGOING WORK ON IMPLEMENTING
THE MASTER PLAN FOR AGING. IT'S
BEEN, UH, A LONG TIME COMING A
LOT OF INVESTMENTS AND LIKE THE
PEOPLE AHEAD OF ME, SAID AGING
SERVICES HAVE HISTORICALLY BEEN
SO UNDERFUNDED AND WERE
SIGNIFICANTLY CUT IN THE LAST
RECESSION AND SO JUST COMING
BACK FROM THAT, AND SO THE SLOW
RAMP UP OF SOME OF THESE THINGS
IS BECAUSE OF A HISTORICAL UNDER
INVESTMENTS AND SO TO
POTENTIALLY BE IN A SITUATION
WHERE WE'RE HAVING TO CUT AGAIN.
UM JUST FURTHER SETS US BACK.
AND LIKE, UM, LISA JUST
MENTIONED WE'RE RUNNING AGAINST
THE CLOCK HERE. AND SO WE JUST,
UM REQUEST THAT YOU TAKE THAT
INTO ACCOUNT AS YOU'RE MAKING
THESE VERY DIFFICULT BUDGET
DECISIONS THIS YEAR. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. DEFINITELY
TAKING ALL OF THAT INTO ACCOUNT
AS WE DO MAKE THOSE TOUGH
DECISIONS. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THOSE WHO TOOK THE TIME, UM TO
COME UP AND GIVE YOUR PUBLIC
COMMENT AND STAY THROUGHOUT THIS
TIME WITH US. UM WE LOOK FORWARD
TO HAVE YOU BACK NEXT WEEK. WITH
THAT BUDGET SUBCOMITTEE, NUMBER
THREE ON HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES IS ADJOINED.